Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freak Show.
Pünktlich 10 Minuten, 15 Minuten zu spät.
Alle relevanten Shows früher begannen immer 20.15 Uhr.
Oh, du meinst wir sind das Abendprogramm?
Mindestens auf Wetten-das-Niveau.
Nachrichten sind jetzt schon durch. Haben wir nicht sozusagen.
Wir haben im Riesen keine News vor hier.
Da würde ich mich auch nicht auf die Freakshow verlassen. Was mache ich?
Raus. Hier wird immer sehr gewissenhaft berichtet.
Ja, ja, ja, das merkt man an den Kommentaren.
Okay, hallo Leute hier, ich bin's Tim, Tim Rittler, das ist die Freakshow,
ihr habt's schon mitbekommen. Ausgabe Nummer 308 steht an, wir schreiben den 28.
Mai 2026 und der Sommer ist da und wir auch.
Ralf ist auch da.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Noch nicht Sommerlicht, noch nicht in einem casual.
Ich bin hier in meinem Kurzarmhemd.
Das ist dann schon casual, aber immer noch Businessblau.
Ja, ich hatte heute Termine in der Senatsverwaltung für Finanzen.
Da trägt man besser ein blaues Hemd.
Da trägt man besser blau. Ich war der Einzige.
Der ein blaues Hemd anhatte.
Hast du auch am meisten Geld bekommen. War die Selbstverleugnung dann nicht ausreichend?
Das müssen wir offen lassen.
Details später.
Details später, wenn sie bekannt sind. Roddy im Casual Black.
Ja, das ist das schwarze T-Shirt, was ich immer zur Arbeit anziehe.
Ach echt, immer so generisch, einfach schwarz.
Ja, unbeschriftet schwarz, das mache ich eigentlich seit einigen Jahren so.
Weil das irgendwie ein guter Kompromiss ist zwischen halbwegs ordentlich angezogen
und nicht rumrennen wie jemand mit einem blauen Hemd.
Und ist es schon mal vorgekommen, dass du kein schwarzes T-Shirt anhattest ohne Schrift?
Ähm...
Bestimmt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wenn du mal was anderes anhattest,
dass die Leute sich dann gar nicht finden. Weil sie sich so daran gewöhnt haben.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, darauf angesprochen worden zu sein.
Aber ich meine, beschriftete T-Shirts sind bei mir ja auch viel zu viele Schwarze dabei.
In den letzten Jahren versuche ich auch andere Farben zu kaufen, ganz bewusst.
Welche denn? Und dieses Unkeglau, Anthrazit und Schleingrau.
Nein, also ich weiß, da kann man jetzt diskutieren drüber, aber alle Töne aus
dem Grauspektrum sind für mich keine Farbe in dem Sinne.
Ja, sondern?
Naja, sowas wie Blau oder Rot oder Grün oder Gelb oder so. Meinetwegen auch Beige.
Also ich habe jetzt auch festgestellt, letztes Wochenende war ja relativ warm,
da hätte es sich dann auch gut getan, ein sehr helles T-Shirt anzuziehen,
weil die Sonne nochmal zusätzlich drauf gebrannt hat, aber ja.
Ich empfehle Kurzarmhemden.
T-Shirts sind kurzarm.
Naja, aber vom Stoff her ist das doch einfach Mist.
Also ich schwitze halt einfach sehr schnell im Sommer und Hemden sind einfach
viel robuster als T-Shirts.
Das ist aber eine Frage, des Materials, nicht des Schnitz.
Ja, aber ich finde es ist einfacher, irgendwie ein wertiges Kurzarmshirt zu
finden, auch im Sale, als ein wirklich gutes T-Shirt zu den Tippen.
Du verwechselst aber jetzt im Lightmeat. Du vermischst Dinge.
Das eine ist ja, man will nicht schwitzen sinnlos oder irgendwie,
das soll nicht schnell durchgestunken sein.
Du willst eine Faser haben, die das halt schnell irgendwie...
Du redest wahrscheinlich mehr von Passform und wie es so rüberkommt?
Auch, aber vor allen Dingen wie halt Schweiß abgeleitet wird.
Also wie schnell das dann ins Gewebe reingeht, wieder verdunstet,
Kühlwirkung herstellt.
Aus welchem Material ist denn dein Kurzarmhemd?
Das weiß ich nicht. Das ist auf jeden Fall von der deutschen Traditionsfirma
Eterna, die jetzt hier Konkurs gegangen ist.
Du warst der einzige Kunde.
Bei dem Namen genau mein Humor, muss ich sagen.
Das hat ja super funktioniert.
Das ist schon ein bisschen tragisch, weil das sind beispielsweise die,
die das bügelfreie Hemd erfunden haben.
In den 60ern, 70ern. Ungefähr so um den Dreh.
Und das war eine der Hemdenfirmen, die also doch immer relativ viel in Forschung
und Entwicklung investiert haben.
Nach dem Motto so, wir müssen einfach die Fasern weiter optimieren.
Was hat es denn bügelfrei gemacht?
Das war eine besondere, also ich habe mich irgendwann mal ein,
zwei Stunden eingelesen in das Thema, aber es ist schon lange her.
Das heißt also jetzt ganz gefährliches Halbwissen.
Ja, das passt ja perfekt zu dieser Sender.
Ne, es ist also der, man wundert sich, mit welchem Aufwand die einzelnen Fasern,
aus denen hinterher ein Stoff gewebt wird, veredelt werden, gerade im Hemdenbereich.
Was das also für verschiedene Schritte sind und mit was für chemisch-physikalischen
Tricks dort gearbeitet wird, aber auch schon lange. Ja, wie gesagt,
bei den 60ern wären sie damit losgegangen.
So Leute, ihr braucht keine Hemden mehr bügeln. Und das haben sie ja eingelöst, das Versprechen.
Ich habe das irgendwie von meinem Papa übernommen. Der hatte auch immer irgendwie
eterna Hemden und wie das dann manchmal so ist.
Man muss ja nicht alles, was die Eltern machen, in Frage stellen.
Und ich habe seit meines Lebens noch kein Hemd gebügelt.
Als bügelfrei werden Kleidungsstücke beworben, deren Gewerbe mit Fasern aus
Kunststoff ummantelt oder mit einer Apertur versehen wurde.
Der Tragekomfort kann durch die resultierende Steifigkeit vermindert sein.
Das würde ich nicht behaupten wollen. Also kann, dann hast du halt irgendwelche Below-Geschichten.
Okay, jetzt ist die Frage, was ist mit Apertur? Also Kunststoffummantelung finde
ich ja jetzt mal völlig falsch.
Apertur. Was wird denn da appreiziert?
Es ist eine Plastikbeschichtung, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich lese gerade hier industrielle Aperturverfahren.
Kolorierung. Blablabla. Unklar. Chemische Apertur.
Auf jeden Fall wird da irgendwas mitgemacht. Was ich in dem Zusammenhang aber
empfehlen kann, vielleicht mal so für den Casual Friday, ist einfach Leinenhemden zu nehmen,
die auch sehr gut sich verhalten, was die Beschweißung betrifft.
Ja, habe ich ein oder zwei im Repertoire, kommen nicht so häufig zum Einsatz.
Ich könnte aber gar nicht genau sagen, warum.
Könnte ich mal wieder raussuchen, jetzt wo du es sagst.
Oder nach, in Office Space gab es ja dann diesen Hawaiian Shirt Day.
Vielleicht wäre das ja auch mal was für dich.
Ja, also dieses Hemd, was ich gerade trage, ist wirklich hellblau und sehr langweilig.
Ich kann mal ein Bild davon in die Shownotes setzen.
Normalerweise bin ich so seit zwei, drei Jahren eigentlich eher Typ exzentrische,
gerne florale, aber auch andere asymmetrische, asymmetrische Muster.
Das ist eigentlich eher so mein Markenzeichen, was so meinen Hemdenstil angeht.
Das ist wirklich sehr langweilig.
Das ist sehr businessy. Aber es sei dir verziehen. Ich war gerade auf einer recht,
Vorsichtigseidende Formulierung auf einer Veranstaltung, auf der es sehr locker
zuging und dann wurde ich tatsächlich von einer potenziellen Teilnehmerin gefragt,
wie denn da der Dresscode sei.
Und ich muss sagen, Dresscode ist etwas, was mich generell in meinem Leben selten
beschäftigt. Also da habe ich.
Vielleicht sollte es dich öfter beschäftigen.
Vielleicht sollte es mich öfter beschäftigen, aber tatsächlich tangiert es mich wirklich selten.
Ab und zu, natürlich muss man schon mal sich Gedanken darüber machen,
was man anzieht, aber es ist meistens mehr durch das Wetter geprägt als durch irgendetwas anderes.
Auf jeden Fall haben wir eine Antwort, casual punk. Und ich finde,
casual punk ist generell ein ganz guter Kleidungsstil.
Also nicht so Punk-Punk, aber casual.
Casual-Punk, also nicht ganz so streng-Punk.
Ja, casual halt.
Make what you want of it.
Bevor irgendwelche Gerüchte aufkommen, ich habe keinerlei Dresscode,
dem ich mich unterworfen sehe.
Ich kann in meiner Bibliothek einfach anziehen, was ich will.
Was mit den Hemmnissen ist, ist da wirklich einfach nur so ein Bequemlichkeitsding.
Wo ich eine persönliche Grenze habe, ist in der Tat auf der Arbeit kurze Hose.
das finde ich geht nicht. Da kommt der fast Italiener in mir durch.
Das würde ich nicht machen, aber das ist auch eigentlich das Einzige,
was ich nicht machen würde. Ansonsten habe ich auch schon diverseste Nerd-Shirts
dort zur Schau getragen.
Im Sommer natürlich auch ein Problem. Lange Hosen, also so Jeans können dann
sehr unangenehm sein, wenn es zu heiß ist.
Da könnte dann auch wieder die Leinenhose zum Einsatz kommen, ja.
Ja, da habe ich auch so ein paar Chinos, die so in unterschiedlichen Dickegraden.
Ich meine, das gemeine Nerdtum und Klamotten, das ist ja eh nochmal so ein Thema für sich.
Weil man ja eigentlich so als Nerd würde mal sagen,
Zu 95 bis 97 Prozent ist die Wahl der Klamotte eine reine Funktionsfrage.
Also der Nerd denkt ja selten darüber nach, wie das so nach außen wirkt,
würde ich jetzt mal so unterstellen.
Wir können über die Prozentzahl auch noch ein bisschen diskutieren,
wenn ihr möchtet, aber ihr wisst schon, was ich meine. Also primär funktionsorientiert.
Und Funktionskleidung, ich meine, es gibt ja zum Beispiel in der,
auch so im CCC, so wenn man auf dem Kongress so rumläuft, gibt es ja diese totalen
Ultras von nachher, wie heißt es noch gleich die Firma, was da alle tragen?
Der deutsche Arbeits... Genau, Engelbert Strauß.
Engelbert Strauß Ultras.
Ich hab da auch Merch von. Merch oder Produkte?
Wie beides.
Aha.
Man kann nämlich, wenn man das will, sich von Engelbert Strauß was besticken lassen?
Und ab einem bestimmten Volumen der Bestellung geht es dann relativ gut.
Und das Voidcamp macht eigentlich auch jedes Jahr Merch-Bestellungen und die
sind immer von Engelbert Strauß.
Und dann kann man aus dem Gesamtkatalog, aber aus einer großen Menge von Dingen,
kann man sich dann was aussuchen und man bekommt dann das Voidcamp-Logo draufgestickt.
Okay, wir reden hier von sogenannter Arbeitskleidung.
Ja, wobei Engelbert Strauß, also du bist mit dem Engelbert Strauß Phänomen überhaupt nicht vertraut?
Das hat mich bisher überhaupt nicht erreicht, aber ich sehe gerade worum es geht in der Sache.
Genau und das Besondere an Engelbert Strauß ist, dass sie eigentlich die einzige
Arbeitsklamottenfirma sind, die tatsächlich so einen Fashion Appeal zu haben scheinen.
Oder zumindest versucht.
Ja, aber sie sind da sehr erfolgreich. Also du kannst dann diese Arbeitshosen,
die gibt es dann nicht nur in einer Farbe, sondern die gibt es dann hier in blau schwarz,
also schwarz-blau, schwarz-grün, blau-rot, also in allen Formen, Farben und...
Selbst Warnwesten. Ach, Warnwesten.
Oder Warnjacken.
Warnweste schwarz.
Ich hab da neulich, also man braucht ja in einem Auto braucht man ja eine Warnweste,
das ist ja vorgeschrieben.
Da habe ich also irgendwann mal beim großen A so ein Fünferpack gekauft und
hatte die irgendwie drei Monate und dann kam der Rückruf, stellt sich raus, die warnen nicht genug.
Hat irgendein Luxemburger Unternehmen festgestellt, nee,
die müssen vom Markt genommen werden und dann habe ich da halt die wieder eingesammelt
und andere bestellt und die warnen auch deutlich besser und dann habe ich bei
Strauß geguckt, was es da an Warn-Dingen gibt.
Und da gibt es wirklich schöne Warnjacken. Also sie sind wirklich schön.
Wenn man jetzt mit sowas rumlaufen will oder muss, öfter den ganzen Tag.
Direkteinstickung, Tatsache. Man kann sich wirklich die Klamotte dann gleich besticken lassen.
Das ist ja cool.
Also ich konnte bisher dem noch widerstehen.
Ich besitze kein einziges Engelbert Strauß Produkt.
Trotzdem habe ich das immer mit einer gewissen, wie soll ich sagen?
Ein Wohlwollen.
Wohlwollen, naja,
Respekt trifft es auch noch nicht so ganz anerkennend aus der Ferne beobachtet,
dass es ihnen durchaus gelingt, in diesem Segment was abzuliefern,
was offensichtlich gut funktioniert und auch jetzt nicht total scheiße aussieht.
Also das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht Laufstegware, aber dafür,
für das, was es ist, ist es auf jeden Fall fashionable.
Also jetzt nicht jedes einzelne Teil, da ist natürlich viel auch wirklich,
naja, einfach wirklich auch nur Funktionskleidung, aber gibt da halt auch so ein paar nette Sachen.
Was ich empfehlen kann, ist der Ledergürtel. Es gibt von Engelbert Strauß einen
Ledergürtel, der sieht aus wie ein normaler Ledergürtel in relativ breit,
wirklich gut und kostet dafür, dass es wirklich echtes Leder ist und einfach
qualitativ hochwertiges Zeug, einfach mal quasi nichts.
Also das ist das.
Und was ich auch sehr interessant finde, wenn du bei Engelbert Strauß tatsächlich
bestellst im Internet, wie man das so bei einem Internetshop macht und direkt bezahlt,
ungelogen, dann rechnen sie einem Skonto runter.
Haben die denn auch einen Ratschengürtel?
Wenn du direkt per Vorkasse bezahlst, rechnen sie dir zwei oder wie viel Prozent, das sind Skonto.
Wirklich?
Runter von deiner Bestellung. Finde ich völlig absurd. Wann hast du das letzte Mal Skonto bekommen?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber was war jetzt so toll an dem Gürtel? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Es ist einfach ein guter Ledergürtel, der einfach auch gar nicht so teuer ist.
Okay, aber da gibt es ja auch verschiedene im Angebot.
Ja, es gibt verschiedene.
Meinst du jetzt alle oder einen bestimmten?
Ohne das jetzt zu sehen, ich meine, du kannst mal gucken.
Ja.
Klassische Schnalle sozusagen.
Einfach ein ganz klassischer Ledergürtel, der nicht weiter auffällt,
aber einfach ein guter Gürtel ist.
Stretch oder nicht Stretch? Nicht Leder.
Ein längliches Stück gegerbtes Leder.
Ohne Löcher.
Mit Löchern.
Also ich meine Löcher durchgehend im ganzen Gürtel?
Nee, nur da, wo man es üblicherweise hat am Ende.
Ja, ich bin Zielgruppe, weil ihr erinnert euch, vor einem Jahr habe ich mal
mein Ratschgürtelset vorgestellt in der Weihnachtsfolge, was man noch so alles kaufen kann.
Und da hatten wir den Punkt, dass ein und dasselbe Modell von irgendwie 40 verschiedenen
China-Anbietern angeboten wurde, wenn das relativ egal ist.
Die gehen ganz schön schnell kaputt.
Also sprich, das ist irgendwie billigst Spaltleder. Und der eigentliche Ratschenmechanismus,
dieses Reinzahn, Reihenzahn, das ist gut und solide, aber die Schnalle selber blättert ab.
Das geht noch, aber nicht so richtig gut anzusehen.
Und das Leder in Anführungszeichen selber ist wirklich totaler Mist.
Das hat also wirklich kein Jahr gehalten.
Und jetzt suche ich also dasselbe Prinzip mal in Wertiger.
Jetzt war bei Engelbert Strauß gekauft.
Ja, ich gucke schon.
Wird auch in Deutschland produziert.
Die haben Ratsche, aber das ist dann mit Stoff. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es soweit schon.
Also die ganzen Engelbert-Strauß-Sachen wirken sehr wertig und sind dafür,
wie wertig sie eigentlich sind, jetzt auch nicht so teuer.
Es sind halt auch wirklich Arbeitsklamotten, das ist so Zeug,
wo du halt auf den Bau mitgehen kannst, weil dafür sind sie gemacht.
Also klar, es gibt in diesem Chaosumfeld die Leute, die dann die großen Sachen
bauen und wieder abbauen, die haben halt alle dieses Engelbert Strauß Zeug, das gehört halt dazu.
Genau, das ist auch das, was mich so ein bisschen davon fernhält.
Naja, ins Konzert würde ich damit auch nicht gehen, obwohl das mal spannend wäre.
Wobei so eine Arbeitsshort für den Sommer, wenn man draußen am Werkeln ist, das ist in der Tat ganz….
Unglaublich viele Taschen und du kannst dann halt auch noch so Gürtelzeug mit
Taschen ranhängen und so weiter.
Mit Flexbelt den Bund, auch für, wenn man fett ist und gerade viel gegessen hat, dann passt es auch.
Genau, und das ist natürlich das Ding, was Nerds interessiert,
Taschen, Reißverschlüsse, Sachen, wo man Kram reinstecken kann,
wo man sein Telefon versenken kann, Werkzeuge ranklippen kann, etc. pp.
Naja, also vielleicht ja was für dich, Ralf, als Alternative zum blauen Hemd.
Oder in Kombination mit dem blauen Hemd.
Ich habe übrigens Thema Fashion, wenn wir irgendwann doch nochmal eine Live-Show
machen, Bühne und so, da könnt ihr euch schon mal darauf mental vorbereiten.
Da habe ich dann ein Live-Reveal von der perfekten Art, wie man Nerd-T-Shirts zusammenfaltet.
Mit einem kompletten Ideologie und einem Mindset dahinter.
Diesen Tagesordnungspunkt schiebe ich jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren vor mir her
so. Aber in der Sendung selber klappt das nicht, weil man muss es glaube ich wirklich live sehen.
Da müssen wir wohl mal eine Live-Sendung machen.
Da müssen wir wohl mal eine Live-Sendung.
So, ihr werdet... Von dem Tag an werdet ihr eure T-Shirts nicht mehr anders
zusammenlegen und verstauen wollen.
Tja, jetzt wollen natürlich alle Kinder wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Tja, so ist das mit den Spoilern.
So ist das mit den Spoilern. Gut, Klamottenfrage weitgehend geregelt. ähm,
Ja, jetzt machen wir uns bereit für den Sommer. Also ich zumindest.
Wollen wir erstmal das Feedback abarbeiten, weil du hast ja auch welches bekommen, wir alle.
Aber ganz viel kam zu deiner 3D-Druckerei.
Genau, da gab es im Wesentlichen zwei Themen.
Das eine, ganz viele unterschiedliche Hinweise, was man so an Einsteiger-Software
sich mal angucken sollte, auch und gerade mit Kindern, das war ja so einer der
nächsten Level, die ich da mal angehen würde,
bin ich jetzt überhaupt noch nicht dazu gekommen, in den letzten Wochen mir
das anzuschauen, aber das ist trotzdem alles wertvoll und es ist alles gespeichert
und wird irgendwann von mir abgearbeitet und dann kann ich das auch nochmal
besprechen, wenn ich es dann probiert habe.
Und die zweite Ebene war, dass ich dann ja so ein bisschen die These aufgestellt
habe, ja, das ist schon alles super mit dem 3D-Druck, so lange wie es funktioniert
und wenn es nicht mehr funktioniert, dann ist es aber auch ganz schön asig.
Und da gab es eine unfassbar breite Welle an Rückkopplung von You're Holding It Wrong.
Ist mir noch nie passiert.
Mir überhaupt noch nie passiert.
Bis zu You Bought Crap.
Wäre so erstaunlich, dass du es ohne
Gefrierttrockner überhaupt jemals zu irgendeinem Print geschafft hast.
Du kommst auch auf die Idee, dass du, wenn du Filament kaufst,
das direkt irgendwo reinspannen könntest, du Honk.
Was mich aber, weil es ist wirklich, es ist jetzt gar nicht böse gemeint von
mir, ich habe das total wertgeschätzt, aber wenn ihr euch das jetzt im Nachklapp
mal wirklich diese Sektion komplett durchlest, dann seht ihr,
dass die Spanne dessen, was dort sein könnte oder angeblich ist oder angeblich
mit Sicherheit überhaupt nicht ist wirklich exakt von 0 bis 100 macht ihr überhaupt
keinen Kopf es funktioniert immer,
bis hin zu nein, eigentlich ist es physikalisch chemisch unmöglich,
dass irgendjemand jemals einen 3D-Druck gemacht hat.
Dazwischen ist wirklich komplett das Spektrum vertreten. Auch von der Quantität
her komplett vertreten.
Was mich in meiner Grundthese bestärkt, dass es Fledermausland ist und eben
du eine Menge Abhängigkeiten doch in alle möglichen Richtungen hast und damit
muss man dann halt irgendwie leben und muss da glaube ich seinen eigenen Weg finden.
Also danke für das viele Feedback dazu, aber es fiel mir schwer,
da jetzt irgendwo einen Mainstream rauszupicken.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich war beim kurzen Durchgucken auch erstaunt.
Irgendjemand schrieb, dass du dir möglicherweise eine Gurke hast andrehen lassen
und dass das eigentlich nicht sein kann, dass der so überhaupt gar nicht funktioniert?
Er funktioniert ja. Ich habe damit ja erfolgreich Dinge schon gedruckt.
Und nachdem einmal die Platte ordentlich gereinigt war, auch mit irgendwie normaler
Seife, funktioniert der seitdem eigentlich einigermaßen reproduzierbar.
Ich glaube, die Dinge, die damit bei mir derzeit dann nicht funktionieren,
da liegt es auch einfach mal am Modell und an dem Splicing, dass das einfach
nicht wirklich gut auf diesem Mini hin optimiert ist.
Und da müsste man dann eben doch irgendwo ein paar Parameter verstellen.
Und so tief bin ich da jetzt noch nicht drin, weil es sind wirklich viele Parameter.
Aber es gab zum Beispiel auch so einen Tipp, der häufiger kam,
den ich dann glaube ich mal nächstes Mal probieren werde, ist,
naja, gerade bei dieser ersten Schicht, die du da druckst,
kannst du die Option einstellen in der Software, dass drumherum nochmal so eine
Stabilisierungsschicht auch mit so einem Rand aufgetragen wird.
Ja, es ist immer nervig den Rand hinterher abzumachen. Aber das hilft.
Dann verrutscht es nämlich auch nicht so stark in den höheren Ebenen,
wo er dann plötzlich irgendwie sich selber umschmeißt und sowas.
Also das fand ich zum Beispiel total nachvollziehbar.
Und das ist ein Klick in der Software. Das ist dann, wenn es Probleme gibt,
würde ich das beispielsweise machen.
Naja, wie gesagt, was ich immer mache ist Waschbenzin. Also nachdem ich ewig
nach Isopropylalkohol gesucht habe und den einfach nicht gefunden habe irgendwo,
also man kann ihn bestimmt online bestellen.
Und ich aber noch eine Flasche Waschbenzin rumstehen hatte, habe ich es halt
damit mal geprobiert und bin damit seitdem eigentlich nur noch unterwegs und
zufrieden. Also das ist so.
Tim scrollt immer noch über die Hosen.
Rennen immer weiter, lass euch nicht.
Ich glaube, im Wesentlichen, was man halt wissen muss, ist, wenn du da,
sagen wir mal, Fettfingerabdrücke auf der Platte hast, dann hält es halt nicht.
Und die musst du irgendwie runtergewaschen kriegen.
Und Waschbenzin ist vielleicht so ein bisschen auf der aggressiveren Seite,
was so Fettlösen anbelangt.
Aber es funktioniert bei mir ohne Probleme.
Also ab und zu löst sich mal was, aber ja.
Ich habe aber jetzt seit der letzten Sendung exakt gar nichts mehr gedruckt,
von daher, wenn ich irgendwann mal wieder ein echtes Leben habe,
dann kann ich da wieder aufholen.
Dann werden wir in der Saga neue Episoden hören.
Ja, die letzten Wochen waren ein bisschen heftig, da muss ich jetzt erstmal runterkommen.
Diese 3D-Druckerei ist schon, also ich hatte jetzt lange, lange Zeit,
eigentlich immer noch, denke ich mir immer so, wann brauche ich das schon mal?
Also ich hatte bisher noch nie so diesen Urge mit, ich muss mir jetzt irgendwas
machen und ich hatte ja glaube ich neulich mal darüber berichtet,
dass ich dann immer so einen Plastikteil, da war es mir dann auch ausreichend,
mir von jemandem helfen zu lassen,
da kommt man mal irgendwo vorbei und dann kennt man mal jemanden und so.
Wobei das war dann auch schon privilegiert, hier in Berlin da gleich die passenden
Nerds zu kennen oder zumindest schnell kennenzulernen, die einem da weiterhelfen können.
So als Servicebüro habe ich das so noch nicht gesehen.
Also es gibt jetzt nicht Firmen oder so, wo man hingeht mit,
Sie suchen irgendein Plastikteil, lassen Sie sich das hier mal schnell.
Tim, das erzählst du mir jetzt. Warum gehst du nicht in die Bibliothek deines
Vertrauens in Berlin und suchst dort einen Makerspace mit 3D-Drucker auf?
Und dann?
Wo die Leute sich einmal die Woche treffen in ihren 3D-Druck-Communities und
da wird ihr geholfen. Das ist quasi wie ein Hackspace.
Nur for the rest of us. Einmal die Woche, ich meine jetzt so richtig mit Geld bezahlen.
Nee, es gibt Dienstleister in Berlin. Doch, hatte ich irgendwann vor drei Jahren
oder sowas schon mal gesucht. Aber die sind dann ganz schön teuer.
Das tut dann schon so ein bisschen weh.
Naja gut, ich meine, du sitzt halt, je nachdem wie komplex das Teil ist,
halt auch schon eine Stunde bis drei Stunden dran, bis du das richtig modelliert
hast, wenn du das ordentlich machen willst und so weiter.
Und dann muss noch gedruckt werden. Also da, ja klar, die Leute wollen es ja
dann auch nicht als Hobby machen, sondern davon leben.
Ja, das ist auch legitim.
Und dann wird es halt entsprechend teuer. Handwerkerstunde kostet ja auch schon ewig viel.
Tja. Da muss dann die KI wieder ran.
Gut.
Feedback. Was haben wir noch? Dann gab es hier Rückmeldungen zu unserer Diskussion über Vehicle to Grid.
Ja.
Und darüber, ob man das nun machen möchte oder nicht. Carsten schreibt,
der ultimative Durchbruch bei den Erneuerbaren sind Batteriespeicher und bidirektionales Laden.
Die Niederlande gehören zu den weltweit führenden Ländern beim bidirektionalen Laden.
Wenn der Strom aus Solar und Wind tagsüber nicht verbraucht werden kann,
werden damit Autos an öffentlichen und privaten Ladestationen geladen,
um den Peak abzuflachen.
Abends geben die Autos den Strom an die Haushalte zurück. In Deutschland kommt
die Technik erst ganz langsam an den Start.
Den Stand kann man ungefähr mit der Digitalisierung vor 15 Jahren vergleichen.
Wer braucht schon schnelles Internet?
Ich behalte mein DSL. Anbei bemerkt verhält es sich insgesamt mit der Energiewende
auf diese Art. Ich kämpfe seit zehn Jahren in meinem Haus dafür,
die Erneuerbaren an den Start zu bekommen und es werden mir immer wieder Steine
in den Weg gelegt, um das Ziel, einmal Autarkie erreicht zu haben, nicht zu realisieren.
Man schlägt sich mit Regelungen, Vorschriften und Behörden rum,
muss sich technisches Wissen aneignen,
um nicht über den Tisch gezogen zu werden, aber das nur am Rande.
Ja, also zu dem Thema ist ja klar, also das Problem ist halt immer,
man muss sich fragen, was will man mit diesem Vehicle-to-Grid eigentlich erreichen?
Wenn ich jetzt sagen will, ich bin ein guter Mensch und ich möchte,
dass mein Stromversorger nicht in den Netzausbau investieren muss,
deswegen stelle ich mein Auto zur Verfügung, dass es Netzausgleich macht,
dann okay, das kann ich machen.
Aber so altruistisch bin ich dann auch nicht, als dass ich halt die Zyklen,
die dann gefahren werde, einfach mal so wegstecke und sage, stört mich nicht.
Und da ist halt dieses, wir sind beim Smart Meter Rollout massiv hinter Plan
und kriegen das nicht hin.
Gleichzeitig sind wir, was Strompreiszonen anbelangt, haben wir immer noch eine
große Strompreiszone, die nicht funktioniert, weil wir nicht das Netz haben,
das das abbilden kann, dass wir hier mit einer Kupferplatte rechnen.
Und dann haben wir diese fürchterlichen Stromausgleichszahlungen.
Im Norden werden Windräder angehalten, damit die im Süden sich das leisten können,
irgendwie ein Gaskraftwerk an den Start zu bringen. Und dann zahlt man...
Im Prinzip geben wir Geld dafür aus, dass Leute keinen Strom produzieren.
Ich meine, was ist denn das?
Das ist eine Katastrophe, ist das.
Und das Ganze wird aber klar, die südlichen Länder, die wehren sich mit Händen
und Füßen, dass wir sagen, wir machen hier mal mehr Strompreiszonen,
damit man das mal besser regulieren kann.
damit man halt vorher weiß, dass unten im Süden Strom fehlt und dann kauft man
es aus Italien oder aus Frankreich oder aus Österreich oder sonst wo.
Nein, man hat im Prinzip im Norden den billigen Windstrom.
Man kriegt ihn nur nicht nach Süden und deswegen kriegt er im Norden Geld dafür,
dass er nicht produziert.
Und im Süden kriegt ein Gaskraftwerk noch mal Geld dafür, dass sie produzieren,
was man eigentlich im Norden hätte.
Und was dann auch den Preis für alle hochhält.
Was für den Preis für alle hochhält. Es ist völliger Irrsinn.
Es ist völliger Irrsinn.
Aber gut. Gut. Und im Prinzip ist natürlich ein Vehicle-to-Grid eine gewisse Möglichkeit raus.
Nur die Frage ist, wer setzt hier Geld ein, um wem welches Problem zu lösen?
Und ich glaube, da ist die Diskussion halt auch noch nirgendwo.
Letzten Endes sagen nur alle, oh, Vehicle to Grid ist so toll,
da könnte man das und das machen. Ja, kann man machen, aber wer bezahlt es denn dann?
Ja gut, also derzeit sieht es so aus, als ob die Autohersteller vorpreschen.
Das sind natürlich dann auch alles sehr markenspezifische Lösungen.
Also BMW und VW möchten jetzt gerne ihren Kunden dann auch noch gleich die bidirektionale
Wallbox und den Smart Meter und so weiter mit dem Stromtarif auch noch zusammenverkaufen.
Das ist sozusagen das Ding. Also so ein richtig offener Markt zeichnet sich
dabei jetzt auch noch nicht ab.
hier brauchst du halt erstmal Standards.
Und du kannst an der Stelle die Uhr danach stellen, die, die eigentlich daran
Geld verdienen, sind natürlich die Hersteller, die einem diese Pakete anbieten.
Ja gut, aber grundsätzlich finde ich das jetzt okay, dass man mal drüber nachdenkt,
auch wenn das jetzt noch nicht ausgereift ist, so eine Ressource,
die man sich dann kauft, also ich meine so ein Elektroauto,
generell ein Auto kostet ja schon eine Menge Holz und wenn Leute da auch noch
den Platz haben, das Ding rumstehen zu lassen, dann tun die Autos das erste
Mal was, während sie rumstehen.
Keine Frage, keine Frage.
Ganz gutes Feature.
Keine Frage, nur geht es halt schnell in dem Jahr, aber dann müssen jetzt alle Wirkel The Grid machen.
Es ist natürlich irgendwie, es ist ja immer noch mein Auto.
Also wenn ich das gekauft habe, weiß ich nicht. Also das ist so...
Egal.
So, wir reden ja heute nochmal über Elektroautos. Dann würde ich erstmal mit
dem Feedback weitermachen. Was hältst du denn davon?
Sagst du? So, Trim.
Ja, das habe ich schlecht erklärt. Das Feedback ist eindeutig,
dass ich das schlecht erklärt habe.
Aber im Prinzip habe ich all das gemeint, was die da geschrieben haben.
Soll ich es trotzdem vorlesen?
Mach das.
Daniel schreibt uns. Ja, Roddy hätte in dieser Diskussion von Wear-Leveling gesprochen.
Wear-Leveling hat damit, dass die SSD langsam werden, relativ wenig zu tun.
Das Problem ist das fehlende Trim. Also wir haben über SSDs gesprochen.
Mir ist Trim am Anfang nicht eingefallen, der Begriff. Deswegen habe ich da rumgeeilt.
Aber ich fand das hier ganz gut erklärt. Deswegen mache ich das jetzt mal,
weil für mich war das auch neu.
Also das Flash, also der Speicher auf dieser SSD, wird in zwei Schritten beschrieben.
Zuerst werden alle, also wenn
man was schreibt, zuerst werden alle Bits in einem Block auf 1 gesetzt.
Dann werden die Bits, die 0 sein sollen, auf 0 gesetzt.
Das auf 1 setzen ist langsam, das auf 0 setzen ist schnell. Wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, im Prinzip, man muss sich mal zurück erinnern, es gab mal sowas, das nannte sich EPROM.
Die Älteren unter uns werden sich erinnern. Das Zeug, was man mit UV-Licht wieder löschen konnte.
Oh ja, das habe ich früher gemacht.
Und im Prinzip ist Flash auch nur eine Weiterentwicklung des EPROMs.
Das ist die gleiche Technologie, nur man kann es eben jetzt mit Strom löschen und nicht mit UV-Licht.
Genau. Und dass das Löschen des ganzen Krams langsam ist, ja klar, das ist dann halt so.
Ja, fährt fort. Bei Trim wird der Platte gesagt, dieser Block interessiert nicht mehr.
Wenn die Platte das weiß, dann kann sie den ersten, also den langsamen Schritt
machen, wenn es ihr zeitlich in den Kram passt.
Der nächste Schreibvorgang, der auf dem Block, ist dann schneller,
weil der langsame Schritt eben schon vorab gemacht wurde.
Ohne Trim und ohne Wear-Leveling muss die SSD immer dann löschen,
wenn ein Block beschrieben werden soll.
Ohne Trim, aber mit Wear-Leveling hat die SSD ein paar Reserveblöcke,
die sie als nächstes via Leveling in den aktiven Pool mappt.
Die kann sie natürlich auch vorab löschen, aber der Reservepool ist relativ klein.
Der kann durch eine große Datei schon aufgebraucht werden und dann muss eben
doch wieder beim Schreiben gelöscht werden. Trim fügt praktisch alle vom Filesystem
ungenutzten Blöcke in diesem Pool hinzu.
Wear-Leveling verbessert primär die Lebensdauer, aber auch die Performance durch
vorgelöschte Reserveblöcke.
Trim trimmt vor allem die Performance, aber auch die Lebensdauer,
weil mehr Blöcke in den Pool kommen.
Also ich glaube, Wear-Leveling machen eigentlich alle richtigen SSDs.
Bei USB-Sticks wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher, aber was eine ordentliche
SSD ist, die macht auch Wear-Leveling. Also.
Sonst kommt diese gar nicht ins Haus hier erst.
Naja, weil die Hersteller dann auch die Lebensdauer, die sie versprechen,
nicht mal im Ansatz halten können.
Naja, die versprechen ja sonst was.
Ja, das Blaue vom Himmel zum Beispiel.
Gut, dann schrieb Apollo mehrere Dinge. Ich habe mir nur den einen Teil davon geschnappt.
das gefühlt 90% der Leute, die Elixier nutzen, das mittlerweile mit KI-Unterstützung
machen, spricht aus meiner Sicht nicht unbedingt für die Sprache.
Hintergrund, ich hatte von dieser kurzen, er hebt mal die Hand im Raum Situation
gesprochen von der Elixier-Konferenz, auf der ich war in Malaga.
Da kam das halt so hin.
Er meint, spricht nicht für die Sprache. Tim betont zwar immer wieder gerne,
dass Elixir die beste aller Programmiersprachen sei, aber die Realität sieht etwas nüchterner aus.
Sie ist für bestimmte Einsatzzwecke absolut okay, bleibt außerhalb dieser Nische
im breiten Markt aber schlicht irrelevant.
Auch weil Tim immer wieder behauptet, Elixir sei eine der besten Sprachen für
KI, halte ich für ein Gerücht, die Verbreitung geht im Vergleich praktisch gegen
null, weshalb es kaum aktuelles Lernmaterial für die Modelle gibt.
Die Sprachen, mit denen KI im Kern wirklich gut umgehen kann,
sind nach wie vor Javascript, Typescript und Python.
Also den ersten Punkt, da muss ich gleich mal einhaken, wenn er sagt,
gefühlt 90% der Leute mit KI-Unterstützung das machen,
das ist, glaube ich, relativ unabhängig von der Sprache inzwischen.
Gut, klar, es gibt Sprachen, die werden richtig schlecht unterstützt,
sondern ich glaube, das ist mehr eine Frage, wie groß ist denn mein Projekt?
Und wie groß ist meine Codebase? Je kleiner die Codebase, desto eher bist du
mit KI halt deutlich schneller, als wenn du das jetzt alles per Hand machst.
Und ich finde 90 Prozent gefühlt ist wahrscheinlich in anderen Sprachen auch schon ähnlich hoch.
Das würde ich aber mal locker genauso unterschreiben, abgesehen davon,
dass diese 90 Prozent aus diesem Raum jetzt nicht 90 Prozent auf der ganzen Welt sind.
Das ist schon mal eine sehr spezifische Zielgruppe an der Stelle,
allerdings die Leute, die es relativ gut und intensiv machen,
so sehr, dass sie sogar auf eine Programmiersprachenspezifische Zielgruppe,
Konferenz fahren in ein anderes Land. Also das ist schon nochmal ein Level von
Engagement hier in dieses Ökosystem, die jetzt nicht herkömmlich ist.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch eine Frage, was man eigentlich damit macht.
Also wenn Nvidia anfängt, mit KI-Unterstützung ihre Grafikkartentreiber zu schreiben
und dann aber irgendwie drei Treiber in Folge wieder zurücknehmen muss,
weil sie massiv Fehler eingebaut haben,
dann sagt dir das halt auch, ja, wo
ist denn der Punkt, wo ich KI sinnvoll einsetze und wo ist er eben nicht?
Oder ich meine, Elixir kommt ja aus dem Erlang-Umfeld, damit hat man mal Telefonswitches
gebaut, die, weiß ich nicht, Five-Nine-Uptime haben oder eben noch höher.
Also hat nicht nur mal gebaut, sondern baut man immer noch.
Baut man immer noch, da kommt die Sprache her. Also auch so ein Telefonswitch-Software
würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nur sehr vorsichtig mit der KI anfassen lassen.
Also lass mir mal ein bisschen auf diesen Kommentar eingehen,
weil ich glaube, ich habe den deshalb jetzt rausgenommen, weil hier auch sehr
viele Missverständnisse mit drin sind.
Also erstes Missverständnis oder der erste Punkt, wo ich es reingrätschen würde,
wie gesagt, sind diese 90%.
Bei den Leuten, die ihre Programmiersprache gut im Griff haben,
die also, sagen wir mal, engagierte Programmierer sind, die damit ihr Geld verdienen
und die da sehr viel Wissen auch darüber haben.
So viel Wissen, dass sie auch in der Lage sind, so eine Druckbetankung aus so
einer Konferenz über sich ergehen zu lassen.
auch wenn es einzelne Leute gibt, die andere Motivationen haben,
da hinzugehen, aber schon in der Regel ist das ziemlich harter Tobak und da
muss man immer schon sehr viel Basiswissen haben, um das auch wirklich gut abspeichern zu können.
Diese Leute, also das war natürlich die Diskussion überhaupt,
also AI und was macht ihr denn damit?
Und wenn du da die Erfahrung hast und wenn du da irgendwie voll engagiert bist
und du weißt auch, was du tust und du bist richtig Software-Ingenieur,
der besseren Kategorie,
oder was heißt besser, aber du machst das sozusagen beruflich, dann.
Ist es heute jetzt schon sehr leicht, sich viel helfen zu lassen,
ohne sich alles abnehmen zu lassen.
Also diese Wahrnehmung, dass jetzt mit KI programmieren bedeutet,
man würde gar nichts mehr tun und nur noch daneben sitzen und Kaffee trinken und nicht mehr denken.
es can't be further from the truth, ganz im Gegenteil ich würde sogar sagen,
dass das Mitdenken auf einmal viel mehr gefordert ist als vorher schon,
weil man sonst sehr viel Zeit damit verbringt irgendwelche Semikolonplatzierungen
zu überdenken und sich darüber Gedanken zu machen,
worum kommt bald denn dieser Scheiß jetzt hier nicht, aber man hat nicht wirklich
den Kopf im Software-Design so, das ist das eine,
Dann, Tim betont zwar immer wieder gerne, dass Elixir die beste aller Programmiersprachen
sei, aber die Realität sieht etwas nüchterner aus.
Ja, bleibt außerhalb der Nische im Breitmarkt aber schlicht irrelevant.
Das hat ja nichts mit Qualität zu tun.
Leute, wirklich, also natürlich ist das die beste Pumiersprache,
das steht ja überhaupt gar nicht mal zur Debatte,
sie ist natürlich nicht für alles geeignet das unterschreibe ich sofort,
das kann man auch relativ klar festmachen wofür sie nicht geeignet ist,
sie ist nicht geeignet für High-Performance Low-Level-System.
Software also die jetzt mehr oder weniger direkt auf der Hardware klebt oder
die, sagen wir mal, hochgradig Speicher- oder Performance-sensitive Algorithmen implementiert.
Da braucht man dann doch schon so destruktiven Kram, dass man sich irgendwie
in seinen eigenen Daten rumschreiben kann, um auf möglichst kompakten Speicherbereich
irgendwelche Ergebnisse zu erzielen.
Das war es dann aber auch schon.
In dem Moment, wo deine Software sich im Wesentlichen aber um die Orchestrierung
von Dingen kümmert Und ich würde mal meinen, das ist ein Großteil der Software,
zumindest im Backend, da sieht das schon ganz anders aus.
Was es halt auch nicht hat, es ist halt auch keine Application Development Sprache
auf den gängigen Plattformen heutzutage, weil du einfach nicht diesen transparenten
Übergang hast in die Betriebssysteme.
Das schränkt natürlich diesen Bereich ein.
Heißt aber nicht, dass die Sprache nicht toll ist.
Die ist toll, weil sie einem ein ganz anderes...
Denkmodell verschafft, wie man überhaupt Software entwickelt.
Das ist das, was ich damit ausdrücken wollte.
Dann meinte er ja noch, naja, weil es ja diese Verbreitung nicht hat,
was eine Unterstellung ist, hat sehr wohl eine bestimmte Verbreitung,
aber im Sinne von, es gibt ja nicht so viel Code davon, deswegen kann die KI nicht damit arbeiten.
Das haben wir ja neulich hier schon mal diskutiert, als wir über diesen Coding
Benchmark gesprochen haben.
Der war erstaunlich wenig Korrelat zwischen wie viel Code ist da draußen und
wie gut sind die Modelle also das hatte mich selber sehr erstaunt,
weil ich das echt dachte,
dass das ein größeres Problem ist, aber scheint es nicht zu sein insofern weiß ich nicht keine Ahnung,
also wenn der Autor von diesen Zeilen der Meinung ist das wäre doch so,
dann müsste ja noch irgendwie ein bisschen Evidenz nachzufangen.
Viele Codebeispiele heißt halt auch viele schlechte und mittelmäßige Codebeispiele.
Vor allem bei JavaScript.
Oh, aber hallo.
Ja eben, genau. Und das ist halt mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr der Punkt,
weil ich glaube, dass wir mittlerweile bei dieser, und ich will schon gar nicht
mehr nur von LLMs reden, weil LLMs sind hier die Basis, aber mittlerweile haben
wir es bei diesen Modellen ja richtig mit,
komplexeren Architekturen zu tun. Da ist Tool Use mit drin.
Ja, also Subagenten etc.
Also dadurch, wie diese Modelle zum Einsatz kommen,
Und wie gut sie trainiert sind, bewegt sich diese Interaktion schon auf einem höheren Level.
Also das ist ja nicht nur so ein reines, ich rate mal, was die nächste Silbe
ist und mal gucken, vielleicht kommt da ein laufender Codeball raus,
sondern durch diese mehrschichtige Abstraktionsgeschichte da reingekommen ist,
dadurch, dass man so große Kontext-Windows hat, dem so viel Performance und
so viel Speicher zuführt.
Da ist schon was am Werk, was eben wirklich schwieriger Begriff drüber nachdenkt,
was hierzu geschehen hat.
Da muss man sich nur das Chatprotokoll durchlesen, dann sieht man schon,
dass das tatsächlich stattfindet.
Und natürlich ist es dann einfacher mit einer Programmiersprache zu arbeiten,
die seiteneffektfrei ist zum Beispiel.
Ja, was ich glaube ich auch denke, was auch sehr stark mit rein schwingt,
ist die Tatsache, dass du einen Compiler hast.
Und die Tatsache, dass ein guter Compiler dir auch sehr genau sagt,
was du falsch gemacht hast, führt dazu, dass so eine Sprache im Prinzip oder
so ein LLM unsupervised lernen kann,
was funktioniert und was auf jeden Fall zu einem Compilerfehler führt.
Also ich muss sagen, dass ich da inzwischen auch so bin, dass ich sage,
also gut, ich arbeite jetzt nur mit Claude.
Aber da ist es halt so, dann sagt man ihm hier, mach mal das und das und das
und bei jedem Schritt bitte kompilieren und gucken, ob es auch funktioniert.
Und klar, am Anfang war das so, dass er dann immer mal wieder,
ja, der kompiliert noch nicht, mach noch ein bisschen, kompiliert immer noch
nicht, mach noch ein bisschen.
ist bei einem Projekt, wenn man dann langsam einen Rechner hat und der kompiliert
halt dann mal acht Minuten, zehn Minuten.
Eher so ärgerlich.
Eher so, ja, was mache ich denn in der Zwischenzeit? Aber vom Ergebnis her,
dass hinterher was rauskommt, was kompiliert und was dann auch einigermaßen
richtig ist, das ist nicht mehr so das Ding.
Ich hätte da eher Bedenken bei JavaScript, Skript, wo ich meine,
wir kennen alle den Wet Talk, oder? Wet, Burn All,
Burn All Programs oder All Languages, wo jemand über JavaScript spricht. Das ist unglaublich.
Das ist, glaube ich, nur zehn Minuten lang oder so.
Wir hatten es schon mal in der Sendung.
Wir hatten es, glaube ich, schon mal in der Sendung, wo er zeigt,
was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich das plus das mache und was passiert,
wenn ich das plus das mache.
Ach so, jetzt spezifisch JavaScript.
Spezifisch JavaScript und jedes Mal, wenn du JavaScript nicht kennst,
denkst du dir, sag mal, was passiert denn da? Habt ihr alle den Hut am Brennen?
Und ja, also in dem Zusammenhang, würde ich sagen,
so hat wahrscheinlich eine Sprache mit einem guten Compiler eher noch einen
Vorteil gegenüber einer reinen Skriptsprache, die halt interpretiert wird.
Und du kriegst halt irgendwann einen Backtrace, dass eine Exception geflogen
ist, statt dass du ein gutes Feedback hast.
Zumindest so auf der ersten Ebene.
Ja, und ich glaube, dass diese LLMs jetzt eine ganze Menge,
an schlechtem Sprachdesign abfangen können, weil sie einfach über so viele Edge
Cases nachdenken können, dass sie sogar mit JavaScript was auf die Kette kriegen
können und auch mit anderen Programmiersprachen.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass es nicht effizientere Gateways gibt zwischen diesem
System und dem Prozessor.
Also es ist ja immer die Frage bei der Programmierung, wo legst du die Abstraktionsgrenze.
Und wie ist die dann designed?
Das ist ja generell bei der Softwareentwicklung von Anfang an die Frage gewesen, wie abstrakt,
Quasi das, mit dem du deinen Gedanken umsetzt, das, was dann letzten Endes die
Maschine zu irgendetwas anhält, das zu tun.
Und da gibt es den Ansatz mit, ich will ganz unten sein, ich will nah an der
Maschine sein, weil ich verstehe die Maschine und dann kann ich sie auch voll
nutzen und die Performance und überhaupt und deswegen möchte ich jeden Hebel einzeln ziehen.
Das ist so die eine Variante und dann eben die, nein, das muss alles logisch,
mathematisch, nachvollziehbar, reproduzierbar sein,
die du auf der anderen Seite hast und jetzt kommen irgendwie die LLMs und finden
im Prinzip auch diese beiden Ebenen vor und es ist sehr interessant zu sehen,
mit was sie jetzt vielleicht am Ende die besseren Ergebnisse erzielen werden.
Und so oder so werden sie die Vorteile der jeweiligen Plattformen noch besser
nutzbar machen und deswegen glaube ich,
dass dann auch die abstrakten Sprachen dann weitere Vorteile davon ziehen werden.
wo wir gerade bei Programmiersprachen-Bashing sind.
Wenn ihr mal so richtig Bock habt also wenn ihr mal so zwei Stunden Zeit habt
und ihr habt wirklich nichts anderes zu tun.
Und ihr habt, sagen wir mal so von Programmierung schon mal so ein bisschen,
was mitbekommen idealerweise so auch in dieser C-Welt.
Dann empfehle ich euch einfach mal, wie nennt man denn das, wenn man sich sowas
anschaut, was aussieht wie so ein Autounfall in Zeitlupe.
Genau das. Und man kann aber nicht weggucken.
Das ist irgendwie ein Zwei-Stunden-Epos über The Worst Programming Language of All Time.
Wo wirklich zack, zack, zack ein Ding nach dem anderen erklärt wird,
warum das jetzt eine echt schlechte Idee war.
Und natürlich geht es um welche Programmiersprache?
Was ist The Worst Programming Language of All Time?
Ich würde sagen PHP, aber...
C++ natürlich.
Zwei Stunden Zerpflückung von C++. Ich habe da vorgesessen, ich dachte,
nein, das nicht auch noch.
Also da ist, vieles kennt man ja schon, aber das hat mich irgendwie wahnsinnig gemacht.
Sehr schön. Da habe ich den Antidot für. Das ist noch viel absurder.
Und zwar The true reason C++ always wins.
Da wird zwar nicht jetzt erklärt direkt, warum C++ geil ist oder nicht,
sondern einfach nur, wie es denn überhaupt dazu kommen konnte,
dass C++ so erfolgreich wurde und was New Jersey damit zu tun hat.
Also die Gute da in dem Video stellt so die Theorie auf es gab früher in den
USA gab es die zwei Blöcke Westküste,
Ostküste und während die Westküste irgendwie große Elfenbeintürme gebaut hat.
Achso von Laurie Wyatt Das ist erst vor zwei Tagen rausgekommen es wurde mir
schon mehrfach vor die Nase gehalten aber ich habe noch nichts zu gebissen.
Und auf der anderen Seite die New Jersey-Methode, mach, dass erst mal überhaupt
irgendwas funktioniert und schmeiß es raus.
Sehr witzig. Ich will damit jetzt nicht C++ verteidigt wissen,
aber es ist ein sehr interessanter Take auf das Ganze irgendwie.
Ich will auch noch ein Angebot machen. Man muss ja auch immer,
man muss ja sagen wir mal auch liefern können, wenn man irgendwas behauptet.
Und wenn ihr Interesse habt...
Ich gedenke, wenn es genug Interesse gibt, ihr könnt da euch einfach mal in
den Kommentaren vielleicht erstmal äußern.
Ich habe da jetzt kein Tool für gemacht.
Ich will einfach erstmal sehen, ob es genug Interesse gibt. dann werde ich einen,
Elixier-Einführungsabend machen, der sich gewaschen hat und danach geht keiner
Da bekommen alle Elixier eingeführt Da würde.
Ich hingehen Da würde ich auch.
Hingehen Und zwar so komplett von vorne bis hinten,
Also wenn es genug Interesse gibt Dann mach ich das auch.
Was ist denn genug Interesse? Wo willst du denn da hin?
Naja, so 10, 20 Leute.
Kann man gleich die Webseite bauen mit so einem Ladebalken, ob schon genug Leute.
Das kannst du gerne machen, das ist ja so deine Domäne.
Ralf will wieder Tokens wasten.
Wenn du das noch gebaut bekommst, bevor die Sendung veröffentlicht wird, dann...
Ach Gott, gut, gib mir zwei Minuten.
Aber die Leute müssten schon irgendwie also danach notifiziert werden können.
Das muss schon Daten sein.
Ja, ja, ich überlege gerade, worauf ich mir da gerade wieder einhandle.
Ja, das muss ich eigentlich in Elixier machen.
Hier kommt gerade die Frage auf als Webinar.
Nein.
Nee, kein Webinar, sondern vor Ort. Schön mit Laptop auf den Schoß.
Live. Wir können das dann auch gerne aufzeichnen. Keine Ahnung, aber.
Ihr müsst vor Ort kommen, ihr müsst Berlin mitnehmen als Party oder als Ärgernis.
Je nachdem, wie man das sieht. Also ich habe da auf jeden Fall auch noch ein
paar andere Elixierexperten in der Hinterhand.
Also ich stehe da nicht alleine, ich kenne da noch genug Leute,
die das dann auch entsprechend unterfüttern können.
So und dann erzähle ich euch einfach die Wahrheit.
Ich guck mal, was meine Knodron-Instanz da so hat.
Ich hab keinen Bock, jetzt nämlich ein User-Management zu schreiben.
Ich muss das ja ein Elixier machen.
Ich war eigentlich auch schon kurz davor, das zu tun, aber ich war mir gerade
über meine Hosting-Option nicht vollkommen im Klaren. Ja, mal schauen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Da hab ich wieder was gemacht.
Ja, lass uns mal bei KI dann bleiben, Ralf?
Ja.
Bezüglich?
Naja, der Papst.
Der Papst, genau.
Bist du jetzt der KI-Papst?
Zum Glück nicht. Aber ich habe eine, glaube ich, doch ganz launige Kino zu KI
gehalten, so ein Rundumschlag von mir, 40 Minuten.
Aber habe ich für die Sendung noch nicht fertig geschnitten gekriegt.
Kommt zur nächsten Sendung.
Da zitiere ich auch den Papst.
Ja, weil wir hatten den ja in der Sendung, du hattest den ja angeschleppt.
Auf Latein.
Es ist ja erstaunlich, wie viele Sprachen das auch gleich publiziert wird.
Das hatten wir in der Sendung gar nicht gesagt. Das waren irgendwie 20 Sprachen oder sowas.
Ja, die haben ja auch Kunden in der ganzen Welt.
Das macht schon auch echt Kunden, die Zielgruppen anzusprechen.
Genau, und da hatten wir so diese, ich weiß gar nicht, welchen Status das eigentlich genau hatte.
Ich glaube so im Januar oder sowas hatte er publiziert, so gefühlt vier DIN-A4-Seiten
oder sowas zu KI und Menschlichkeit und wir haben das ja sehr wohlwollend aufgenommen.
Gefühlt war das aber weniger als vier DIN-A4-Seiten.
Ja, auf jeden Fall nicht mehr.
So anderthalb bis zwei oder so.
Mag auch sein.
Egal.
So und was damals aber noch nicht klar war, zumindest mir nicht,
ist, dass das nur der erste Aufschlag, quasi der Spoiler war für eine richtige
Enzyklika, die er jetzt rausgegeben hat.
Und wer wie ich schickt er dann auch Bullen und wie der ganze Kram heißt?
Ja, ja, dann machte ich da mal nicht so drüber lustig, also wer wie ich irgendwann
mit dem Verein mal was zu tun hatte ich war immer Messdiener und alle so das ganze Programm,
dann steht es jedem Papst gut zu Gesicht so in seinem Leben mindestens mal eine
Enzyklika rauszugeben, das heißt also ein neues theologisches Grundlagenwerk,
was dann die Basis ist für weitere,
Streits, weiteres Wohlverhalten.
Diskussionen?
Naja, da es ja vom Papst kommt, ist es dann ja schon doch Ex-Kathedra.
Also so eine Enzyklika, das ist schon ein Ding.
Das überlegt sich jeder Papst sehr weislich, wann er das tut,
zu welchem Thema er das tut.
Das nimmt man nicht so auf die leichte Schulter.
Und unser neuer Papst ist ja relativ neu. Wie lange ist er jetzt im Amt?
Zwei, drei Jahre oder sowas nach Ratzinger?
Keine Ahnung.
Aus den USA hat jetzt also seine Enzyklika vorgelegt zum Thema KI.
Da ist er dann aber auch schnell.
Da ist er schnell, ja. Ich weiß, dass er da Hilfe bei hatte.
Also sprich, er hat die nicht selber geschrieben. Ich kenne...
Von was? Von Claude?
Nein. von einer Truppe, die sich intern, glaube ich, die KI-Apostel nennen.
Und ich kenne jemanden, der einen davon kennt.
So, so. Die Welt ist so klein.
Und da werde ich nochmal ein bisschen nachstochern, wie genau die Entstehungsgeschichte davon dann war.
ich sitze da quasi relativ dicht an der Primärquelle, wenn man so will.
Aber habe auch jetzt das Stück selber noch nicht gelesen.
Das habe ich Jetzt, wie gesagt, letzten Wochen waren anstrengend,
habe das für die Sendung nicht geschafft, aber ich werde es durchlesen.
Es wird gemunkelt, dass es doch ähnlich brauchbar sei, wie hier die Kurzfassung,
die wir schon mal besprochen hatten.
Dass also doch der ein oder andere schlaue Gedanke verbaut ist.
Ich traue dem das auch zu. Ich glaube, das ist eine der besseren Päpste,
die wir in den letzten Jahrzehnten, Jahrhunderten so hatten.
Im Sinne von?
Also was so intellektuelle Flughöhe angeht, die so einen gewissen Praxisbezug hat.
Also ich glaube so als Theologe beispielsweise war Ratzinger hervorragend,
hat aber natürlich irgendwie mit der Welt da draußen nichts zu tun gehabt.
Und das ist glaube ich jetzt bei dem aktuellen Vertreter ein bisschen anders gelagert.
Da werden jetzt glaube ich die Theologen und weniger Theologinnen in der katholischen
Kirche weniger mit der Zunge schnalzen als vielleicht bei Beratze,
aber dafür hat die Welt da vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr von.
Also ich habe gerade nochmal hier unseren Link rausgesucht und seine Anmerkungen
waren ja anlässlich des 60.
World Day of Social Communications oder wie das in der deutschen Übersetzung so schön heißt, 60.
Welttag der sozialen Kommunikationsmittel.
und ich versuche gerade heraus, ich meine 60, wer,
hat denn das überhaupt ein Social Communication Day,
instituted by Pope Paul der Sechste? Okay, das ist also sozusagen so ein Papst-Ding.
World Communications Day. Okay, das hat die Kirche sich mal ausgedacht.
Ich dachte, das ist jetzt wieder so ein Feiertag wie...
Tag der Erdbeere oder so. Genau. Und das war vom, was hast du gesagt, Januar?
Ich meine, im Januar ist er dir rausgekommen. Wir haben es, glaube ich, im März besprochen.
24. Januar, tatsächlich. Dem Gedenktag des heiligen Franz von Sales.
Siehst du.
Tempora omores, es gibt es wieder nicht auf Latein. Das ist doch kein Papst.
Das ist nicht mein Papst. Es ist sowieso nicht mein Papst.
Also die gibt es mit Sicherheit auf Latein. Also ich sehe sie jetzt ja auch
auf der von mir verlinkten Seite nicht, aber das ist völlig undenkbar,
dass es eine Enzyklika nicht auf Latein gibt.
So und das sind jetzt wieder in A4-Seiten gerechnet, ziemlich eng bedruckte
A4-Seiten, 56 Seiten. Also das ist schon...
Naja, kannst du mal in die AI schmeißen und dir mal zusammenfassen lassen?
Tim, doch nicht mit dem Wort Gottes.
Blasphemie.
Wieso Blasphemie? Ich habe ja gerade angekündigt, dass ich das Wort Gottes zu verkünden vorhabe.
Was ich ehrlich gesagt inzwischen sehr oft benutze, ist diese in macOS eingebaute
Funktion, einen Blocktext zu markieren und mit Rechtsklick zusammenfassend zu machen.
Echt, das machst du?
Das mache ich relativ regelmäßig.
Ich glaube, das habe ich mir noch nie getraut.
Ach, ist gut.
Da wird nicht Siri angestoßen, sondern wo geht er dann hin? Ist das dann schon?
Apple AI, keine Ahnung, wo das hingeht.
Ist das schon das Gemini?
Was Text zusammenfassen? Oder das läuft auf deinem Computer selber lokal?
Also rein von der Prozessorauslastung habe ich das Gefühl, das könnte auch sein,
dass es nicht unbedingt lokal läuft.
Aber die Funktion gibt es schon länger, als es dieses Private Cloud Compute gibt.
Das haben sie jetzt nur verbessert, aber das ist halt generell,
dass sie halt das lokal machen und nur wenn sozusagen höherer Bedarf ist,
das an ihre Private Cloud Compute auslagern.
Aber ich meine Text Summarization, das kriegt die Kiste auch lokal hin.
Ich habe jetzt die 56 Seiten Enzyklopädie hier gerade mal selektiert und jetzt
hier mal reingeschmissen.
Selektiert? Naja, Steuerung A halt.
Achso.
Auf der Webseite einfach.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen heftig.
Du hast gesagt, das geht.
Nein, so viel habe ich nie. Also ich mache mal nur die Einleitung.
So, was erlaube Apple? Der Dienst ist abgestürzt.
Prozessor, also er hat vier Performance-Cores ausgelastet und nach zehn Sekunden,
hat er das Fenster geschlossen.
Das ist das Motto. Nein, bis hierher und nicht weiter.
Gottes Wort.
War zu viel.
Hat ihn dann sozusagen erledigt.
Der tödliche Witz.
Also die Einleitung fängt laut Zusammenfassung damit an, die Menschheit steht
vor der Wahl, entweder einen neuen Turm zu Babel zu bauen oder eine Stadt,
in der Gott und die Menschen zusammen wohnen.
Zusammen wohnen.
Würde ich ja mal sagen, man kann auch das eine tun, ohne das andere zu lassen, aber gut.
Ja, naja, also ich komme mit diesen Prämissen von diesen Religionsleuten irgendwie nicht klar.
Ich auch nicht, das ist nicht meine Baustelle.
Ja, ich meine, es ist schon so im ersten Satz, es ist so, ja okay,
von Gott geschaffene Menschheit, großartig.
Also eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs Worte und ich komme schon irgendwie
mit vier davon nicht klar.
Ja, aber ab dem zweiten Satz ist es dann aber schon alles nicht mehr so schlimm.
Mit dem Turm von Babel meinst du?
Den sehe ich jetzt nicht.
Wenn du den hinter dich hast, den du den im Rücken hast, geht's.
Naja, der Papst. Wir werden dann mal entsprechend antworten.
Herr Papst, Sie müssen sich noch etwas gedulden, bis die Freakshow sich kompetent geäußert hat.
Also ich lese jetzt mal den zweiten Satz vor, nur der Vollständigkeit halber.
Jede Generation erbt die Aufgabe, die eigene Zeit zu gestalten,
damit die Geschichte zu einem Ort reifen kann, an dem die Würde des Menschen
gewahrt, Gerechtigkeit gefördert und Geschwisterlichkeit ermöglicht wird.
Doch jeder Epoche droht die Gefahr, dass die Welt unmenschlich und ungerechter wird.
Ja, Salbader, Salbader, Allgemeinplatz, Allgemeinplatz. Also ich meine, Salbader.
Okay, können wir wieder zu einem Thema zurückkommen?
Bleiben wir doch bei KI.
Bei KI.
Du bist ja der Meinung, dass Open Source, Open Raid, Open Open funktioniert jetzt.
Ja, ich würde nicht sagen, dass es funktioniert, aber der Abstand wird kleiner.
Ich habe mal so eine Seite, die hatten wir auch schon ein, zwei Mal in der Sendung,
aber ich finde, die kann man nicht oft genug bewerben.
Wo ist der Link? Vielleicht schmeißt er das mal auf die Orgel.
Auf die Orgel?
Naja, hier auf dem Beamarm. Die Orgel. Kennt ihr das nicht?
Mit der Orgel.
So, und ich werfe auch mal den Link in den Chat.
So, also die Seite, die ich wirklich regelmäßig und gerne besuche,
ist Artificial Analysis.
.ai natürlich.
Weil man dort so im Tagestakt quasi sieht, so okay, jetzt sind die neuesten
Modelle, die auch gerade rauskommen.
Wie schlagen die sich denn in diesen ganzen Benchmarks, die so rumhängen?
Und das hatten wir auch schon x-mal in der Sendung. Diese Benchmarks sind natürlich
irgendwie insofern schwierig, als dass ja auch häufig dann die neuen Modelle
darauf getunt werden, dort besonders gut abzuschneiden, jada jada.
Auf der anderen Seite werden die Benchmarks auch immer cleverer,
das sich dagegen zu wappnen.
Das ist also auch so ein Hase-Igel-Teil. Aber ich finde im Großen und Ganzen
bildet sich da schon immer ein bisschen was ab.
Und wenn du mal nach unten scrollst auf der Seite, ist diesmal,
als ich mir das jetzt vor ein paar Tagen zum ersten Mal wieder angeschaut habe,
genau das ist der Chart, über den ich gerade gerne reden würde,
nämlich die haben jetzt mal einen Chart drin,
Progress in Open Weights versus Proprietary Intelligence.
Das heißt also, das was sie machen ist, dass zu einem Zeitpunkt X in ihren Benchmarks
am besten abschneidende,
kommerzielle, geschlossene LLM zu vergleichen mit dem besten Open Source LLM.
Das gibt es ja in der Art eigentlich nicht oder zumindest keine,
die wirklich eine Rolle spielen würden. Ich glaube, es gibt ein oder zwei,
die wirklich komplett Open Source sind, aber ansonsten heißt es ja immer,
die Gewichtung der Trainingsdaten sind offen und einsehbar und modifizierbar.
Das ist ja das, was man so als Open Weight bezeichnet.
Also Open-Source-Modell ist falsche Bezeichnung an der Stelle.
Und das haben, also bestes kommerzielles Modell versus zum selben Zeitpunkt
bestes Open-Weights-Modell und wie groß ist da eigentlich der Abstand.
Und das haben die im Zeitverlauf mal geplottet von November 2022.
Also quasi wo, welche Version haben sie da als allererstes? JetGPT 3.5 oder
so. Welche ist das da? Gehen wir auf den Knubbel.
Genau, 3.5 Turbo. So, und die haben auf der Y-Achse haben sie sowas wie so die
verdichtete, aus diversen Indexen zusammengezogene KI-Intelligenz.
Auf einer Skala von 0 bis irgendwo eigentlich oben offen, aber derzeit,
also da sieht man, ChatGPT 3.5 ist gestartet auf irgendwie so einem Index von 16.
Und mittlerweile sind wir jetzt also bei Claude Opus 4.8. Oh,
ist das neu? 28. Mai, heute rausgekommen.
Ja, offensichtlich.
Ah, und wo sind, wobei, wie viel ist sie? Sind sie jetzt schon 61?
Okay, weil das davor war, geh mal eins höher wieder.
Genau, GPT-55 X-High, das ist als erstes Modell über 60 gekommen.
Also gestartet bei 16. Mittlerweile sind wir jetzt also bei 60.
Das ist eine Versechsfachung im Zeitraum seit 22.
Und jetzt hat sich da Claude wieder knapp davor geschoben mit 61. Na gut.
So, und dann sieht man, wie groß ist quasi der Abstand zwischen dem besten kommerziellen
und dem besten offenen System.
Was aber noch spannender ist, und da sieht man, noch spannender ist es, wenn du die.
Mal den Chart von rechts nach links liest. Das heißt, wie lange dauert es eigentlich,
bis die offenen Modelle auf dem Niveau nachziehen, zu dem die kommerziellen Modelle waren.
Also sprich, man nimmt, guckt sich jetzt nicht die Zeit an, sondern man guckt
sich vor allen Dingen diesen Intelligenzindex an, also Intelligenz immer in
Anführungszeichen gedacht,
sondern wenn man jetzt guckt, okay, das erste Modell, was irgendwie über 20
gekommen ist bei den kommerziellen, das war so irgendwie Oktober 24 da so,
gehen wir noch eins weiter,
so die ungefähr O1 Preview, das war im September 24.
So und jetzt läufst du da quasi nach rechts, wie lange es gedauert hat,
bis das erste Open-Welt-Modell in ähnliche Regionen kam.
Das war dann DeepSeek R1.
Das hat Mai 25 gedauert. Also nicht ganz ein Jahr, aber so fast ein Jahr.
Hast du dazwischen. Und wenn man sich jetzt diesen Chart anguckt,
dann sieht man, oh, diese Zeit wird immer kürzer.
Das heißt, die Open-Weights-Modelle sind jetzt viel eher in Schlagweite.
Sie haben es nie geschafft, irgendwo das beste Modell rauszugeben.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich erstaunlich. Aber du kannst also jetzt,
wenn du das Beste, hier ist jetzt Kimi 2.6 als Bestes mit einem Index von 54.
Das ist so gut wie das beste Modell, was im Februar diesen Jahres rauskam,
nämlich GPT-5-3-Kodex.
Und das finde ich schon erstaunlich.
Etwas über zwei Monate jetzt. Das ist der Leck nur noch so.
Ich finde, man sieht, wenn man auf die Kurve guckt, auch so ein bisschen,
dass die blauen, die offenen Modelle ein bisschen mehr Steigung haben seit Anfang
2025, als es die geschlossenen Modelle haben.
Das kann aber auch damit zu tun haben, dass diese Open-Wales-Modelle mit den
anderen nachjustiert wurden.
Das kann durchaus sein. Das ist ja erst mal nur eine Analyse dessen,
was man da sieht und nicht, wo es herkommt.
Und ich meine, der Begriff Open Source ist in der Tat etwas verwirrend an dieser Stelle.
Naja, Open Waits muss man sagen.
Aber Open Waits bedeutet vor allem überhaupt erst mal, man kriegt auch das Modell,
man kann das runterladen. Genau, und selbst betreiben.
Man kann es selbst betreiben, man kann es dann mit Open Source selbst betreiben.
Und es ist nicht versteckt hinter irgendeinem Server.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist das sehr interessant. Es sagt allerdings relativ wenig
über die Performance aus hier.
Also wenn du das halt dann auf eigener Hardware fahren willst,
dann musst du auch ordentlich Geld in die Hand nehmen.
Aber am Ende ist es ja auch so, oder was heißt oft, also wenn,
sich das jetzt so abzeichnet, wie jetzt gerade bei der Programmierung,
dass man schon fast vorher sagen kann, das wird jetzt auch funktionieren.
Weil wenn ich das so prompte, mit dem Modell weiß ich, die und die Qualität werde ich erreichen.
Vielleicht muss ich noch ein, zwei Mal nachziehen, aber ich komme schon so Good enough.
Wenn man das also erwarten kann, dann ist es vielleicht dann auch durchaus zumutbar,
dass es sagt, das dauert jetzt nicht 15 Minuten, die mich dann 200 Dollar kosten.
Jetzt eine Zahl, die ich mir gerade ausgedacht habe.
Kann aber schon durchaus passieren für die aktuellen Modelle,
sondern es ist halt vielleicht sowas wie,
rendern auf den C64. Also man wartet dann halt, man macht das dann über Nacht
und dann ist halt die Software am nächsten Morgen fertig.
Das ist ja dann auch schon machbar.
So langsam sind die Modelle aber auch alle gar nicht. Also hier 343 Max, Freakshow Max,
der hat jetzt einen 64 GB MacBook Pro und auf dem lässt er, ich glaube,
den Vorgänger hier zu dem, was du jetzt gerade eben hattest.
Laufen.
Genau, und das ist halt so etwas langsamer, aber ich wollte ihn mal besuchen
und mir das mal live und in Farbe angucken, weil im Moment kann ja keiner mehr
so viel Speicher bezahlen.
So Pi mal Daumen, glaube ich, ungefähr so die halbe Geschwindigkeit von dem,
was du jetzt mit einem Cloth hättest.
so und dann wartest aber eben nicht die ganze Nacht, sondern wartest halt eine
halbe Stunde statt 15 Minuten, so und dann bist du da aber schon in Schlagweite, würde ich sagen,
zumal es eben dann auch mal einfach Use Cases eröffnet wo du sagen kannst, okay,
das sind doch einfach mal sensible Daten und ich traue noch nicht mal irgendwie
in meinem zertifizierten Rechenzentrum die an, sondern ich will das einfach
bei mir in eigenen vier Wänden behalten ja, so wie im öffentlichen Dienst dann
da durchaus etliches an Szenarien, die mir da gut einfallen würden,
So, dann ist das einfach mal alternativlos und dann haben wir mittlerweile aber
jetzt auch wirklich Modelle an der Hand, mit denen man das betreiben kann.
Du bist jetzt mal einen Chart runtergegangen, wo man sieht, wie teilt sich diese
Kurve, wenn man sich nicht nur das jeweils beste Modell anguckt,
sondern überhaupt so die großen Open-Weights-Betreiber und dann siehst du,
okay, es sind halt die Chinesen, die das machen.
Die einzigen, die da überhaupt mitspielen, ist Mistral, die Franzosen,
die jetzt ihr 3,5er-Modell, das hat erstaunlich gute Scores bekommen.
Ich habe da ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und war schon wieder total schockiert.
Also mein Tonart-Einstieg ist ja immer hier TikTok Extreme, hatte ich ja in
der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung, wie ihr denn uns.
Das mit dem Wort drin.
Ich habe ein total tolles neues Spiel erfunden, Tic-Tac-Toe Extreme.
Vor jedem Spiel wird das Spielbrett einmal um 90 Grad gedreht und dann die günstigen
LLMs vielleicht ausrasten und mir einen Businessplan schreiben dafür,
wie ich damit die Weltherrschaft erringen kann mit diesem fantastischen Spiel.
und da ist jetzt Mistral 3.5 auch sofort wieder auf die Nase gefallen da habe
ich auch schon gar keine Lust mehr weiter zu testen hier.
Und die Psyk.
44 Labs, die irgendwie Open-Wade-Modelle rausbringen.
Mir fehlt überall irgendwo der Download-Button.
Was meinst du damit? Für die Charts oder für die Modelle?
Für die Modelle selber.
Wenn du beispielsweise LM Studio hast, da hast du die alle im Index drin.
Du suchst dir hier einfach eins raus und tippst es dort rein in die Suche und kriegst es.
Und ansonsten The Hugging Face. Da sind die alle. Da muss man ja gar nicht suchen,
sondern da weiß man, wo sie sind.
Da gibt es dann auch, was die Open-Weights-Modelle halt auch wirklich interessant
macht, ist, dass es dann sofort eine Community gibt,
die daraus Derivate bauen, die dann noch stärker komprimiert sind und die Anzahl
an aktiven Komponenten runterfahren, sodass es dann auch auf weniger Speicher
laufen lassen kann, mit nicht allzu viel Einschränkung.
also da ist, sobald also quasi eines der Studios eine offizielle Version rausgegeben
hast, kannst du dann zwei Wochen später dir 20 Derivate davon angucken,
das ist eben genau der Vorteil dieses Open-Wades-Ansatzes.
Was ist denn Kimi eigentlich für eine Bude?
Das sind auch Chinesen,
Da muss man sagen, da haben die echt einfach die Zeichen der Zeit erkannt und
haben da mal wieder als Land gesagt, das ist jetzt Staatsräson,
das ist jetzt wichtig, dass wir das nicht den USA überlassen.
Mit R1 hat es ja angefangen, was würde ich sagen auch wirklich so der Startpunkt
war, dass das überhaupt die Welt begriffen hat.
Oh, als quasi jetzt etwas despektierlich Hobby-Klitsche kannst du sogar irgendwie
in dem Game mitspielen, interessant.
Du meinst jetzt Deep Seek R1? Genau.
Und seitdem hat sich der Markt ja durchaus ein bisschen ausdifferenziert.
Also Kimi spielt eine Rolle, GLM ist immer weit vorne mit dabei,
DeepSeek auch nach wie vor, die lassen das auch nicht locker.
Wir sind jetzt bei V4, sehe ich hier gerade, V4 Pro.
Krass, ja Moonshot AI heißt die Bude.
Genau, QN, das sind eigentlich so die großen Bekannten.
Das ist ganz lustig, weil bei uns in der Firma hatte jemand,
ich glaube es war sogar das DeepSeek-Modell mal irgendwie quasi in der Cloud
an den Start gebracht, dass man das mal ausprobieren kann.
Und dann habe ich natürlich mal geguckt, ah, wie geht denn das Modell so mit der chinesischen,
was passierte am Platz des himmlischen Friedens in der Nachtform,
habe ich vorher gegoogelt, welche Nacht das war.
Und dann ist er auch gleich so, ja, nee, da kann ich jetzt nicht so viel zu
sagen, das ist ein bisschen politisch hier.
So, auch da ist es aber interessant, dass du, was ich gerade sagte,
zwei Wochen später, hast du sofort Anzensort-Versionen auch davon.
Die allerdings dann auch thematisch komplett anzensort auf alles sind.
Das heißt also wirklich quasi, du bist dann auf dem puren Trainingsstand.
Das heißt also, da kriegst du dann auch alles an Gewalt hin,
alles an Atombau, Bombenbauanleitungen.
Und welche Ufos da in Area 51 abgestürzt sind?
Diese ganzen Safe Guards, die dann halt eingebaut werden von den offiziellen
Betreibern, die kriegst du halt rausoperiert.
Sehr effektiv mit, wenn es auch in Weights ist.
Heißt aber auch wieder, die Büchse der Pandora steht beliebig weit offen,
was das angeht. Keiner kann das verhindern.
So ist es bei Open Source.
Tja.
So ist es halt im Internet.
Ja und ich bedauere zutiefst, dass hier Europa, ich sag's jede zweite Sendung,
den Hintern nicht hochkriegt und wie gesagt Mistral.
Die machen überhaupt noch was so, immerhin, aber vielleicht etwas weniger Geld
in Spritsteuer und dafür vielleicht mal ein Offenbaresmodell.
Ja, ich glaube die deutschen Politiker sind noch dabei, sich darüber lustig zu machen im Bierzelt.
Ja.
So, dann können wir uns ja mal auch darüber unterhalten, ob damit auch noch
ordentlich Geld verdient werden kann.
Die Seite ist lustig. Die ist mir auf Mastodon über den Weg gelaufen und dachte,
die schmeiße ich hier mal rein.
Is AI profitable.com?
Yet. Yet, genau.
Ne, .com ohne Yet.
No, everyone's broke.
Ja.
Genau, also was macht diese Seite? Das ist natürlich eine Kampagnen-Seite.
Das ist jetzt also keine Wissenschaft, aber die Zahlen sind glaube ich Sound soweit.
Und das führt halt so die großen Firmen in dem Game an und rechnet mal aus oder
versucht anhand von öffentlich zugänglichen Zahlen darzustellen,
wie viel haben die eigentlich investiert in den ganzen KI-Bereich und wie viel
nehmen sie eigentlich gerade ein und in was wir im Verhältnis steht das zueinander.
Und es gibt exakt eine Firma, die wirklich Gewinn macht.
Welche ist es? Ohne, dass ihr jetzt weiter scrollt.
Ja, okay, hätte man wissen können.
Hätte man wissen können.
Eine Firma, die Hardware,
Achso, Nvidia meinst du, ja.
Die schaufeln,
What the fuck Ja.
Also ich bin mir sicher, es gibt auch noch ein paar andere die Geld verdienen,
die sind aber wahrscheinlich hier nicht auf dieser Liste aber trotzdem mal ganz
interessant also was wir hier sehen ist immer eine Aufstellung,
was angeblich insgesamt von dem jeweiligen Unternehmen ausgegeben worden sei
und was angeblich von diesem Unternehmen bisher eingenommen worden sei auf Basis dieser Investitionen.
Beispiel Amazon habe 313 Milliarden US-Dollar investiert und 22 Milliarden rausbekommen.
Ähnliches Verhältnis bei Google und Microsoft.
Was ich krass finde.
Was die Investitionen angeht.
Weil die ja gar kein eigenes Modell auch haben. Also das müssen die Datacenter
halt letztendlich ja sein, die dann hier mit rein spielen.
Amazon?
Ja.
Die hatten mal ein Modell, aber ich meine, das haben sie nicht weiterentwickelt.
Ihr neues Alexa war, glaube ich, nicht so erfolgreich.
Die werden schon irgendwas haben. Also auf jeden Fall ziehen sie Datacenter hoch.
Ob sie da ihre eigenen Modelle nehmen oder anderer Leute Modelle, weiß ich nicht.
Meta-ähnlich. Die hatten auch mal ein öffentliches, zugängiges Modell.
Hatten die nicht Olama?
Ja.
Ne, Lama. Lama war ihr erstes Modell, die waren die ersten, die eigentlich ein
Open-Source-Modell oder mit die ersten, die ja rausgeschmissen haben. Das hieß Lama.
Noch lange nichts mehr gehört.
O-Lama ist nur so ein Open-Source-Projekt, was sozusagen jetzt das Ganze auch
irgendwie in Open-Source zum Laufen kriegen.
Ja, okay. Also die Zahlen können fishy sein.
Ich versuche gerade nur irgendwie ein bisschen rauszulesen, ob hier irgendeiner,
jetzt abgesehen mal von NVIDIA.
Mir scheint die Zahl von OpenAI viel zu klein zu sein.
Beim Invest.
Ja, viel zu klein.
Naja.
Keine Ahnung, was die hier für...
Das ist irgendwo beschrieben auf der Seite, was die Quellen sind.
Das kann man dann im Zweifel nochmal nachlesen. Was halt ein lustiges Goodie
ist, oben läuft halt so ein Counter weiter, so ähnlich wie beim Bund der Steuerzahler.
Seit wir die Seite geladen haben, sind also 6 Millionen Dollar weiter verbrannt worden.
Naja, schauen wir mal, wie das ausgeht. Ich denke, da wird sich das eine oder
andere auch noch auszahlen.
Beziehungsweise viele Investitionen werden am Ende wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht
unbedingt gemacht werden, weil das ja alles nur so Ankündigungen sind von wir
bauen jetzt so und so viele Datacenter, die werden eh alle nicht gebaut werden.
Schauen wir mal. Na gut, aber ein schönes Ding.
Interessant finde ich, wie wenig DeepSeek ausgegeben hat.
Die sind wirklich ganz unten.
Hier die R1, Leute, ne?
Die Frage ist, wie glaubwürdig ist das?
Genau. Da gab es dann im Nachklapp ja Debatten, naja, ganz so einfach war es
doch nicht mit ihren billigen NVIDIAs, die sie angeblich nur genommen hatten.
Da war die Saarlage dann doch ein bisschen komplexer, wo mal reingestochert wurde. Aber ja.
Ja, ich kann dieses Video von Gamers Nexus empfehlen, wo sie mal aufdröseln,
wie das ist mit dem Grafikkartenschmuggel nach China.
und wie viel Nvidia-Hardware die China nicht haben dürfte, tatsächlich in China
ist. Also es ist wohl extrem viel.
Ich finde auch XAI hat hier sehr wenig Invest.
XAI ist eine Maskbude? Man erkennt es am X, oder?
Hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, dass der da schon mehr drauf geworfen hat. Nun ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Gut, soviel zur Spekulation. ein letztes Interessant übrigens.
Apple taucht hier nicht auf.
Ja, die machen ja auch nichts mit AI. Die Nasen. Langsam muss man echt sagen, die Nasen.
Das haben sie echt mal komplett verschlafen.
Ja doch, mal gucken, wie WTC ist.
Also naja, ich weiß nicht, Apple würde sich jetzt nicht unbedingt damit rühmen,
300 Milliarden Miesel gemacht zu haben in irgendeinem Feld und derzeit kaufen
sie einfach für ein Apple und ein Ei sich einfach ein fertiges Gemini,
was sie auf ihrem System laufen lassen,
da zahlen sie eine Milliarde für im Jahr und haben genau das gleiche Ergebnis für die User.
Also man könnte auch sagen, das sind die einzigen, die hier die richtige Strategie haben.
Wir wissen noch nicht genau, wie das ausgeht, aber das ist, glaube ich,
noch offen, dass sie jetzt in der Zwischenzeit Probleme damit hatten,
die richtige Balance zu finden, mit welchen Technologien nehmen wir denn jetzt
hier für unser Siri und da gibt es in der Hinsicht immer an der falschen Stelle
abgesprungen zu sein scheinen.
Jetzt glaube ich sind wir technologisch in so einer Konsolidierungsphase jetzt
ist irgendwie klar wohin die Reise geht und da können sie jetzt einfach mit einsteigen,
werden wir sehen eine letzte Sache noch dann habe ich das hier von der Liste,
LM Studio, wir haben es schon öfter mal erwähnt, wer also auf einem Mac selber
Modelle ausprobieren möchte.
Die ganzen, die wir jetzt gerade erwähnt haben, gibt es ja in allen möglichen Größenordnungen.
Das heißt, ganz davon abhängig, wie viel RAM ihr so habt, könnt ihr halt mehr
oder weniger große Modelle ausprobieren und damit rumspielen.
Wenn ihr einen Rechner habt, der viel RAM hat, ich habe zum Beispiel hier mein
Mac Studio mal in Weiser voraus, ich bin 64 GB RAM gekauft, ehrlich gesagt,
noch weiser wäre ich gewesen mit 128 GB.
Wärst du jetzt ein gemachter Mann und könntest meinen Studiorechner verkaufen.
Und durch nichts ersetzen. Naja, trotzdem, das bietet mir schon die Möglichkeit,
zumindest so moderate Modelle ganz gut, was heißt ganz gut, überhaupt zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Nur sitzt man ja nicht unbedingt immer am gleichen Rechner. Und dieses LM-Studio
macht es ja nicht nur sehr leicht, Modelle runterzuladen, also zu finden,
runterzuladen und dann auszuprobieren, also dann gleich so einen Chat damit zu starten,
sondern sie haben jetzt in einer der letzten Versionen ein neues Feature namens
LM-Link eingebaut und damit kann man dann relativ easy so eine Art Netzwerk
der eigenen Computer erstellen,
sodass man dann auch von einem anderen Rechner von irgendwo,
den Rechner benutzen kann, der am meisten Wumms hat für so ein Modell und das
dann sozusagen remote macht.
Man braucht ja, um sowas irgendwie halbwegs zu integrieren, also ein Server
lief da ja schon immer auf Localhost irgendwie,
aber wenn man das irgendwie zuverlässig dann auch benutzen möchte,
will man ja dann auch einen secure Zugang haben mit HTTPS und das ist ja immer
alles ziemlich schwierig.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein easy way, das zu machen.
Das hat man mit zwei, drei Klicks am Start und dann kann man dann auch mal irgendeinen
Rechner benutzen, der vielleicht sonst einfach nur idle rumsteht,
aber die notwendigen Voraussetzungen hat.
Nämlich zum Beispiel für Speicher oder eben im Idealfall auch eine schnelle GPU.
So, dann können wir aber das AI-Thema erstmal zumachen, oder? Ja.
So, also unterhalten wir uns darüber.
Nachdem wir jetzt wieder so viele Sachen hatten, wo Deutschland nicht so gut ist.
Nehmen wir noch eins. Wo Deutschland nicht so gut ist.
Fußball.
Ja, wie steht es da momentan?
Das wissen wir nicht.
Das wissen wir erst nach der WM. Oder vielleicht auch schon,
wo anfängt der WM. Man weiß es nicht.
Also du willst jetzt keine längere Diskussion über Fußball haben,
aber die WM kommt erst noch. Sagen wir es mal so.
Die WM kommt erst noch. So sieht es aus.
Sind wir denn dabei? Autos, Autos, Autos.
Autos, ja.
Ja, Autos, das konnten wir mal ganz gut. Jetzt lassen wir uns von den Chinesen
zeigen, wie das geht, glaube ich, demnächst.
Ich glaube, das wird sich nicht mehr vermeiden lassen.
Aber Ralf wollte ja jetzt auch mal ein richtiges Auto haben und hat sich eins bestellt.
Also es begab sich ja zu der Zeit. Ich hole mal ein bisschen aus.
Die Autoweihnachtsgeschichte fängt an.
Also es ist ja Hörern der Sendung kein Geheimnis, ich bin kein Automensch.
So, das heißt also, ich mache mir nichts aus Autos. Ich empfinde keinen großen
Fahrspaß und irgendwie auch Optik und sowas.
Wir erinnern uns an antike Autoradios.
Genau. So, und ich war eigentlich mit meiner B-Klasse, Mercedes B-Klasse ist
mittlerweile jetzt 20 Jahre alt.
Eigentlich mal völlig zufrieden. Zumal, nachdem ich hier mit die Autoradio-Frage
ja auch gewinnbringend gelöst hatte.
So, jetzt musst du aber halt wieder über den TÜV irgendwie mal so demnächst.
Und dann stellt man sich ja schon die Frage, okay, will man das jetzt nochmal?
Weil da wird man mit Sicherheit nochmal so irgendwie 1500 Euro investieren.
Wird ihm eh wieder geklaut in Berlin, ja.
Zusätzlich zu den 10 Fahrrädern.
Weißt du schon, wo du das AirTag anbringst?
Naja, das ist ehrlich gesagt mal eine ganz interessante Frage.
Also ist Klauen von E-Autos eigentlich ein Thema, weil die ja ohnehin alle schon
mit ihrer Homebase ständig in Kontakt sind und klaut und so?
Oder wird das dann als, naja, dann schlachten wir halt Batterie und sonstige Ersatzteile aus?
Also mir ist noch keins geklaut worden. Ich kann nicht mitreden.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich meine, das gilt ja nicht nur für Elektroautos,
sondern diese Vernetzung ist ja in allen Fahrzeugen so.
Ich werde es für euch rausfinden und berichten.
Die Story kommt dann in der Kriegshow, wie er sein Auto wieder aus irgendeinem fernen Land geholt hat.
Gut, also die Frage war, bringt man den jetzt nochmal über den TÜV oder lässt
man sich irgendwie was anderes überlegen? Und was soll ich sagen?
Alle Optionen waren auf dem Tisch. Wir brauchen eigentlich gar kein Auto mehr.
Kinder sind jetzt aus dem Gröbsten raus und man macht das mit nur Ad-Hoc-Ausleihen,
wenn man mal irgendwo hinfahren will,
bis hin zu, so wir kaufen jetzt irgendwie eins und welches soll es denn sein
und alle Facetten dazwischen waren irgendwie grundsätzlich eine Option.
Und wenn man dann aber so anfängt zu rechnen, dann merkt man ja dieses irgendwie
Carsharing und so, das ist schon doch auch alles dann relativ kostenintensiv.
Also es ist nach wie vor nicht so richtig künstlich.
Guckt ein bisschen drauf an, wann man diese Fahrzeuge haben will,
weil wenn man jetzt so Familienausflug, lass mal am Wochenende,
das Wetter ist doch gut, dann versuch mal so eine Karre zu bekommen.
Und die Sommerferien, wo halt Berlin.
Und das sind exakt, das haben wir auch nämlich gemerkt. Wir hatten nämlich eigentlich
vor, was war vor Pfingsten hier? Ostern, glaube ich.
Das kommt meistens vorher.
Bisher war es immer so.
Wollte ich das eigentlich mal ausprobieren und habe dann also schlicht keine
Karre mit einigermaßen realistischem Finanzrahmen mehr irgendwie gefunden.
Und das war, glaube ich, so knapp drei Wochen vorher.
Jetzt nur Sharing oder auch Mietwagen?
Da habe ich alle auch von irgendwie Sixt bis irgendwie andere kleinere Berliner
Buden, hatte ich irgendwie fünf, sechs Anbieter und das war überall dasselbe Desaster.
Und das ist dann ein Punkt, ja, da bin ich dann doch irgendwie zu alt und lahm
und gemütlich, wo ich dann auch sage, also dafür, dass du dann irgendwie dann
jedes Wochenende wieder in so einen Struggle irgendwie reingehst,
das habe ich dann auch irgendwie nicht so richtig Bock drauf.
bei uns in der Familie ist es ja so, ich bin für die Fahrräder zuständig und
Claudia für die Autos also die hat sich dann halt mal jetzt guck nicht so, das ist so.
Das ist auch mir eine Neuigkeit, aber das könnt ihr ja halten, wie ihr wollt.
Nicht, weil sie jetzt einen überbordenden Autofetisch hätte,
aber sie interessiert sich gefühlt deutlich mehr für Autos als ich also wenn
wir irgendwie zusammen auf der Autobahn sind dann auch immer,
guck mal da rechts, das ist der Neue die so, aha Verstehe.
Ihr wisst ja, sie ist ja eine Nerdin durch und durch und wenn sie dann so anfängt,
dort in die Recherche zu gehen, dann kommen da Ergebnisse bei raus.
Und dann gab es also diverse Modelle und diverse Anbieter und so ein paar Dinge
habe ich dann aber als Setzung dann doch reingegeben.
Das Erste, aber da waren wir uns auch beide einig, lieber mal doch kein chinesisches Auto.
Es muss nun wahrlich nichts irgendwie deutsches sein, aber so europäisch wäre
irgendwie schon ganz cool.
Schlimmerweise, finde ich, hatte ich glaube ich auch schon mal in der Sendung
gesagt. Es ist finster, dass wir in Zeiten leben, wo man überhaupt in solchen
Dimensionen denken muss. Ich hatte mir das mit der Globalisierung alles anders vorgestellt.
Aber wer hat das nicht? Und die Welt ist nun mal so, wie sie ist. Und Europa, yay.
Zweite Setzung war, der Kofferraum darf nicht kleiner sein als die aktuelle
B-Klasse, die ich fahre.
Weil da habe ich schon noch eine Dachbox oben drauf, um die quasi noch optional
vergrößern zu können. Und wenn du dann eben zwei Lack hast.
800, nee, nicht 850. Also das ist immer schwer, ob mit Rückbank umgeklappt oder
nicht und bis wohin wird nach oben gemessen. Naja, ihr habt ja Kinder.
Da ist ja nichts mit Rückbank umgeklappen.
Eben, das ist also immer so ein akademischer Wert. Selbst nach Ikea oder so
hast du im Zweifelsfall dann noch mindestens irgendwie ein Kind dabei.
Müsste ich jetzt nochmal irgendwie nachschauen. Aber stellt sich aber raus,
das ist schon ein ganz schön hartes Kriterium, weil diese B-Klasse hat einfach
mal einen sehr, sehr großen Kofferraum hinten.
Das ist das, was sie ja von der A-Klasse abgehoben hat.
So ist ja mehr oder weniger dasselbe Auto, aber halt doppeltes an Ladevolumen hinten.
Und da bist du dann schon fast direkt in so einem mindestens Mini-SUV-Bereich,
wenn du also sowas noch irgendwie haben willst.
Also so kleinere, normalere Wagen strecken da schon alle Viere von sich.
Und lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, worauf es dann relativ schnell hinaus lief,
war dann so Richtung, okay, Skoda ist doch eigentlich cool.
So eine VW-Plattform, ID.3, ID.4 und dann da so der LROC war eigentlich so das,
was wir uns da so rausgesucht hatten,
ist dann schon insgesamt größer und klobriger als das jetzige,
aber schien irgendwie ganz sinnvoll zu sein.
Dann waren wir in Hannmünden bei den Schwiegereltern und dann hieß es,
hey, das wäre doch lustig, wenn man einfach mal so eine Probefahrt macht und
sich das mal irgendwie so anguckt.
Kurze Frage, von wann ist das alte Auto?
Das ist jetzt knapp 20 Jahre alt. Müsst du also zurückrechnen, ich glaube.
Oh ja, vor 2008.
Ja, knapp davor müsste es sein.
Ja, gut, weiter. Gleich.
Gleich, okay. Alles falsch gemacht, oh nein.
Nein, nein, alles gut.
So, und ich dann also rumtelefoniert, so diverse Autohäuser in Kassel und Göttingen,
also Herr Mühn liegt ja so ein bisschen dazwischen, zwischen Kassel und Göttingen,
so könnte man denn mal vorbeifahren kommen und mal so einen L-Rock irgendwie
bei Probe fahren. Und...
Großes Wunder, du kriegst ja überhaupt nirgendwo mehr einen Menschen an Telefonapparat.
Also überall nur noch AI-Telefonbots.
Also nicht irgendwie die klassischen Systeme, sondern jetzt schon so AI-Systeme,
die so tun, als würden sie vernünftig mit einem reden, aber am Ende kommt dann
doch raus, ja, keine Ahnung, ob irgendjemand irgendwie Zeit hat, wir rufen sie zurück.
das fand ich so für so eine Experience in Bezug auf ich will dort irgendwie
einen Betrag X vielleicht irgendwo auf den Tisch legen war ich schon mal so semi cool,
und man muss sagen wie viel habe ich angerufen, ich glaube 5 und bei 4 ist halt
wirklich keiner drangegangen und die früheste Rückmeldung von einem von denen kam 4 Tage später,
super da war ich natürlich dann schon auch lange nicht mehr in Hannemünde und
es war alles schon mir völlig egal Aber dachte ich auch so, okay,
so verkauft ihr also Autos irgendwie im Jahr 2026. Nun gut.
Vielleicht das auch noch irgendwie für den Hintergrund. Ich habe Zeit meines
Lebens überhaupt noch nie ein Auto gekauft. Das heißt also, ich habe immer nur Gebrauchte gekauft.
Also keinen Neuwagen.
Keinen Neuwagen, genau. Und jetzt auch die B-Klasse habe ich von meinem Papa
übernommen, als er selber nicht mehr fahren konnte.
So, ansonsten hätte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt auch weder ein Auto und schon gar keinen
Benz irgendwie gebraucht. Aber war dann halt einfach mal praktisch an der Stelle.
Und als Familienklitsche lasse ich da auch echt nichts drauf kommen,
hat er sich ja echt sehr bewährt.
So, also schwierig so mit den Händlern und irgendwie der Responsivität,
aber in Göttingen hatte dann einer am nächsten Tag Zeit und meinte,
ja, kommen Sie vorbei morgens um 10 Uhr.
Und das haben wir dann gemacht und dann gucke ich mir so diesen L-Rock an und
eben Reflex so als erstes, bevor wir überhaupt irgendwie weiterreden,
machen sie doch mal den Kofferraum auf.
Scheiße, weil der klein.
Skoda L-Rock, ich habe gerade nachgeguckt, Kofferraumvolumen EU, 470 Liter.
Ja, und die B-Klasse?
Die B-Klasse habe ich jetzt nur die 2008 bis 2011, kommt aber auf 544 Liter.
Genau, es fühlt sich an wie doppelt so groß. So und das ist nämlich die Frage,
dass ich immer fragen habe, wie die diese Liter eigentlich messen.
Messen die die eigentlich dann, bis man dieses Zwischendeck zugezogen hat?
Das wäre nämlich meine Arbeitsthese.
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Weil also das ist ja nicht das, wie man einen Kofferraum bepackt.
Also zumindest wenn man Familie hat, dann stapelst du bis knapp nach oben,
sodass du gerade eben noch durch den Rückspiegel durchgucken kannst.
Irgendwie muss man es messen, aber ich glaube, es ist ganz fair,
das so zu messen, wenn die Abdeckung zu ist, weil das ist ja die Variante,
die du, sagen wir mal, täglich benutzt und nicht, wenn ich mit Sack und Pack losfahre.
Also ich habe meine Abdeckung seit Tag 1 irgendwo im Keller eingemottet.
Also schon meinen Wocheneinkauf kriege ich da ja nicht rein.
Ja, okay, okay.
Falls du dich fragst, warum ich gefragt habe, das kann ich jetzt kurz in den Chat schmeißen.
Es gibt da eine Webseite, die finde ich sehr interessant und sehr hilfreich,
die heißt carsized.com.
Die würde ich persönlich nicht mit einem normalen Browser aufmachen,
sondern nur mit einem Browser, der einen eingebauten Adblocker hat.
Ah, sowas haben wir ja. Helium.
Helium, genau. Mit Helium ist super. Mit allen anderen Browsern wirst du wahnsinnig,
weil es die wirklich massiv übertreiben. Aber mit Helium ist okay.
Ach, das ist ja geil. Das wollte ich mir bauen. Das wollte ich mir Vibe-Coden.
Guck, siehste, und schon hat man es hier.
Hervorragend. So, ich habe mich nämlich geärgert, dass es das nicht gibt.
Guck, schon lohnt sich die Sendung. So, also was sehen wir hier?
Kannst du zwei oder auch mehr Autos aussuchen?
Du kannst nur zwei aussuchen. Du kannst sie aber auch von vorne angucken und
von der Seite und von hinten.
Genau, also man kann zwei Autos quasi nebeneinander stellen und dann von der
Seite und von vorne angucken, wie sich die Maße hier so verhalten.
Und da sieht man jetzt schon bei dem L-Rock versus B-Klasse,
der ist schon ein Ticken größer. Ein Ticken größer vorne, die Schnauze ist halt
höher, wie jetzt bei diesen Mini-SUVs halt alle.
Und nach hinten hat er so gefühlt, würde ich sagen, so 15, 20 Zentimeter mehr.
Das Dach oben ist relativ gleich, würde ich sagen. Das tut sich nicht so viel.
Aber warte mal, er hat doch hier sogar die genau 21,5 Zentimeter länger.
Na guck. Das ist eine super Seite, Roddy, danke.
2 Zentimeter höher. 2,1 Zentimeter. Ja, was meinst du, wie oft ich diese Seite
versucht habe, um herauszufinden, ob mein Auto auf mein Grundstück fahren kann
und ob das Gartentor groß genug ist.
Warum, wenn ich jetzt auf Front gehe, warum kann ich die dann nicht übereinander leigen?
Macht er nicht, kann ich dir nicht sagen, warum.
Niemand weiß warum. Okay.
Vielleicht musst du doch nochmal Vibe coden.
10 Zentimeter, nee, das lohnt nicht, das ist gut genug.
Aber ich finde auch die Tabelle unten, so breite, breite inklusive Außenspiegel
und so weiter, das sind schon schöne Zahlen.
Ja super.
Und dann halt auch immer mit der Angabe plus wie viel, minus wie viel.
Ja, aber hier Kofferraumvolumen, das ist also wirklich Quatsch.
Also weil ja so 470, aber ich komme gleich dazu, 470 plus 544 plus 16 Prozent
seien das nur, es fühlt sich an wie fast das Doppelte.
Du hast aber geguckt, ob es da einen doppelten Boden gibt, den man rausnehmen kann.
Ja, gibt es, den kannst du hochnehmen. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sie den mit reinrechnen in ihre Liter.
Ich nehme mal an, den rechnen sie mit rein.
Dann hast du so ein paar Fächer da nämlich, aber in die kriegst du auch nicht
so rasend viel rein, weil dann halt so dieser dicke Schaumstoff dazwischen und so.
Also eine Einkaufstüte kriegst du da nicht rein, Punkt.
Also ich will jetzt auch nicht Skoda verteidigen oder irgendwas,
sondern nur sagen, wie die Zahlen zustande kommen.
Aber es ist eine geile Seite. Okay, danke dafür. Die hätte ich mal vorher gebraucht. Super.
Hast ja nicht gefragt.
Kars heißt, ich habe im Chat sehr wohl gefragt. Kars heißt .com mit Helium Browser for the win. Okay.
So, nichtsdestotrotz, ich dann also Probe gefahren und wie gesagt,
ich bin kein Automensch.
Heißt auch, dass ich irgendwie seit 20 Jahren halt kein modernes Auto mehr gefahren bin.
Also schon mal ab und zu, aber jetzt halt nicht irgendwie bewusst.
und Elektro ist ja schon ganz cool.
Und diese Skoda sind sehr, sehr gemütlich von der ganzen Abstimmung her und
ich habe dann auch bewusst sofort nochmal in den,
Economy Green Mode geschaltet, weil ich es auch gerne gemütlich habe beim Fahren
und dieses von 0 auf 100 in 6 Sekunden habe ich einfach keinen Anwendungsfall in meinem Leben für.
Das macht man beim Rauffahren auf die Autobahn kurz an, dann macht man es wieder aus.
Ja, aber auch das habe ich probiert und das ging dann auch immer noch mehr als,
doppelt so schnell als in meinem Bandzahl.
Von daher habe ich da jetzt überhaupt nichts vermisst an der Stelle.
Ist ja schon geil, so ein modernes Auto. Müsste ich dann aber feststellen.
Also ich widerspreche dir jetzt nicht.
Also doch, hat mich dann etwas angefasst.
So, dass ich dachte so, okay, du hast das jetzt eigentlich eher so als spaßiges
Freizeit-Entertainment hier so.
Man hatte gerade am Tag nichts Besseres zu tun und ernsthaft mit dem Thema beschäftigen
willst du dich eigentlich nicht.
Da war natürlich so, ah okay, das ist schon so ein bisschen cool, ist das schon so.
Und habe ich auch schon mal erzählt, ich fahre halt sehr, sehr,
sehr gerne in Urlaub mit dem Auto.
Das ist halt wirklich total mein Ding, um dann vor Ort irgendwie flexibel zu
sein und dort nicht ständig irgendwie zu gucken, wie das mit den Öffis ist und so.
Und dafür dann irgendwie plötzlich so eine Karre zu haben, die dann doch mal
so ein klein bisschen mehr im Komfort irgendwie als ein 20 Jahre Alter mitbringt.
Das fand ich schon ganz charming. Und der Sound, ja, ich habe dann also dann
mich per, ja, wie heißt das, Carplay, dann eben auch drauf geschaltet und mal
so die Sachen, die ich gut im Ohr habe, wie es klingen müsste.
So, das ist natürlich auch wie Tag und Nacht zu dem, was irgendwie da vor 20
Jahren von Mercedes verbaut worden ist, mit irgendwie Subwoofer drin.
Und da hatte ich noch die günstigen Boxen, jetzt in dem was dann kommt,
habe ich noch Kanton rechts unten Boxen irgendwie dann noch drin verbaut,
aber komme ich gleich zu.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, diese Fahrt hat mich dann schon so ein bisschen angefasst
und habe dann dem Verkäufer deutlich mehr Chancen eingeräumt,
als ich das vorher eigentlich so vorhatte, aber das Problem war halt so mit
diesem Kofferraum, geht halt nicht so.
Also tolles Auto, macht Spaß, gefällt mir gut, grundsätzlich langweilig so,
wie Skoda halt immer so ist, aber von daher voll bei mir in der Zielgruppe,
ich will da überhaupt nichts flashy haben, soll halt funktionieren und vernünftig
sein und da sind das schon so,
haben die schon so einen Sweetspot, finde ich, die Skodas, vernünftig.
Kein Quatsch, aber dieser Kofferraum geht halt nicht.
Und da meinte er, naja, dann ist vielleicht aber auch einfach mal der L-Rock
das Falsche und dann müssen sie sich vielleicht den Enyaq mal angucken.
Und Tim, du kannst ja jetzt mal den Enyaq gegen den Karok laufen lassen.
Und den hatte er eben daneben stehen und dann machte man den Kofferraum auf
und ich habe das Licht gesehen, weil es war so groß.
Und es hat Gehalt. Oder was?
Und das war dann halt wirklich ein Erweckungserlebnis, weil da hatte ich den
Eindruck, okay, das ist mindestens so groß wie meine B-Klasse,
vielleicht sogar noch ein Tucken größer.
So, und da war ich dann sehr glücklich.
Ist das jetzt, nee, nicht gegen die C-Klasse, sondern mach mal wirklich INIAC gegen L-Rock.
Also wenn ich das hier mache, dann ist der nochmal 17 Zentimeter länger.
Gleiche Höhe.
Das ist eigentlich quasi nur eine Verkombifizierung von dem Gerät.
Also wenn ich mir das so angucke, nee, nicht wirklich, weil der andere ist ja
prinzipiell auch ein bisschen Kombi.
Entschuldigung, ich bin zu doof, dieses Browser zu benutzen.
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, wo das hier herkommt und wie ich das wieder loswerde?
Geteilte Ansicht erstellen.
Taucht auf einmal irgendein komischer, dusseliger Sidebar auf.
Kuckst du es mit Escape nicht weg? Escape-Taste, Mann, so wichtig.
Es taucht irgendwann auf und dann ist es da und es hilft nur,
wenn ich irgendwie ein komplett neues Fenster aufmache. Dann ist es irgendwie weg.
Aber ich habe nicht herausgefunden, wodurch es kommt und wie es geht.
Tja, gut. Aber die Ja, das Kofferraumvolumen wird hier auch als deutlich größer angegeben.
Also wenn man sie so nebeneinander sieht, sieht man eigentlich kaum einen Unterschied.
Diese 17 cm ist auch 16,1 Zentimeter mehr Länge, also überall anders steht irgendwie 21, irgendwas.
Also ich würde jetzt fast nochmal die Daten dieser Seite hier hinterfragen wollen gerade.
Ja, das ist bestimmt auch nicht Kanon, was sie da haben.
Aber Ja, aber geh nochmal unten jetzt hier auf den Kofferraum, was sie da angeben.
Prozent weniger Kofferraumvolumen.
Genau, das wären dann 500, aber das stimmt ja irgendwie, genau 585 versus 470 plus 25 Prozent.
Also mehr als eben bei der B-Klasse hier angegeben war.
Und das fühlt sich definitiv wie doppelt so viel an, weil da auch irgendwie
gefühlt der tiefer runter geht
und irgendwie diese Zwischendecke irgendwie nochmal anders gebaut ist.
Also da war sofort der Reflex, ja das reicht, da kriegst du einen Wocheneinkauf
rein, das wird funktionieren. Damit kommen wir ins Geschäft.
Will ich deinen Wocheneinkauf sehen? Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Für einen Familienfrieden mit zu viert kann ich das sehr empfehlen.
Einmal die Woche einkaufen und dann aber auch alles.
Und dann hast du aber auch Ruhe die ganze Woche. Du musst nicht ständig irgendwo
nachfüllen. Du machst dir einen Wochenplan, was es wann gibt zu essen und dafür wird eingekauft.
Und das muss dann aber halt auch in einem Rutsch in so eine Karre reinpassen.
Und das erscheint mir möglich. So, und...
Das Kofferraumproblem war also definitiv gelöst, im Sinne von ja, damit kann ich leben.
Du kriegst immer noch eine Dachbox obendrauf, was bei Elektro ja immer so eine
semi-gute Idee ist, wegen Luftwiderstand und Reichweite und so.
Reichweite vielleicht auch nochmal, liegen die jetzt so bei dieser offiziellen
Angabe 580 Kilometer, wo ich gesagt habe, solange ich realistisch auf 400 komme, ist es gut genug.
So mehr brauche ich nicht, aber die will ich schon haben.
Wenn man 20 Prozent runterrechnet, dann ist man in einem relativ realistischen
Bereich, aber es kommt natürlich darauf an, wie du fährst.
Also wenn du auf der Autobahn mit gemütlichen 110 vor dich hintuckerst,
dann kommst du vielleicht sogar auf die angegebene Reichweite.
Wenn du meinst, du müsstest 150 fahren.
Dann definitiv nicht. mehr, aber ich wiederhole mich, ich bin da sehr gemütlich
und defensiv und entspannt unterwegs, von daher bin ich da glaube ich auch ein guter Elektrofahrer.
Also übrigens das auch, weil ich es einfach komplett übersprungen habe,
nicht für eine Sekunde war irgendwie auf dem Tisch, ob man noch irgendwie ein
Hybrid oder Benziner oder Diesel oder so nimmt, das finde ich,
da hätte ich ja die Freakshow verlassen müssen.
Da wärst du ausgewiesen worden.
Darüber möchte ich einfach im Jahr 2025 nicht nachdenken. Übrigens auch interessanter Punkt.
Wir haben schon 26, aber es ist okay.
26, ja gut. Hier Thema Skoda.
Der L-Rock und der E-Niag, das sind ja quasi die E-Varianten von klassischen
Autos bei denen, die auf der quasi sehr ähnliche Baufaktoren und Ausstattungsmerkmale haben.
Und die Elektro-Varianten sind knapp günstiger.
Das finde ich auch ein gutes Statement.
Aber soweit ich weiß, sind es Ableger, also mobile Elektrobaukasten von VW,
sprich die entsprechen eigentlich anderen ID-Modellen.
Ja, das ist was die Technik und Fahrwerk und so weiter angeht.
Aber die Karosserien sind eigentlich abgeleitet aus anderen Skoda-Modellen,
die dann kein E vorne haben, sondern ein K, glaube ich.
Ja, aber dann sind sie wahrscheinlich einfach nur so designt,
dass sie gleich aussehen.
Also nicht L-Rock, sondern K-Rock heißt es dann, glaube ich.
L-Rock, K-Rock.
Die Namensfindung finde ich auch gut.
Lass mich raten, nächstes Jahr kommt der M-Rock oder was?
Das wird ja keinen Sinn haben, ja. Naja, und dann begann also die Verhandlungsrunde mit dem Verkäufer,
was denn jetzt so die Strafgebühr für so etwas wäre.
So und dann war schon mal die erste Erkenntnis, die ich geahnt habe,
aber die mich doch überrascht hat, dass er meinte, okay kaufen tut ja keiner
mehr E-Autos, sondern neun von zehn Leuten leasen.
So und ob das dann auch bei mir der Fall wäre.
Neun von zehn leasen?
Neun von zehn, die bei ihm sitzen, leasen.
Weil so dieses so, okay, wer weiß, was in zwei, drei Jahren,
wie dir die Technik hergibt und ob das doch alles mit den Batterien und so weiter
und man möchte irgendwie up-to-date bleiben, es kauft keiner mehr Autos,
meinte er, findet nicht mehr statt.
Ich glaube, da gehört aber auch ein bisschen rein, dass die Hersteller dann
manchmal versuchen, Modelle loszuwerten und sie dann aber mit günstigen Leasingkonditionen
rauswerfen, statt den Preis zu senken.
Ja, mag sein. Dasselbe hat mir aber der dann in Berlin erzählt, drei Tage später.
Also die war komplett konsistent, die Geschichte.
Mag natürlich auch sein, dass das bei denen alles… Im privaten Bereich.
Ja.
Kann sein, dass die so geschult werden.
Genau, mag alles sein. Er hat jetzt glaube ich kein Interesse daran,
mich jetzt irgendwie Richtung Leasing auf Teufel komm raus irgendwie zu pushen.
Kommt drauf an, wenn das Leasing von der VW Bank kommt, schon.
Naja, das kommt, ist von der Skoda eigenen Bank, genau, die haben ja mit VW
drin, in dem Fall läuft das aber über die selber, genau.
So, aber da wir ohnehin in diesem Leasing-Track unterwegs waren,
war das also jetzt für mich no shocking news, sondern ja wunderbar,
da machen wir es so wie alle anderen.
Aber den alten Bands hast du nicht geleast?
Den habe ich nicht geleast, nee.
Wie, du machst jetzt Leasing?
Ich mache Leasing, ja.
Und warum? Warum?
Weil ich die Freiheit schätze zu sagen, so in zwei Jahren kann man dieses Mobilitätsding
dann wieder ganz anders nochmal interpretieren. Zwei Jahre, nicht drei.
Und eine relativ hohe Anzahlung, die mir jetzt im Moment nicht sonderlich wehtut,
aber dafür sorgt, dass ich eine absurde monatliche Rate hatte.
Absurd was? Absurd niedrige?
Ja, also bei dem Modell, was wir am Anfang hatten,
hier dieser Elrog, mit irgendwie so mittlerer Ausstattung, was wir uns vorher
so irgendwie zusammengeklickt hatten, dann kriegst du als Mercedes und BMW Kunde eingetragener Fahrer,
kriegst du gerade noch einen Sonderrabatt bei Skoda und dann war noch irgendwie
Oster-Special und Frühjahr und jadda jadda.
war er dann und das schluckte er dann selber bei einer monatlichen Rate von 64 Euro.
Das ist wenig.
Das ist wenig, ja.
Okay.
Da musste er selber nochmal gegen sein System treten, aber das ist das, was da so rauskam.
Das ist das, was du jetzt bezahlst?
Nein, das ist nicht das, was ich jetzt bezahle. Die Geschichte geht noch eine Umdrehung weiter.
Ach so.
So, aber das hätte ich quasi da shoppen können, aber erst in sieben Monaten
kriegst du was, weil so lange sind derzeit die Lieferfristen.
Aber wir haben da noch was auf dem Hof stehen. Das könnte Ihnen auch gefallen.
Nee, er hatte überhaupt nichts auf dem Hof stehen. Er meinte und wünscht mir
viel Glück, ob er irgendwo im Umkreis von 2000 Kilometern einen Skoda-Händler
findet, der irgendwas auf dem Hof stehen hat. Das sei alles komplett weggekauft gerade.
Dank Trump.
Da ist nichts mehr.
Ja, die fahren alle die Straße von Hormuz runter.
Tesla wollte keiner mehr. Nachschubwege. Da werden so manche Aspekte aufeinander gekommen.
Es ist tatsächlich auch so, dass der Markt extrem Richtung Elektro geschwenkt hat.
Jetzt, wo die Preise so hoch sind, da kann ich so ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen
plaudern, weil ich da so gehört habe, die Zahlen sind wohl relativ eindeutig.
Die Verbrenner liegen gerade bleischwer in den Regalen der Händler.
Ich schmeiße mal was in den Chat rein. So, ich habe ihn gefragt,
ob ich das im Podcast verwursten darf.
Ich habe das jetzt so ausgeschnitten, dass er seine ganze GUI und sein Browser
und so nicht zu sehen ist.
Das sind die Lieferfenster, die offiziellen, die er...
für Skoda sieht. Das heißt also, welche der Modelle ab wann verfügbar sind.
Und da sehen wir also der...
Skala und Kamik kriegst du quasi morgen.
Genau. Und alles, was aber so spannend ist, sprich der gerade eben besprochene
L-Rock und Enyaq, da bist du dann bei Mitte November.
Wow. Kognak. Nee, Kognak gibt's nicht.
So, und das war dann schon so ein Downer, weil ich hatte mich eigentlich schon
klar in meinem Sommerurlaub und so imaginiert, wo man nämlich irgendwie mit
dem Großen eine Römer-Rundtour entlang des Limes und sowas plant.
Ach, du wolltest den einfach gleich mitnehmen?
Wenn er da was super Sexies gehabt hätte, meinetwegen, aber ansonsten hat er
irgendwie so zwei Monate Lieferzeit, dachte ich, oder so, das sei ja vielleicht
schon irgendwie realistisch, aber Pustekuchen.
Okay.
Naja gut, wenn die Auftragsbücher voll sind.
Das heißt, das Modell war dann auf einmal doch keine Option mehr.
Es wäre eine Option gewesen, Claudia wäre in der Woche drauf,
am Mittwoch auch nochmal in Göttingen gewesen und da hätten wir den Deal dann
gemacht, wenn ich denn nicht in Berlin nochmal einen Skoda-Händler meines Vertrauens aufgesucht hätte.
Deines jetzt Vertrauens.
Meines jetzt neuen Vertrauens, genau. Und da ging...
Die Geschichte halt so, okay, rechnen sie erst nochmal gegen,
auf was kommen sie denn hier?
Der kam dann leider nicht mehr auf die 64 Euro, sondern landete dann eher so
beim Doppelten, 120, was aber auch immer noch irgendwie zu vertreten war.
Für so ein Riesenauto eigentlich auch nicht viel Geld.
Für so ein Riesenauto vor allen Dingen war das, was er dann da halt hatte,
von der Ausstattung her, the very definition of rechts unten.
Das heißt also all das, was wir jetzt so bei dem in Göttingen so als mittlere
Ausstattung hatten, war bei dem komplett ausgemaxt.
Aber den hatte er schon vor zweieinhalb Monaten bestellt.
Das heißt also der ist dann schon so in viereinhalb Monaten da und nicht erst
irgendwie Mitte November, sondern September.
Hat er auf gut Glück einen bestellt?
Ja, er meinte, das sei genau die Strategie, rechts unten ausstatten,
populäre Farbe, kriegt er immer los.
Ist quasi ein No-Brainer. Sobald also Skoda irgendwas Neues announced,
sofort drücken die auf, bestellen.
Weil das hat dann auf jeden Fall alle Features, die die Leute haben wollen und es ist da.
Und es ist dann da. Oder früher da als bei der Konkurrenz. Da dachte ich auch
so, hm, nicht so schlecht, Junge. Hat funktioniert.
Es hat auch exakt die Farbe, die ich haben wollte. Nämlich dieses Grafitgrau.
Eigentlich dachte ich immer so, wenn ich mein erstes E-Auto habe, muss es weiß sein.
Ich weiß gar nicht wieso, aber irgendwie dachte ich so.
Aber als ich den dann da so in Grafitgrau stehen sehe, dachte ich so,
oh ja, der ist aber doch schick. Das ist gute Farbe.
Grafit grau. Deshalb sind ja gefühlt alle Autos grau.
Ja, aber das ist ein sehr schönes Grau.
Ja, ja. Ist nicht wie die anderen Graus.
Das ist kein Mausgrau und auch kein Steingrau. Das ist ein Grafit Grau.
Das ist ganz anderes.
Das ist quasi Anthrazit.
Und es hat ein sehr, sehr schönes, großes Schiebedach.
Hervorragend zu deinem blauen Business-Hemd, will ich sagen.
Ja, Touché. Wenn ich dann vor der nächsten Freakshow oder über,
über, über nächsten Freakshow dann mit meinem blauen Eterna-Hemd aus dem Grafit-Grauen.
Ja, super. Ich hab's klar vor Augen.
Schiebedach, also richtig offen oder Sunroof?
Nee, zum Machen auf. Fand ich geil, wollte ich sowieso haben.
Hier, der Jan schreibt gerade im Chat, er hat vorgestern ein ID7-Tourer in einem
erfrischenden Steingrau.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir aber auch wirklich die Loriot-Geschichte aus YouTube noch da raussuchen.
Auf die wir uns hier die ganze Zeit beziehen, weil die Jüngeren unter euch mögen das noch nicht kennen.
Also Loriot-Grau. Das ist aus seinem ersten Film Ödi Pussy. Wir hätten gerne das Aschgrau.
War nicht Mausgrau und Steingrau oder so?
So, also ich schmeiße den Link rein, wenn ihr das nicht kennt, unbedingt angucken.
Immer wenn es um die Farbe Grau geht, ist das der einzige zugelassene Referenzpunkt.
Wie lang ist denn das?
In der grauen Sitzgruppe bringen sie ihre Frau oben, ja.
Ja, Aschgrau, Steingrau, Grafitgrau, also es ist einfach unglaublich,
dass du überhaupt da zu einem Ergebnis gekommen bist.
Also du hast jetzt einen Skoda N-Jag im Vollausbau rechts unten mit maximaler 20 Zoll Felgen.
Kanton Soundsystem, alles an Assistenzen, was das Leben, also du kannst es nicht
teurer machen, als das, was ich dann da habe.
Und das war nicht unbedingt mein Plan, aber zumindest nicht dieses Modell.
Ja.
Genau, nicht dieses Modell, aber mit dem großen Akku, es ergab sich jetzt so,
mit dem großen Akku natürlich.
Aber nicht RS.
Nee, nicht RS, das nicht. Genau, nicht irgendwie Sportversion und sondern da also schon die normale.
Die richtige interessante Information. Die Ladekurve.
Die Ladekurve.
135 Kilowatt maximale Ladegeschwindigkeit. Naja.
Da muss man mal gucken, ob das schon das 2007 ob das 2027 Modell ist.
Da müsstest du mal kurz gucken.
27?
Ja, weil das ist quasi, ich kriege den ersten vom Band, der jetzt dann schon die neue...
Nach zwei Jahren machen die ein neues Modell. Ja.
Hat der dann auch die neue Standardzelle von VW? Ah ja, das ist interessant.
Und das Ganze, was da in diesem iPad verbaut ist, ist auch alles komplett neu
und soll responsiver sein.
Vielleicht kriegst du sogar die,
alten Instrumente. Also der neue ID.Polo und der neue ID.3 haben ja diese,
Retro-Instrumente, die so aussehen, als wären es richtige Zeigerinstrumente aus dem Golf 1.
Nee, das hat er nicht, aber Head-Up-Display hat er. Das finde ich dann,
glaube ich, auch ganz spacig.
Head-Up-Display ist sehr cool. Ich vermisse es ein bisschen.
Dass du dann so auch den Navi drin hast, in der Windschutzscheibe und so,
weil die Hauptanzeige bei diesen Skoda-Teilen ist absurd klein.
Also das, was du so hinterm Steuerrad eigentlich hast. Das ist so gefühlt wie
so ein iPhone, so groß nur.
Und das dann noch so als Head-Up-Display zu haben, ist vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ja, so gesagt, der Akku ist nochmal ein anderer jetzt bei der 2027-Version.
Größer oder was?
Ja, ich glaube, auf etwas mehr Reichweite optimiert. bei, also irgendwas haben
sie aber auch reduziert dabei.
Ich bin in dem ganzen Game da ja noch nicht so...
Ja.
Also normalerweise ist es so, oder sagen wir mal so, bei VW war das jetzt so,
dass sie, wenn am Anfang, wenn sie die Autos raushauen, ist die Ladegeschwindigkeit
noch etwas begrenzt, weil sie die Sache erst mal beobachten.
Und es kann sein, dass dann irgendwann ein Update kommt, wo sie noch ein bisschen mehr draufpacken.
Also jetzt bei dem Basis habe ich gesehen.
Das schnellste waren glaube ich 165 kW Ladeleistung.
Das ist der 85X dann sozusagen den hatten wir hier auch Sekunde.
Ja, aber ich meine 135 ist auch.
Na, 175 ist auf jeden Fall. Ladekurve ist natürlich, also okay,
die fällt dann aber auch früher ab.
Ja, so sehen Ladekurven aber aus. Also ich meine, das ist so.
Naja, die von dem Vorgängermodell sahen nicht so aus. Deswegen fand ich die
gerade ganz beeindruckend.
Interessant, dass die konstanter länger.
Ja, ja.
Das bedeutet aber nur, dass sie einen Peak abgeschnitten haben.
dass das Pack eigentlich noch mehr könnte im Bereich von 20 bis 40.
Der geht bis 100, geht da bis 70% und jetzt kannst du ja nochmal den anwenden.
Ja, das ist schon okay. Das ist völlig in Ordnung. Okay, darfst du erwerben.
Ja, danke. Ich bin es beruhigt.
Was heißt, du hast ihn jetzt bestellt und kommt wann?
September.
Aber dann kannst du ja trotzdem nicht im Sommer fahren.
Kann ich trotzdem, muss ich mit meiner B-Klasse noch eine Ehrenrunde noch mal fahren.
Also hast du jetzt zwei Monate früher, kannst du nicht in den Urlaub fahren,
aber dafür kostet es doppelte.
Ja, aber er hat auch das rechts unten.
Aber Ledersitze.
Ja, die Ledersitze hätte ich mir jetzt echt auch.
Also in der Freakshow gibt es keine Schelte für rechts unten.
Das muss man jetzt mal klarstellen.
Ich finde, bei Autos wäre das schon, also aber gut, das hat sich jetzt so ergeben
und ich werde berichten.
Achso, eine Anhängerkuppel hat er, das finde ich ja auch interessant und dann
da nämlich noch die Fahrräder draufpacken zu können oder so.
Was steht hier? 1500 Kilo.
1500?
Wow.
Ich kann fast mal einen Wohnwagen ziehen.
Ich habe glaube ich nur 1,2 oder so.
Allrad ist es aber glaube ich nicht, was hier gerade Q schreibt.
Ich glaube das ist der Front.
Nein, das ist vielleicht ein Nivellichter-Motor.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Kann sein, dass er vorne ist. Wenn er Allrad ist,
dann hat er sehr wahrscheinlich zwei Motoren.
Du hast ein Allradfahrzeug?
Nein.
Das kann sein. Also der ID. Polo ist jetzt auch wieder Fronttrieb,
während der neueste ID.3 ist nach wie vor Hecktriebler.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, ja. Naja, der ID.3 war immer Hecktriebler. Ich meine, der Bass ist auch
Hecktriebler. Die ganze ID-Reihe ist Heck.
Würde ich aber vermuten, dass es die Plattform ist, dass es auch Heck ist.
Auf jeden Fall hatte der einen fantastisch engen Drehradius, Kurvenradius.
Ja, dann hattest du wahrscheinlich auch einen Hecktriebler.
Weil das hat mich an der B-Klasse rasend gemacht. Das ist eine der Dinge,
die ich von Anfang an scheiße fand.
Durch diesen Elchtest hatten wir ja auch schon mal in der Sendung hier,
wo die A-Klasse umgekippt ist wegen zu enger Kurve und der Elch steht auf der Straße.
Da haben die ja bei der A-Klasse und bei der B-Klasse dann unter anderem einfach
so den Drehradius limitiert, dass gar keiner mehr so stark einschlagen kann, dass der umkippt.
Das ist ja eine tolle Lösung.
Super Lösung, genau. Aber das Problem hatte der jetzt mal echt nicht.
Der fühlte sich da sehr vieler einparktauglicher.
Das muss ich sagen, das haben die ganzen MEB-Autos eigentlich wirklich gut.
Dadurch, dass sie halt Hecktriebler sind, hast du halt vorne wirklich nur Lenkgedöns
und die schlagen sehr weit ein.
Also beim Bass ist es so, dass wenn ich im Stand wirklich ganz einschlage und
dann losfahre, schiebt er mir eigentlich über die Vorderreifen.
Weil er das gar nicht um die Kurve kriegt.
Das ist echt ganz merkwürdig. Rückwärts geht es, aber vorwärts, da muss ich aufpassen.
Tja.
Na dann, gratuliere.
Tja, schauen wir mal. So und in zwei Jahren geht das Game dann halt wieder von
vorne los und das finde ich aber so als Modell eigentlich ganz...
Oder du sagst, der ist dir so ans Herz gewachsen, dass du ihn übernimmst.
Ja, das habe ich gefragt, so ob wieder so die Chancen sind und dann meinte er,
da sollte ich mal don't hold your breath, weil also die normalerweise so kalkuliert
sind, dass sie dann in irgendwie ganz andere Verwertungsketten reingehen und
die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass mir dein Angebot gemacht sei, wäre eher gering.
Achso, das ist nicht deine Entscheidung?
Nee. Die Kiste gehört Skoda.
Klar, aber ich dachte, beim Leasing wäre generell Übernahme eine Option.
Also war wohl mal so, aber derzeit haben die das wohl nicht mehr nötig.
Mal gucken, was das wird.
Und wie sauber muss der dann sein, wenn man den zurückgibt? Wie sauber muss der dann sein?
Ja, das sind natürlich mit zwei so Kindern relevante Fragen.
Ja, aber auf Leder kriegst du die Kotze ja noch ganz gut weg.
Das war dann, dachte ich mir dann auch, dass da vielleicht Leder sogar noch
etwas... Gut, also kotzen tun die zum Glück alle nicht.
Naja, weiß man nie, weil welchen Fahrstil du jetzt an den Tag legst mit deinem neuen Elektromotor.
Naja, also grundsätzlich so dieser Umpf, mit dem man dann da plötzlich so in
den Sitz gedrückt wirkt. Also einmal auf der Landstraße habe ich es dann doch
mal ausprobiert mit Durchtreten.
Das ist natürlich schon lustig. Aber ich brauche das nicht.
Ja...
Ja, nee, du hast bei Elektroautos, wenn die vier Rad getrieben sind,
hast du meistens zwei Motoren.
Weil das viel zu teuer oder viel zu unhandlich ist, da irgendwelche Kardanwellen
am Boden noch zu verlegen.
Da baust du lieber einen zweiten Motor ein.
So, hier kommt schon der Kommentar. Ich freue mich jetzt schon auf Ralfs Reaktion,
wenn er das Ladeinfrastruktur Chaos kennt.
Das Allrad, schreibt er hier.
Ja, der X.
Genau.
Aber er hat ja den X nicht.
Ich habe nicht den X, sondern ich habe den… Ach so, ich dachte der X.
aber eben als 2027 Modell, genau, das heißt also der, der jetzt hier gerade
rumgeht, das ist glaube ich schon doch nochmal ein anderer, weil der ist noch nicht auf der Straße.
Kriege ich wirklich eins der ersten Modelle von denen. Von daher würde mich
das auch wundern, wenn der schon irgendwo Testdaten...
Naja, Weir Drive, da steht es auch.
Na, mal gucken, wann es für mich endlich mal ein Auto gibt. Ich habe immer das
Gefühl, für mich will keiner ein Auto bauen.
Naja, du hast aber mit deinem schweren Anhänger halt auch extreme Anforderungen, sage ich mal.
Extreme Anforderungen? Einen Wohnwagen zu ziehen ist doch keine extreme Anforderung.
Naja, doch schon.
Das gibt es schon seit 40, 50, 60 Jahren gibt es Fahrzeuge, die sowas ziehen können.
Was ist denn da extrem?
Extrem ist, dass die alle so niedrige Spezifikationen haben.
Ich meine, der Trick ist, du kannst natürlich für sehr viele Fahrzeuge nachträglich,
also gibt es zwei, im Prinzip zwei Wege,
entweder du baust richtig was anderes an, also es gibt so Nachrüstsätze,
auch für Fahrzeuge vor allem, die erstmal überhaupt gar keine Anhängerkupplung haben.
also was weiß ich hier auch so für alte Teslas und so weiter kannst du dir irgendwie
so fette Anhängerkupplungen ran machen, die richtig dann können die auf einmal ordentlich ziehen.
Da brauchst du aber eine Einzelabnahme, oder?
Naja, du brauchst mit dieser Anhängerkupplung sozusagen so ein Dokument,
was dann belegt, dass das alles ordentlich getestet ist und das passt schon.
Einzelabnahme.
Ne, ich weiß nicht, ob das abgenommen werden muss. Ich glaube,
das muss nicht abgenommen werden, sondern die bauen dir dann ein.
Naja, aber müssen es eingetragen.
Ja, ja, sicher. Aber die Dokumente gibt es.
Wenn es dann eingebaut ist, dann passt das auch.
Und dann kannst du dir aber auch für manche Modelle einfach so eine Auflastung per Dekret bekommen.
Also du kaufst dann bei so einer Bude, ich habe den Namen vergessen,
das findest du schnell, die machen einfach nur so Gutachten,
So nach dem Motto, ja, wir haben das mal richtig nachgerechnet und dann kannst
du dir irgendwie dieses Gutachten kaufen und mit diesem Gutachten alleine,
ohne irgendeine Modifikation, kannst du mit deinem Auto dann zum Tufrennen und
dir das irgendwie eintragen lassen.
Das ist eine Auflastung der Anhängerkupplung.
Ja, aber keine physikalische Änderung, sondern du darfst dann auf einmal mehr,
weil sie ja rausgefunden haben, dass es irgendwie geht und anstatt,
dass es einfach generell für alle Fahrzeuge dieses Typs gilt,
musst du das dann irgendwie einzeln erwerben, das ist irgendwie völlig gaga.
Naja, das gibt es wohl für Wohnmobile viel, wo du dann mit einer Auflastung
aber über 3,5 Tonnen kommst, hast aber dann halt das Problem,
dass Straßen, die gesperrt sind, ab 3,5 Tonnen darfst halt nicht fahren.
Ich habe da neulich so ein Pärchen kennengelernt, die haben da ein bisschen geklagt.
Dass sie sich das mit der Auflastung besser hätten überlegen sollen. Aber gut.
Arsene.
Wo wir hinfahren, haben wir keine Straßen.
Alter.
Sahara oder was?
Ihr wisst, wo das herkommt, oder?
Ja, natürlich weiß ich, wo das herkommt.
Ist es der Erste? Nee.
Ende vom Ersten.
Das ist das beste Filmende aller Zeiten.
Also wo wir jetzt schon bei Autos sind, also was mir ja ins Auge gesprungen ist, ist ja Hyundai.
Hyundai hat jetzt irgendwie angekündigt von dem Staria eine Elektrovariante rauszubringen Ich.
Dachte der Staria wäre insgesamt.
Elektrisch Ja das dachte man immer bei dem Staria weil der so aussieht aber der war nie,
elektrisch bis er jetzt in diesem Jahr das erste Mal elektrisch sein wird und
noch ist der gar nicht rausgekommen aber der ist halt schon immer so total futuristisch aus,
da vorne mit diesem Lichtstreifen und so weiter.
Also der hatte schon immer so dieses Design und den Appeal.
Aber der kommt tatsächlich jetzt erst so raus.
Das ist ja eigentlich die richtige Familienkarre. Da hast du ja so richtig so.
Einen Bus und dann mit vielen Sitzen und so weiter.
Ah, okay. Der ist aber schon sehr, sehr groß.
Der sieht sehr, sehr, sehr groß aus, aber er ist halt nicht,
also er ist nur länger als ein Adibas.
Ansonsten aber durchaus in derselben Kategorie.
Und ist auf jeden Fall ja.
Stimmt, der ist einen Ticken länger.
Der ist so 30 Zentimeter länger, ein bisschen steilere Seitenwände.
6 Zentimeter höher auch.
Mehr Volumen drin.
Aber die 6 Zentimeter, kann ich aus Erfahrung sagen, die sind eventuell der
Keller wegen Tiefgaragen.
Naja, kommt auf zwei Meter.
Ja, trotzdem, wenn da zwei Meter dran steht und du bist 1,99, hui, hui.
Ja, das mag sein.
Ja, ich kann jetzt auch gar nicht so viel sagen zu diesem Fahrzeug.
Das kann auch zwei Tonnen ziehen, deswegen hat es meine Aufmerksamkeit erhalten.
Auch in der Elektro-Variante?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was die andere kann. Ich interessiere mich nicht für Verbrennerfahrzeuge.
Der kann also zwei Tonnen ziehen. Und da dachte ich mir so, okay, alles klar.
Endlich mal ein Auto, was kann.
Der einzige Haken ist halt Fronttriebler.
Was ja eigentlich ganz cool ist für so einen Bus. Weil, ne?
Warum ist das jetzt deiner Meinung nach ein Nachteil?
Na, wenn du einen Wohnwagen hast, du willst den irgendwo rausziehen und deine
Kraft liegt vorne auf dem Auto und hinten hast du was Schweres dran,
dann gehen halt vorne die Reifen hoch.
Sagt der, wie viel Gewicht das Ding hat?
Bestimmt.
Oder? 2,3 Tonnen, da gehen hier keine Reifen hoch.
Nein.
Wenn hinten 1,8 Tonnen ziehen, gehen auch mal die Reifen hoch.
Wie gehen die Reifen nicht hoch? Natürlich gehen die.
Ja, aber nicht,
wirklich. Wie nicht wirklich?
Sie gehen halt hoch und dann hast du nicht mehr die volle Traktion.
Ja, trotzdem. Wo willst du denn fahren damit?
Auf einer Wiese.
Am Strand? Im tiefen Sand oder was?
Nee, Wiese. Ich habe das schon so oft gehabt. Wohnwagen aus einer nassen Wiese
rausziehen ist wirklich ein Problem.
Deswegen hätte ich gerne dieses Fahrzeug in Allrad und alle meine Träume werden erfüllt.
Egal, Zukunft. Als erstes kriegt Ralf sein Auto, dann seid ihr beide schon mal auf Elektro Vierrad.
Ich bleibe erstmal bei Elektro Zweirad.
Es gibt auch keine Updates von den Donuts irgendwie.
Wenn gleich, ja.
Die Donuts, ja.
Die Donuts.
I still do not believe, sag ich mal.
Ja, werden wir sehen. Ich habe auf jeden Fall auch meine Zweifel.
Ja, genau. Und dann, ich war sehr überrascht im Nachgang der letzten Sendung,
dass so viele Leute meinten, sie hätten ja noch nie von dieser THG-Quote gehört, die ich erwähnt hatte.
Das wundert mich allerdings auch, weil ich dachte, dass die Sau wäre so dermaßen
durchs Dorf getrieben worden.
Na, zumindest bei...
Aber vielleicht in meiner Bubble, gut, das kann durchaus sein.
Ja, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Bubble-Ding. Ich meine,
wenn man so wie du und ich ja auch so jahrelang schon irgendwelchen Elektrifizierungspodcasts
zugehört hat, wo das so gefühlt alle 20 Minuten ein Thema war.
Oder wenn man so wie ich schon seit acht Jahren elektrisch fährt.
Genau, na gut, aber es können ja durchaus sein, dass Leute auch seit acht Jahren
elektrisch fahren und noch nichts davon mitbekommen haben. Auf jeden Fall,
diese THG-Quote ist real und das ist sozusagen einfach Geld,
was einem nachgeworfen wird.
Treibhausgasminderungsquote heißt das offiziell und gibt seit 2015.
Und ich frage mich gerade, wie lange läuft das eigentlich noch?
Es läuft erstmal noch, ne?
Das läuft erstmal noch, weil das irgendwie...
Gibt es auf jeden Fall Geld für und...
Könnt ihr machen, wenn ihr also so ein Elektroauto habt, dann bekommt ihr dafür einfach Geld.
Ich weiß nicht, kriegt man das eigentlich auch, wenn man Leasing macht?
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon.
Ja, ja, ja. Da reichst du deinen Fahrzeugschein ein und dann kriegst du das Geld.
Also jetzt natürlich nicht physisch, sondern nur quasi ein Scan,
aber ja, ja, das wird auf das Auto dann und so weiter.
Genau, ich packe nochmal den Link dazu rein, dann klickt ihr da drauf,
dann kriegt ihr auch euer Geld.
So, genug Autos.
Was haben wir denn noch? Haben wir noch ein Thema? Ja, stimmt.
Das war ja gerade Republika.
Ralf, ich habe einen Vortrag von dir gesehen. Du hast da in besser Steve Jobs
Manier ohne Turtleneck Shirt allerdings, aber auch nicht im blauen Hemd.
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Oder doch?
Ich hatte irgendein Beatles Nerd Shirt mit Sakko drüber. Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Okay, also Casual Punk sozusagen.
Genau, Casual Punk. Ja, siehst du.
Das klingt aber eher nach Casual Beatnik.
Genau, ich habe dem auch beigewohnt und du hast ja da deinen Launch durchgeführt,
um mal zu gucken, wie das so läuft.
Gibt es irgendwas, was du dazu uns noch zu sagen möchtest? Oder ist das geheim?
Ohne die Keynote zu wiederholen.
Geheim ist es nicht. Es gibt ja auch, die Keynote ist keine Keynote,
es ist einfach so ein Lightning Talk.
Also die Republika hat ja ein sehr abgestuftes Verfahren, wann wer wie auf welche
Bühnen kommt und ein sehr niedrigschwelliges Format ist so in der Haupthalle,
haben sie zwei oder drei sogenannte Lightning Talk Bühnen noch so aufgebaut,
was einfach nur Stuhl rein vor irgendwie nicht, leider nicht sonderlich großem Screen.
Ich habe immer gerne wirklich sehr große Screens bei den Vorträgen nicht so
mache, aber es muss da halt reichen.
Genau und da habe ich das Projekt vorgestellt, was ich hier in der letzten Freakshow
oder vorletzten schon mal angespoilert hatte.
Nämlich Viblio. Genau, da sieht man auch mein Outfit schon mal gut bei dem Preview. Sehr gut.
Und wir hatten einen Stand auf der Republika von den Berliner Bibliotheken.
Gesponsort auch von der Senatsverwaltung für Kultur und gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt.
Vielen, vielen Dank nochmal in die Richtung, weil das ist nicht so ganz günstig, so ein Stand.
Und dort haben wir drei verschiedene Bereiche vorgestellt, unser Digitalzebra
und digitale Welten und eben jetzt neu unser Viblio.
Und mich hat da vor allen Dingen so als Republika ja doch eigentlich Freund,
also wir haben ja auch schon mal, Tim, viele Sachen gemacht auf der Republika
mit Sendezentrum vor Ort und so und mein erster echter Kontakt so mit dieser
ganzen Digitalwelt lange vorm Club war auch so die erste Republika vor,
ich weiß gar nicht, 15 Jahren oder sowas,
wo ich zum ersten Mal so gleichdenkende gefühlt gefunden habe,
endlich mal normale Leute.
Also von daher schlägt da so, bin ich emotional schon immer noch so,
Republika ist eigentlich doch
schon eine gute Sache. Johnny Häusler finde ich auch nach wie vor gut.
Ja und mich hat interessiert, okay, das was wir jetzt so seit mittlerweile drei
Jahren doch relativ intensiv beplanen und jetzt auch schon mal als Prototyp
oder Alpha gebaut haben,
so wie kommt denn das da draußen an bei Leuten, die schon alles gesehen haben
oder behaupten, alles schon mal gesehen zu haben, wie reagieren die so da drauf.
und dafür war das eigentlich so, dass das Test fällt, um mal zu gucken,
okay, wie kommen so die UX-Entscheidungen an, die wir da so getroffen haben
und ich muss mich übrigens bei dem Video für den Sound schon mal entschuldigen,
das ist natürlich hier nicht Freakshow-Standard,
der ist irgendwie super kaputt komprimiert und ich schreie da die ganze Zeit,
also ich finde, man versucht ja schon live immer eine gewisse Energie irgendwie
so in den Raum zu bringen und auch über...
Du schreist die ganze Zeit?
Der Sound ist schrecklich, ist es, als ob ich so in so einem Fisch stand.
Lass das doch einmal durch Auphonic laufen und lad es nochmal selber hoch.
Das macht, glaube ich, damit kannst du das Mikro, glaube ich,
selber nicht mehr. Du kriegst ja keine Dynamik mehr rein. Es ist einfach null Dynamik drin.
Gut, aber es ist jetzt so, wie es ist. Aber nicht, dass es euch wundert.
Das ist jetzt nicht der Content zählt.
Naja, und Und das Projekt, was ich da vorstelle, da glaube ich wirklich dran.
Ich glaube, es ist das Beste, was ich bisher gemacht habe.
Und wenn das gut wird, hat das vielleicht auch das Potenzial,
so die Art und Weise, wie Bibliotheken gesehen werden und was sie für eine Rolle
spielen, insbesondere in der digitalen Welt.
könnte das nochmal so ein bisschen auf den Kopf stellen und seit langerer Zeit
tingle ich halt damit so durch die Bibliothekswelt,
Und da heißt es immer, oh cool, dass es mal endlich jemand probiert.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Wir wünschen Ihnen viel Glück.
Und jetzt müssen wir es aber auch halt mal auf die Straße bringen und erste Communities.
Und wir müssen jetzt nicht im Detail nochmal den Talk nacherzählen.
Wie gesagt, das kann man sich dann anschauen, wenn man da grundsätzlich Interesse
daran hat. Aber so zwei, drei Grundclaims würde ich hier vielleicht doch mal reingeben.
Das erste ist diese Folie hier, die ich gerne zeige. Okay.
Das ist nämlich sicherlich etwas breitbeinig, der Ansatz so,
welche Systeme lösen wir eigentlich ab mit dem Biblio, was wir als Bibliotheken
anbieten wollen. Die Antwort ist alle.
Also, WhatsApp, Google Docs, Media Wiki, Dropbox, Slack, Reddit,
Microsoft Teams, Discord, Confluence, Signal, SharePoint, Facebook Groups,
nebenan.de, Zoom und Office 365.
Telegram nicht?
Oh scheiße, ich habe Telegram vergessen. Nein, also Telegram ist,
in unserer Zielgruppe nicht so verbreitet. Und es ist schon WhatsApp und Signal
drauf, da substituiert sich.
Und ex-Twitter auch nicht.
Genau, es ist kein Social-Media-Dienst.
Ah, okay.
So, das heißt, das, was wir eigentlich bauen, ist eine...
Software-Plattformen für Online-Communities, die aber im Hyperlokalen verortet sind.
Das heißt also nicht irgendwie so die 3D-Druckerszene von Deutschland verbindet
sich irgendwie in einer Community, sondern die fünf Leute,
vorhin sprachen wir schon über die, sich einmal die Woche im Makerspace der Bibliothek treffen.
So, die sind meine Zielgruppe. Das heißt, Communities, die schon unsere Bibliotheksstandorte,
und davon haben wir ja knapp 80 in Berlin, das heißt also, wir sind einfach mal auf der Straße,
ohnehin schon mit uns vernetzt haben, denen zu sagen,
ey, ihr wollt in Austausch gehen und bleiben und in Kontakt bleiben und wollt
mal 3D-Rezepte austauschen, das müsst ihr jetzt nicht mehr über WhatsApp machen
und ihr könnt euch nicht mal einigen, ob ihr nun WhatsApp oder Signal nehmt
und die einen wollen das und die anderen das.
We've Got You Covered. Hier haben wir eure digital souveräne,
von eurer Lieblingsbibliothek selbst betriebene Plattform, auf der ihr das alles machen könnt.
Und der Grund, warum ich sage so, das wird auch funktionieren,
die alle zu ersetzen, ist, dass wir halt als Plattform Discourse nehmen.
Also die Weltmarktführer im Open Source Community Building, die von den Machern
von Stack Overflow und seit zwölf Jahren, würde ich sagen, da unangefochtene
Platzhirsche in dem Bereich.
Und was halt wenig bekannt ist, ist, wie vielfältig die ihre Plattform mittlerweile ausgebaut haben.
Das heißt also, die haben eben auch einen Chat, der jetzt mittlerweile auch
Push-Notifications vernünftig schickt. Das heißt also, diese ganzen Features,
die du so in Slack hast, kannst du wirklich ziemlich eins zu eins nachbauen im Diskurs.
Nur, dass du im selben System auch ein Forum hast und im selben System auch
ein Wiki hast und im selben System auch ein Pad hast. und das auch innerhalb
flüssig in einem einzigen Diskussionsstrang.
Kannst du bei jedem einzelnen Beitrag sagen, ach du bist jetzt übrigens ein
Wiki-Beitrag. Da können jetzt alle dran schreiben.
Das heißt also, du hast einen großen Vorteil, dass Leute nicht fünf oder zehn
verschiedene Softwarepakete sich drauf abstimmen oder lernen müssen,
sondern nur ein einziges und das auch von der Bedienung her wirklich harmonisch ist.
Wir haben da noch ziemlich dran rumgeskinnt. Ich habe, glaube ich,
auch eine sehr talentierte UX-Designerin mir da eingekauft und,
Ja, das machen wir. Das sind die zwei Punkte, warum ich da optimistisch bin.
Erstens, die kochen auch alle nur mit Wasser, die anderen Firmen.
Was sie vor allen Dingen können, ist eben Skalierung und Marketing auf dem sozialen
Grafen. Das ist das, was die auszeichnet.
Und ihr hostet das jetzt, oder wie?
Genau, beziehungsweise bei einer Bude, Infrarun ist das in dem Fall.
Naja, lasst hosten, aber gut, ja.
Lassen hosten, aber bei gut bekannten Bediener-Tech-Buden unseres Vertrauens.
Ja, ich war jetzt nicht davon ausgegangen, dass in der Bibliothek im Keller ein Server steht.
Haben wir in der ZLB, wir haben ein kleines eigenes Rechenzentrum.
Wobei Rechenzentrum schon eine optimistische Interpretation ist.
Ein Serverraum.
Also für unsere eigenen Sachen reicht das, aber ich will dort keine Endnutzerdaten
selber irgendwo speichern bei mir in der Bibliothek. Das ist nicht mein Beritt.
Bei Anna Stabi hatte ich das gemacht. Da hatten wir ganz mit Lamberzelle und
so, konnten wir da ganz anders irgendwie von der Skalierung rangehen.
Aber hier möchte ich gerne irgendwie Profis haben, die sowas schon nachweislich
ein paar Mal gemacht haben.
Und genau, also das eine Argument ist, okay, die kochen alle von den Features
her nur mit Wasser. Ja, das ist eigentlich alles auserzählt,
was da an Features hinter ist. Das ist alles gut verstanden.
Nur die können halt skalieren. So, ich muss aber nicht skalieren.
So, ich brauche eben keine 10 Millionen oder 10 Milliarden Accounts,
sondern ich will genau die richtigen 50 Leute miteinander irgendwie vernetzen.
Und das skaliert, glaube ich, ganz entspannt über die Bibliotheken.
Das Zweite ist, ich muss keinen Euro in Werbung investieren,
um irgendwo einen sozialen Grafen aufzubauen oder die Leute von woanders irgendwie
wegzuholen, weil sie sind ja schon da.
Das heißt, die Bibliotheken haben schon ihren sozialen Grafen etabliert in ihrer Stadt.
Darum sind wir die besuchtesten Institutionen kulturell in Berlin und den meisten anderen Städten auch.
Das heißt also, ich kann schon aufsetzen auf einen sozialen Grafen,
der einfach schon da ist.
Dieser Kombination sage ich, das wird funktionieren.
Und jetzt müssen wir nur noch zeigen, dass es auch funktioniert.
Und ab wann läuft das jetzt alles so richtig?
Also wir werden jetzt über den Sommer die ersten zehn Communities ungefähr starten in Berlin,
wo wir also uns einzelne Player raussuchen, die mal dichter,
mal weniger dichter in der Bibliothek dran sind und gehen dann da mit Community
Managerin rein und stellen das vor.
Und das Konzept ist wirklich, du bist halt in der Bibliothek drin,
in deinem Workshop oder in deiner Lesung oder was auch immer und du hast einen
hochspezialisierten QR-Code an der Wand und du nimmst dein Handy,
scannst den, musst keine App runterladen,
kannst einfach nur deinen Username, E-Mail abgeben und bist dann sofort in dem
Chatraum drin, wo die anderen Leute, die im selben Raum physisch real stehen,
genau auch alle drin sind.
Das heißt, du musst also auch gar nicht erst suchen, wo ist jetzt nochmal diese
Community und wo ist nochmal irgendwie die ID und mein Gott ist das alles unübersichtlich,
sondern ein QR-Code hochspezialisiert pro Event,
der wird gescannt und dann sind die Leute, die richtigen Leute sind in dem Moment sofort beisammen.
Und die kriegen ja noch Invite-Codes, um dann noch irgendwie Freunde und Kollegen
reinzuholen, die es nicht vor Ort geschafft haben, aber dann auch sehr limitiert,
dass das Ganze dann auch nicht ausufert.
Und sprich, ich habe dann am Ende tausend Mini-Communities,
die auch gar nicht groß untereinander irgendwie in den Austausch treten müssen,
weil ich will deren kleines Community-Problem lösen und nicht die 95.
Politik-Schwarzbude für ganz Berlin hochziehen.
Warum ich auch glaube, dass wir weniger Probleme mit Trollen und Vandale und
ähnliches zu tun haben, weil an der Bibliothek kommen ja auch nur nette Menschen wissen wir ja.
Ist das so?
Ja, darum arbeite ich da.
Dann wird das wohl so sein.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren. Ich weiß nicht, es ist schon wirklich lange her,
dass ich mal in einer Bibliothek war Oh Gott!
Wieso? Oh Gott!
Super Bibliotheken!
Naja, Vielen Dank.
Das würde ich grämen. Aber ich
bin jetzt wirklich nicht so der Buchleser gewesen in den letzten Jahren.
Ich habe mich da noch sehr aufs Digitale fokussiert.
Und Bibliotheken waren halt irgendwie immer sehr, na wie soll ich sagen,
also meine Bibliothek war ja dann das Internet.
Also insofern bin ich den ganzen Tag in der Bibliothek unterwegs,
nur halt nicht in so einer physischen.
Ich muss sagen, in meiner Jugend habe ich auch ziemlich viel in der Bibliothek
Sachen ausgeliehen und gelesen, aber seitdem nicht mehr so sehr.
Also von den Statistikdaten her spiegelt es halt, das was wir an der Nutzung
sehen, ist halt genau das, was Rudi sagt.
Wenn du Kind und Jugendlicher bist, gehst du halt mit deinen Eltern erst in
die Bibliothek, so als Jugendlicher dann auch selber.
Und dann irgendwie so diese Young Idols, so ab 15, 16 Jahren,
Berichter laden dann in sich zusammen.
Ja, dann sind plötzlich Mädchen spannend
und Jungs und auch dafür ist die Bibliothek aber noch ein guter Ort.
Aber was du als Dating-Plattform meinst du?
Was hat dir alles nicht noch?
Ich sag dir, wisst ihr.
Da fehlen dann aber noch ein paar Apps in deiner Übersicht.
Ein Killer-Feature reiht sich ans nächste.
So, und dann verlieren wir die wirklich über lange, lange Zeit und dann so Mitte
30, Ende 30, Anfang 40 sehen wir die plötzlich wieder, die Leute,
weil sie dann halt mit ihren eigenen Kindern wieder in die Bibliothek reingehen.
So und das ist eine unserer Fragestellungen, die wir jetzt auch in Berlin haben.
Okay, wie können wir das mal durchbrechen?
So und wie können wir gerade so diese Altersgruppe dazwischen mal reaktivieren?
Tja.
So, was hier Q schreibt, Bibliotheken sind halt irgendwie 80er vom Image.
Das ist natürlich grundfalsch. Da muss man sich wirklich mal nur große europäische
Bibliotheken angucken.
So Aarhus oder sowas. In Holland gibt es auch tolle Bibliotheken,
was die mittlerweile so an Raumkonzepten auch einfach haben.
Plus so, okay, da steht halt ein 3D-Drucker.
Und da steht deine digitale Stickmaschine.
Also auch, was wir im Verbrauch einfach so an Hardware so haben.
was man da einfach nutzen kann. Das ist wie ein, ich sage immer,
das ist wie ein Huckspace for the rest of us. Das ist die öffentliche Bibliothek.
Und diese Transformation haben eigentlich deutschlandweit praktisch alle Bibliotheken
in den letzten zehn Jahren durchlaufen.
So weg vom Bestand, weg von den Buchregalen hin zu Orten, wo halt irgendwie
die Leute auch einfach ganz andere Dinge machen können.
Was aber immer noch was mit besser werden, Dinge lernen.
Also der Vergleich zum Huckspace ist da wirklich sehr naheliegend, finde ich.
Alright. So,
voraussichtlich, wenn wir uns, ich weiß nicht, haben wir uns überhaupt auf den
nächsten Sendungstermin schon geeinigt?
Glaube nicht, aber wir haben einen drin stehen.
Vielleicht bloß nicht, ob wir uns darauf geeinigt haben.
Ich konnte da glaube ich nicht bei dem, was zumindest im Kalender drin steht.
Aber warum ist das jetzt gerade Thema?
Weil in der Woche vor diesem Termin, von dem wir nicht wissen,
ob wir den haben, werden.
Verstehe.
Gibt es gleich zwei Veranstaltungen, an denen ich in irgendeiner Form teilnehmen
möchte. Das eine ist die ILA.
Die Luftausstellung.
Genau. Da werde ich hingehen und mir mal angucken, was jetzt so für tolle Raketen
gebaut werden mittlerweile. Also...
Das ist ja eine Leistungsshow der Luft und natürlich auch der Militärtechnik
und alles mögliche und Raumfahrt.
Also da gibt es sozusagen alle Aspekte von Dingen, die mich gerade sehr interessieren.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, da bin ich auf jeden Fall und werde berichten.
Und ein paar Tage vorher ist Worldwide Developers Conference von Apfel.
Die kein Geld investieren in AI und total abgehängt sind.
Zumindest wirkt es so.
Ja, aber die nach wie vor 80 bis 90 Prozent des Geldes, was auf diesem Planeten
mit Smartphone verdient wird, verdienen.
Und von daher eigentlich gar nicht so scheiße dastehen.
Sie machen ein paar Sachen richtig, willst du sagen.
Es ist nicht alles schlecht bei Apple.
Es ist nicht alles schlecht. Na gut, es war nicht alles schlecht.
Wie sehr man das auch nachhaltig behaupten kann, das wissen wir dann danach.
Natürlich ist mittlerweile Glaskugeling sinnlos, weil es ist ja das meiste,
also es fliegen so viele Gerüche, sagen wir mal so, es wird so viel darüber
geredet, dass es irgendwie gar keinen Spaß mehr macht, sich darüber Gedanken
zu machen, was denn vielleicht kommt. Also mir geht es zumindest so.
Ja gut, aber natürlich nur unter der Prämisse, dass all diese Gerüchte stimmen.
Aber allein, dass es schon so viele Gerüchte gibt, das macht es irgendwie schon unspannend.
Okay.
Weil du ja eh dann davon ausgehen kannst, dass auch vieles davon in irgendeiner Form stattfinden wird.
Naja, so ein bisschen versprochen wurde ja uns ja, dass jetzt dann mal ein Release
kommt, wo Dinge stabilisiert werden.
Es wurde uns ja nicht versprochen, sondern es wurde nur gerüchtet.
Versprochen wurde ja gar nichts.
Ach, Apple, na gut.
Verspricht nicht. Genau, aber vielleicht können wir ja trotzdem mal zum Ausdruck bringen, was denn,
uns denn so, was würde uns denn glücklich machen? Was würde dich denn glücklich machen, Roddy?
Na, wir haben ja zwei oder drei Sendungen ago sehr viel über Eckenradien und,
Icons und Inkonsistenzen aller Art gesprochen und ich glaube die Forderung daraus,
was uns denn glücklich machen würde, es liegt relativ auf der Hand,
wenn wir diesen ganzen Scheiß mal aufräumen würden.
Und das alles irgendwie wieder stimmig machen würden, wieder Mehr die Konsistenz
in den Vordergrund bringen.
Gerne auch diese dämlichen Icons aus den Menüs wieder rauswerfen,
die haben echt keinen Nutzen gehabt.
Und ja, ansonsten bin ich so ein bisschen, was würde ich mir wünschen?
Also was ich mir als Developer würde ich mir wünschen, dass sich Apple auch
einfach mal zusammenreißt und den Developern mal mehr wieder Liebe zukommen lässt.
Also ich habe da gerade, nee gerade ist gut, ich habe vor einem halben Jahr
ungefähr einen Bug reported,
wo ein Fehler, der schon seit drei Jahren existiert, beklagt wird.
Also meiner Meinung nach ist es ein Fehler.
Dann habe ich nochmal geguckt, im Forum gab es immer mal wieder Diskussionen
dazu, die irgendwie immer im Sande verlaufen sind,
weil irgendwo der Fehler zwischen dem Xcode-Team und dem Swift-Compiler-Team
irgendwo in der Ritze verschwindet, weil sich scheinbar keiner zuständig fühlt,
diesen Missstand abzumildern oder zu beheben.
keine Ahnung, also da würde ich gerne mal und dann halt, das habe ich naja,
wir hatten es vorhin schon.
Das Problem ist auch so ein bisschen diese Apple-Developer-Kiste wenn du einen
Apple-Developer-Account hast wo du,
mehr als eine App hast und vor allen Dingen hast du externe Teams,
die dann eine der Apps machen und dann musst du Benutzerrechte für dieses Team rausrücken,
willst ihn aber quasi nicht gleich zum Admin machen,
dann wird es extrem schwierig, weil du die Benutzerrechte nicht feingranular
genug aufteilen kannst.
was jetzt zum Beispiel dazu führte, dass vor zwei Wochen einer der Dienstleister
irgendwie unser Hauptzertifikat gelöscht hat.
Was super ist, nicht wirklich problematisch, weil man kann ja ein neues erstellen
und dann lädt man halt die App und signiert die App mit dem neuen Zertifikat
und dann geht es seinen Gang.
Aber das hat halt Staub aufgewirbelt, der eigentlich gerne mal hätte liegen
bleiben können. Also das ist so, solche Sachen, da bin ich dann so, na, keine Ahnung.
Und ansonsten, was ich gerne noch sehen würde, ist, dass sich in dieser ganzen iOS Vision OS Sache,
dass sich da ein bisschen mehr geöffnet würde und wir eine Annäherung an das
bekommen, was macOS ist.
Also wenn ich jetzt sage, ich will ein Terminal auf iPadOS haben und auf VisionOS,
dann sage ich das nicht wegen dem Terminal, sondern dann sage ich das,
weil ich finde, das System sollte offen genug sein, damit man auch Dinge tun
kann, die jetzt nicht gerade durch den App Store von Apple abgenommen wurden.
Wenn ich der Meinung bin, ich müsste das machen.
Also das Terminal ist an der Stelle mehr so ein ...
Wie soll ich sagen, das ist mehr so ein Ding, das zeigt, dass das System offen
ist und nicht das Tool per se.
Also klar, es gibt sicherlich hier einige Terminal-Reiter, die jetzt schreien,
wenn ich sage, Terminal ist jetzt nicht ganz so wichtig, aber es gibt halt Tools
oder das Erstellen eigener Tools, das Benutzen von Script-Sprachen aller Art,
um Dinge zu tun, die ich halt im Terminal machen kann, ist halt ein sehr,
sehr wertvolles und gutes Tool,
um Dinge zu skripten und zu tun und zu machen.
Und das fehlt mir bei iOS, bei Vision OS halt,
wo Apple Produkte auf den Markt wirft, die Pro heißen, aber nicht Pro sind,
weil man es als Pro-User nicht Pro benutzen kann. Und das nervt halt ohne Ende.
Also das ist meine Wunschliste. Das ist alles unrealistisch, aber ja.
Okay. Und du Ralf, hast du Wünsche, was dir verkündet werden soll?
Ach, ich habe doch jetzt meinen Linux.
Ernsthaft, ich bin da ganz entspannt, weil ich mir gerade meine Kicks woanders hole.
Ich habe ein bisschen die Hoffnung aufgegeben, dass die WWDC jetzt irgendwas
vorstellt, was mich so richtig anpiekt.
Wo ich denke so, oh, das ist ja geil, Apple. Das hast du aber gut gemacht.
Das überrascht mich jetzt. Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass ich das haben will in meinem Leben.
So die Hoffnung habe ich gerade nicht. Also es wäre schon mal schön,
wenn sie das mit der Konsistenz und der GUI und dem Design mal irgendwie vernünftig ...
Das war immer ihre Stärke. In die müssen sie reinspielen. Ja.
Ist einfach so.
Fehler stückchenweise wieder einfangen. Also ich gucke gerade wieder auf die,
oben die Kopfzeile, hier einfach nur in der Fotos-App.
Wir müssen es nicht neu auseinandernehmen. Wir sind uns ja eh einig,
dass konsistenzmäßig, selbst wenn man so wie ich vielleicht nicht so den ganz
so kritischen Grafikdesign-Blick hat, den ich einfach nicht so habe.
Trotzdem fällt selbst mir das auf, dass das alles so nicht so richtig geht und
nicht so richtig geil ist. Es fühlt sich nur mal so mittel an.
Also ich bin sehr interessiert, was Sie denn so mit Ihrem iPhone Fold vorhaben.
Aber das ist jetzt nichts wie WWDC, vermute ich zumindest.
Das würden Sie erst beim iPhone Event machen.
Naja, was wir sehen könnten, ist natürlich vorbereitende APIs, um,
wenn es einen witzigen Kniff an dem Fold gibt, dass sie quasi schon so halbwegs
vorwegnehmen, wie man das programmiert, was man dann aber noch nicht wissen darf.
Also um es mal den Leuten zu erklären, die vielleicht nicht die ganze Zeit ihre
Nase in der Gerüchteküche haben, mit diesem Fold ist sozusagen das Gerücht gemeint,
es könnte ja sein, dass Apple ein iPhone-Modell rausbringt,
was mehr als ein Bildschirm hat und was man in irgendeiner Form aufklappt und
vergrößert, vorne, hinten, was auch immer machen kann.
Ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen, weil ich das für so gar nicht Apple
halte, aber ich lasse mich überraschen. Wenn Leute das gut finden und kaufen.
Dann ist es… Welchen Teil findest du daran nicht Apple?
Das Klappen, das Fold, dieses, das, das, also, also, Apple hat,
jetzt mal abgesehen von Laptops,
eigentlich schon sehr lange kein Gerät mehr gebaut, was irgendwie einen Klapparatismus
hat. Was man irgendwie aufklappt oder so.
Außer Laptops.
Außer Laptops, ja. Aber auch bei Laptops faltest du nicht den Screen auseinander.
Und Apple hat zum ersten iPhone ganz klar dieser Klappmechanik,
die irgendwie so Sony Ericsson und wie sie alle hießen,
das war ja fürchterlich beliebt und Apple kam mit diesem Candybar-Style,
wie man ihn damals nannte, auf dem Markt, wo nichts geklappt hat und so weiter.
Man hatte ein Stück, massives Stück etwas in der Hand und das hat sich nicht bewegt.
Und ich glaube, dass die Wertigkeit dessen, ich habe ein massives Stück etwas
in der Hand, glaube ich, auch viel zählt.
Zumindest vielleicht für Apple. Deswegen halte ich es für, wenn du ein Klapp-Display
hast, dann ist das Display ja in irgendeiner Weise halt auch eine Folie,
die sich bewegen kann und so weiter.
Also für mich klingt das überhaupt nicht nach Apple.
Aber genau deshalb, also da traue ich Apple zu in Sachen Hardware,
dass sie da was Irres machen.
Wo man denkt so, okay, erstaunlich, dass das noch keiner, aber jetzt ja, es macht Sinn.
Ich lasse mich gerne überraschen, aber ich kann es mir einfach beim besten Willen
nicht vorstellen, dass Apple das macht.
Aber da sind die Gerüchte so laut und auch schon so langer Zeit.
Das kann ja auch einfach sein, dass ich da falsch liege und dass wir uns dann
fürchterlich beschweren, weil es vielleicht dann doch irgendwie billig wirkt,
weil man möglicherweise ein Faltdisplay halt einfach nicht in Edel hinkriegt, wir wissen es nicht,
aber wenn du sagst, ja vielleicht macht Apple da auch was super geniales und
es wird alles super und toll, naja dann, wir werden sehen.
Also sagen wir ja häufig, die Hardware-Spalte ist gerade nicht das Problem von
Apple und ich glaube, wenn sie dann sowas rausbringen und in so einen Markt
plötzlich reingehen, da werden die sich schon ordentlich auf die Hinterbeine gestellt haben.
Also so oder so wird das jetzt nicht in zwei Wochen.
Genau, das denke ich auch so.
Nein, sicherlich nicht. Es ist auch so, dass selbst, also wenn sie das täten,
dann hätten sie auch alle Technologien am Start, dass Apps das benutzen könnten,
ohne dass das jetzt irgendwie alles neu geschrieben werden muss.
Was mich interessieren würde, ist, wenn sie macOS eben touchfähig machen.
So, aber da sind wir jetzt gefühlt irgendwie auch noch ein Jahr in der Hardware
nicht, wenn man da wiederum der anderen Gerüchteküche hört.
Das heißt also, dass MacBook Pros mit Touch-Display rauskommen.
Das ist wie diese Gerüchteküche alles kaputt macht.
Ja, aber gut. Also dann wäre es auch blöd, wenn sie jetzt was vorstellen,
was du erst im Dreivierteljahr kaufen kannst. Das wäre auch nicht Apples Teil so.
Naja gut, aber ich glaube, dass das...
Dass der PC-Markt mit Windows und Touch und Survival gezeigt hat,
dass das nicht unbedingt etwas ist, was jetzt reißerisch einen Mehrwert bietet,
wenn ich jetzt ein Touch-Display auf dem Laptop habe.
Also vielleicht ist es dann noch weniger Touch als mehr der Pencil.
Also mein MacBook so umklappen können, dass es ein Tablet-artiges Dingsi ist,
wo ich mit dem Stift drauf zeichnen kann und mit skribbeln kann irgendwelche
Notizen. Das finde ich schon ganz geil.
Aber eben andererseits nicht ständig der Limitierung eines iPads unterworfen zu sein.
Sondern eben einfach so, ich klappse halt ein bisschen weiter rum.
Also mich würde der Pencil mehr interessieren als Touch, sagen wir mal so.
Aber ich klappse ein bisschen weiter rum, da bin ich wieder bei dem Thema Klapparatismus.
Ja, das kriegt Apple hin.
Gut, sei es drum.
Jetzt seid ihr aber doch beim Glaskugeling. Ich wollte ja nur eine Wischlist haben.
Ja, da ist ja nichts.
Wie, da ist nichts. Du bist wunschlos glücklich. Du hättest kein Linux auf deinem
Mac. Mal gucken, macht vielleicht Apple das Jahr.
Ich wäre schon mal sehr glücklich, wenn Mail nicht abstürzen würde.
Ich habe jetzt wieder die allerneueste Nightly-Bild drauf hier von,
was ist es jetzt mittlerweile, 16.5, 18.6, was auch immer. Was ist hier?
26.
Aber sich zu beschweren, dass bei einer Beta was abstürzt, finde ich jetzt aber auch...
Es stürzt seit drei Jahren ab.
Das ist kein Problem.
Mir ist in den letzten drei Jahren Mail nicht abgestürzt, aber vielleicht viermal am Tag.
Wenn es im Hintergrund ist. Ich mache überhaupt nichts.
Mir fällt noch was ein und das ist wahrscheinlich nochmal ein Thema,
was Apple auch so schnell nicht angehen wird, ist dieses ganze App-Store-Thema.
Das ist ja doch ein Monopol ist in gewisser Weise. Ich weiß,
da haben wir auch schon sehr kontrovers darüber diskutiert.
Es wäre nur, glaube ich, am Ende des Tages für Apple wahrscheinlich günstig,
wenn sie da ein bisschen weniger den Arsch zukneifen würden und ein bisschen
mehr zulassen würden und nicht von Anfang an versuchen,
irgendwie alle Konkurrenten auf der eigenen Plattform direkt wieder fortzujagen.
Keine Ahnung, ob das realistisch ist oder ob sie da halt auch wirklich von der
EU erst an der Nase durch den Ring gezogen werden müssen, bis da mehr passiert.
Ja, aber das ist was, was ich mir wünschen würde.
Was wünschst du dir denn, Tim?
Also ich wünsche mir erstmal, dass wir eine starke Konzentration auf macOS sehen,
weil macOS ist einfach die größte Baustelle.
Also das iPhone funktioniert soweit ganz gut, das gilt in gewisser Hinsicht
auch für das iPad, also das was Apple bisher davon wollte, was es sein soll,
das finde ich haben sie auch ganz gut hinbekommen.
Ich habe im Wesentlichen keine Probleme mit meinem iPhone.
Irgendwas ist immer, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich jetzt irgendwie den
ganzen Tag abkortze, wie furchtbar doch dieses iPhone ist oder das iPad.
Da stellen mich eher so Marginalitäten, die wirklich nur mit meiner persönlichen,
Nutzung was zu tun haben, wie zum Beispiel, dass ich jetzt kein neues iPad Pro
kaufen kann, weil sie das Cover, was sie bis vor diesem Modell hatten, nicht mehr anbieten.
Und ohne das Cover will ich das nicht haben.
Also dieses Smart Keyboard-Folio, was sie ja ewig hatten, wo einfach so eine.
Klappe drauf hast und da ist die Tastatur mit drin und du kannst es so schnell aufstellen.
Das war so perfekt und jetzt haben sie nur noch diese ganzen Scheiß-Cover und
diese furchtbar schweren Teile, die das dann so zum Laptop machen,
damit wir nichts zu tun haben.
Deswegen habe ich mir noch kein neues iPad geholt und bin immer noch auf meinem 2018er-Modell.
Bei iPadOS gibt es vielleicht eine Sache, die ich noch anmerken würde,
diese Window-Management.
Ich will das jetzt mal anbringen. Also Also,
iPhone, iPad ist irgendwie alles okay soweit.
Ich fände es ganz gut, wenn Ihnen mal vielleicht was einfällt,
wie dieses Apple TV noch ein bisschen sinnvoller sein könnte.
Da würde sich zum Beispiel mal so eine Home-Visualisierung mal extrem lohnen.
Also dass man auf dem Gerät, was der Controller ist und was ein Bildschirm hat, weil es ja TV ist.
Nicht in der Lage ist, irgendwie mal ein Smart Home zu visualisieren in irgendeiner
Form oder mal so Daten einzusammeln und mal anzuzeigen, wie der Stromverbrauch
war oder die Temperatur in den letzten zwei Monaten,
obwohl sie da ausreichend Speicher, Cloud, Internet, Verfügbarkeit, Strom.
es ist alles da, sie müssen es nur tun und das fehlt schon immer,
also tvOS ist für mich irgendwie schon immer so ein bisschen der Garten der
verpassten Chancen bei Apple, weil ja okay gut ich kann da so eine App aufmachen,
kann ich mir auch was angucken mache ich ehrlich gesagt relativ selten,
also oder gerne macOS drauf und dann hätte ich gerne so einen billigen kleinen Mini-Me.
Hat aber jetzt auch für mich auch nicht so die große Bedeutung.
Der Mac ist einfach das wichtigste Gerät.
Und ich finde, es ist alles so unklar, wohin sie eigentlich wollen. Also es gab...
App-Kit, um sozusagen Anwendungen für den Mac zu entwickeln und viele benutzen
das ja auch heute noch, weil das sieht zwar irgendwie anders aus als der ganze iOS-Kram,
ja, aber da kannst du irgendwie alles machen.
Dann sind sie dann irgendwann gekommen mit, ja, jetzt haben wir aber eine neue
PoMU-Sprache und jetzt könnt ihr hier mit SwiftUI Dinge machen,
aber alle, ich meine, ich arbeite damit jetzt nicht, aber alle bestätigen immer wieder so,
damit kann man aber nicht alles machen, was man jetzt mit AppKit machen kann.
Und es ist buggy und es wird irgendwie nicht richtig gepflegt.
Es hängt hinterher ohne Ende.
Es ist halt nix Halbes, nix Ganzes.
Andererseits ist aber dieses AppKit auch irgendwie, ja, wird dann eben auch,
ist halt auch nicht der Pfad in die Zukunft, sondern es ist halt irgendwie das,
wie das so bisher war und ich weiß nicht, ob sie da überhaupt noch irgendwie groß was dran machen.
Also auf jeden Fall haben sie zwei verschiedene Wege, irgendwie Anwendungen zu denken.
Drei.
Die dritte ist UI-Kit. UI-Kit läuft auf dem Mac?
Ja.
Du kannst eine beliebige iPad-App auf dem Mac laufen lassen.
Ach so, okay, ja, stimmt, genau. Und dann gibt es auch noch UIKit und UIKit
kann aber auch nicht alles, was AppKit kann und kann, ist aber dann auch nicht
irgendwie jetzt SwiftUI oder doch irgendwie dann da drin?
Nein, also zumindest unter iOS ist es so, dass SwiftUI im Wesentlichen quasi
eine Scripting-Sprache für UIKit ist.
Du sagst SwiftUI, was passieren soll.
Deklarativ halt.
Deklarativ, was passieren soll und SwiftUI baut dir im Hintergrund mit UIKit
deine Oberfläche zusammen.
Wobei es durchaus sein kann, dass es da Views gibt, die nicht mit UIKit gebaut werden.
Ich habe es nicht alles dekompiliert und mir angeguckt, aber im Großen und Ganzen,
wenn man reinguckt, dann ist das alles immer noch UIKit.
Genau, also was wir haben, ist einfach eine hybride Situation.
Ja, also beide Systeme sind nicht vollständig irgendwie.
Also das eine wird nicht so richtig in die Zukunft entwickelt und das andere
deckt die Vergangenheit nicht ausreichend mit ab.
Und es gibt überhaupt gar keinen klaren Pfad, geschweige denn in irgendeiner
Form eine Anstrengung, wo man mal sagt,
das ist wie wir jetzt in Zukunft Anwendungen entwickeln und so machst du das
Cross-Plattform und da kannst du auch alles machen, was man machen muss.
und dann sieht deine Anwendung auch immer noch aus wie eine Mac-Anwendung.
Weil das, was sie jetzt selber da liefern, an, also was weiß ich,
diese Home-App zum Beispiel, habe ich ja neulich schon drüber abgekotzt.
Das ist ja sowas von,
unfassbar scheiße. Also wirklich.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch einfach die iPad-App. Fertig.
Ja, aber ich meine, was erlaube Apple? Das ist einfach, das geht überhaupt nicht.
Also das ist nicht nur ein bisschen schlecht, sondern das ist richtig scheiße ist das.
Da kannst du ja fast alle Apple-eigenen Apps mittlerweile nehmen.
Ja, aber wir sind jetzt auf dem Mac wirklich an der Stelle, wo Windows irgendwann
war, als sie angefangen hat zu reskinnen.
Und immer drei Klicks deep hast du dann noch das alte Windows NT Antlitz.
Ja, das ist bis heute so.
Das ist bis heute so. Und da hat Tim vollkommen recht.
Sie müssen eigentlich den ganzen Scheiß mal rauswerfen. Sie müssen sich einfach
mal hinstellen und sagen, AppKit ist jetzt deprecated.
Das können Sie natürlich bei dem Zustand, den UI-Kit auf dem Mac hat,
nicht machen und das können Sie bei dem Zustand, den SwiftUI auf dem Mac hat,
schon gleich dreimal nicht machen.
Deswegen schleppen sie den Scheiß hinterher, was natürlich auch Ressourcen kostet,
aber am Ende des Tages ist dieses ganze View-Modell, wie baue ich Views,
wie baue ich Fenster, wie baue ich alles das, das ist alles Next Step.
Das ist wirklich alter Scheiß und das müssen sie einfach auch technisch loswerden,
sonst haben sie da einen Klotz am Bein.
Genau und da fehlt mir einfach die Strategie, da fehlt mir einfach die klare
Ansage, so wird das jetzt stattfinden und vor allem auch die Garantie, dass auf so einem Weg…,
zu diesem modernen Ding nicht nochmal 30 Sachen rausgeschmissen werden,
die auf dem Mac schon immer geil waren.
Das ist ja die eigentliche Angst, dass einfach bestimmte Dinge dann,
überhaupt nicht mehr so funktionieren wie früher und wenn jetzt sich alles so
benutzen lassen würde, wie diese Musik-App oder so, also ich meine, wie du schon sagst.
Na gut, die war aber immer schon ein bisschen kacke.
Die war mal ganz toll, als die noch ganz am Anfang war iTunes richtig gut.
ITunes war mal richtig gut.
War mal richtig gut. Und das ist mittlerweile, also ich meine,
ich bilde mir ja ein, dass ich
jetzt die 40 Jahre, die ich mich jetzt mit Computern aktiv beschäftige.
Was suchst du?
Die Bestätigung, dass sein Mikrofon aus ist. Das ist das, was er tut.
Ja, Tim hat diesen Monitor davor geklappt.
Ja, beschwere dich mal bei Rodekassa, dass ich das nicht auslesen kann,
sonst hätte ich hier schon längst so eine Lampe in der Mitte, wo das zu sehen wäre.
Anyway, ich will meinen Ran zu Ende bringen. Ähm,
Also, das ist das Wichtigste.
Sie sollen sich hinstellen und sagen, wir bitten um Entschuldigung,
ich weiß, das werden sie nicht tun, aber so gefühlt, dass sie sich jetzt mal
wieder um den Mac kümmern und dass sie diesen ganzen furchtbaren Zustand entfernen.
Sie haben ja jetzt einen neuen CEO. Also es wäre ja möglich.
Dass...
Aber ist da nicht der neue Typ?
Ja, ab September.
Das wäre jetzt für die, wie wir jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen früh.
Trotzdem könnte er sich hinstellen und sagen, wir haben jetzt...
Ich weiß nicht,
ob... Also keine Ahnung, wie sie das drehen werden.
Der wird sicherlich in diesem Video, was sie dann veröffentlichen,
Es gibt ja gar keine ordentliche Bühnenpräsentation mehr. Das könnten Sie mal ändern.
Das würde ich mir auch wünschen.
Aber es ist weiter unten. Also wenn Sie macOS ordentlich fixen,
dürfen Sie weiter Ihr komisches Video machen. Bin ich der Meinung.
Ja und ich finde, Sie müssen macOS nicht nur fixen, sondern Sie müssen es,
noch viel besser werden lassen.
Also es gibt einfach Sachen, wo ich mich frage, was macht Apple eigentlich beruflich?
Also ich weiß ja nicht genau, wie eure Macs sich so verhalten,
aber ich habe hier auf vielen meiner Systeme teilweise so ein Safari und dann
klickt man irgendwie auf so eine Anwendung und dann vergehen auf einmal mehrere
Sekunden, bis irgendetwas reagiert.
Und das habe ich einfach zu oft, dass es unklar ist, was jetzt hier eigentlich ist.
Ja, verbrauchen die Programme jetzt zu viel Speicher gerade oder verbrauchen die gerade zu viel CPU?
Oder wartest du gerade auf irgendwas oder ist irgendwas zu langsam?
ich kann jetzt Aktivitätsmonitor
Top irgendwelche Prozesstools auf
der Kommandozeile starten und mit Copy und
Paste in ChatGPT reinwerfen und sagen erklär mir mal was auf diesem Gerät gerade
los ist und dann wird er mir irgendwas erzählen aber dieses System scheint ja
nicht in der Lage zu sein sich selbst zu überwachen und mal sicherzustellen
dass das hier auch alles ordentlich läuft Also ich finde,
dass diese ganze Integrität des Computers selber,
hier wird nicht in ausreichendem Maße sichergestellt, dass das gut läuft.
Der muss doch in der Lage sein zu erkennen, wenn er langsam ist,
der muss doch in der Lage sein zu erkennen, dass hier gerade Speicher das Problem
ist. tatsächlich muss man irgendwie mit obskuren Tools raten, was vielleicht ist.
Und gerade Speicherkram ist ja wirklich komplex heutzutage.
Der Computer hilft mir aber nicht dabei, in irgendeiner Form herauszufinden,
was denn jetzt hier eigentlich gerade das Problem ist.
Also nicht mit Bordmitteln.
Ja.
Ja und iStats Pro gibt halt auch irgendwie, ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel gerade
einen aktiven Swap von 3 Gigabyte.
Ja, was heißt das?
So, warum eigentlich? Mein Speicherdruck ist 56%, 82% Speicher belegt,
da müsste eigentlich noch Puffer sein, ich habe gar nicht so viel auf. So, warum eigentlich?
Ja, also ich habe so eine Facette, die schließt an, weil du es gerade sagtest,
du drückst was und Dinge passieren nicht.
Das Problem habe ich zusehends aber bei allen möglichen Dingen auf Apple-Geräten gerade.
So, das habe ich vergessen in der Folge, die wir gemacht hatten,
hier zu Buttons und physische Buttons und warum die alle so komischen State
haben und sich irgendwie zig Belegungen und sowas.
Ich habe zusehends das Problem, dass ich auch auf dem iPhone Buttons drücke,
die Animation abgespielt wird, ich habe erkannt, dass dieser Button gedrückt
wird und es passiert aber nichts.
Und dann muss ich den nochmal drücken, bevor wirklich irgendwas passiert.
Ist das aber gar nicht unbedingt, finde ich, ein macOS-Problem.
Auf macOS habe ich das auch, aber fast noch weniger als auf dem iPhone.
Ich denke so, was läuft denn da eigentlich gerade schief? Wenn mir schon die
richtige Animation abgespielt wird, ist es ja offensichtlich getriggert worden,
aber was dahinter läuft denn eigentlich jetzt gerade ins Leere?
Ja, also irgendwie, Ich finde, es gibt einfach viel Potenzial dafür,
dieses System solider zu machen, ein bisschen self-aware zu machen,
den Nutzer da besser mitzunehmen und klar,
Konsistenz im User-Interface ist wichtig, aber ich würde sagen,
womit sie mich wirklich beeindrucken können, ist Performance.
Performance, Performance, Performance, Performance, Performance, Performance.
Also jedes bisschen verstrichene Zeit einfach eine Lösung finden.
Zum Beispiel, was mich seit Jahrhunderten schon stört. Ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich auch.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz in mich gehen, damit ich das jetzt auch richtig beschreibe.
Ähm...
Das Programm, was gerade in der Front ist, tut irgendwas.
Im Vordergrund, sagt man.
Ja, im Vordergrund.
Das tut etwas, tut irgendwas.
Das hier ist mal gut.
Ja, genau. Und dann ist es aber sehr mit sich selber beschäftigt.
Und dann klicke ich aufs Apfelmenü.
und dann reagiert es aber nicht, weil das Programm, was im Vordergrund ist,
mich sozusagen daran hindert.
Ah, ja, das kenne ich.
Dann klicke ich ein anderes Programm an, was dann im Vordergrund ist,
während dieses andere Programm immer noch dasselbe tut, was es eben gerade getan
hat, was auch immer es ist, was es tut,
und dann, wenn das zweite Programm im Vordergrund ist, durch dieses Dahin klicken,
dann kann ich das Apfelmenü anklicken und dann geht es auch rauf.
Ja, habe ich täglich.
Das ist so, da sitze ich so davor und denke mir so, Leute, was? Ich meine.
Das ist so wie der Mauscursor.
Das kann, das ist, kann, also das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
Kann euch, das kann das sein, dass euch das noch nie...
Das ist aber garantiert seit 20 Jahren schon so.
Ja, na und?
Na, ich hätte gesagt, seit anderthalb Jahren ist mir das zum ersten Mal passiert.
Das ist noch nicht so alt.
Nee, nee, das ist schon immer drin, weil das halt, Weil da halt irgendwas ganz
Grundsätzliches das verhindert.
Weil irgendwie das Apple-Menü dann zu dem Programm irgendwie gehört und dann
Events schleifen und so weiter.
Ja, zu dem Menü dazu gehört.
Das ist halt einfach alles nicht wirklich Multiprocessing. Also hier werden
schon mehrere Cores benutzt, aber das liegt natürlich auch daran, dass sie halt ...
Weil das halt alles mit diesen minderwertigen Programmiersprachen programmiert
ist, die nicht wirklich parallel sind.
Naja, ich meine, in solchen Sachen kommt es doch immer wieder zum Vorschein.
Mit den normalen Programmiersprachen programmierst du halt immer so lange Singles, bis es nicht mehr geht.
So, da geht halt meistens noch eine ganze Menge.
Und deswegen ist das alles nicht gleichzeitig. Ich meine, auf BOS damals,
als so der Mac gegen die Wand fuhr, so ganz langsam mit dem alten MacOS.
Und da kam dieses BOS raus von diesem Jean-Louis Garcet.
Das war halt in keiner Hinsicht ein vollständiges Betriebssystem,
wenn man das aus der Perspektive von macOS betrachtet hat.
Weil da fehlten halt tonnenweise Frameworks, all dieser ganze Kram,
der Desktop-Publishing ermöglicht hat und all die ganzen anderen Sachen.
Angeblich konnte es nicht mal mehr drucken. Also Louis Garcet hat mir widersprochen,
als ich das mal getweetet habe.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Doch, ich glaube, so einfache Sachen waren schon drin.
Aber es war jetzt kein vollständiges OS.
Aber es war so eine Freude, allein nur auf dem, was da war, herumzuklicken,
weil es einfach auf eine Art und Weise...
metallisch responsiv war. Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Ja, ja, absolut.
Also es hat einfach, was auch immer du angeklickt hast, es hat sofort Klonke gemacht.
So wie auf Linux.
Das war aber zu einer Zeit, wo das tatsächlich überhaupt gar nicht üblich war.
Also Apple war noch tief in der Classic-MacOS-Phase drin und andere konnten
eigentlich, waren froh, wenn sie ein Fenster aufgekriegt haben.
Also jetzt muss man nicht Linux sagen, das ist irgendwie, zu dem Zeitpunkt gab
es Linux-Desktops, aber da konntest du halt die Einstellungen aufmachen und
dann konntest du irgendwie… Kaffee holen.
Nee, Kaffee holen nicht, aber du konntest da nichts Sinnvolles einstellen,
weil alles anderes musstest du auf der Kommandozeile machen.
Das war ja kein richtiges Betriebssystem damals. Ja.
Ja, also und die B-Box, auf der das dann so flüssig lief, die hatte ja nur zwei
Prozessoren, also zweimal ein Core sozusagen. Also nicht Dual-Core.
Ja und dann diese LED-Laufleisten an der Front.
Genau und das war einfach alles super responsiv und da hat man einfach gesehen,
wenn man das will, dann geht das auch.
Und diesen Willen, den sehe ich halt nicht.
Also es muss einfach möglich sein, dieses System in eine Richtung zu treiben,
wo es einfach kompromisslose Responsivität bietet.
Also wo einfach immer alles, was gemacht werden kann, in dem Moment auch gemacht wird.
Und das nicht irgendwie die ganze Zeit auf irgendwas gewartet.
Die Frage ist halt, wie sich sowas dann beispielsweise zu Akkulaufzeiten verhält.
Ob das nicht genau die Ebene ist, an der sie halt auch tunen,
um diese Energieeffizienz hinzunehmen.
Das hat mit Akkulaufzeiten nichts zu tun.
Ja, weißt du es?
Wenn du dich immer quasi irgendwo zwischendrängelst, weil jetzt muss es ganz, ganz schnell gehen.
Nein, das ist Quatsch. Das ist Blödsinn. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Es sind ja alles nur doofe Blockierungen und interne Blockierungen.
Da wartet irgendeiner auf irgendwas, dass irgendwas passiert. Ja, Rädchen.
Und es passiert aber nix.
Aber weil da gewartet wird auf eine Art und Weise, die anderen in dem Moment
nicht erlaubt, was zu tun, obwohl sie das tun könnten, weil der andere ja nur
wartet, das ist diese typische Blockierung von Singles-Thread-Programmierung.
Und das ist halt alles irgendwie noch gefühlte Singles-Thread-Welt.
Das ist nicht wirklich parallel.
Das hat viele Kerne, aber die meisten Kerne langweilen sich.
Ich meine, ich habe das doch hier auch mit dem Reaper.
Ich rendere da meine Sachen raus und irgendwie die Platte, SSD,
alles schnell, die Datenmengen, die ich da bewege, überhaupt kein Ding.
Und die CPUs langweilen sich.
Warum? So auf 80 Prozent sind die.
Aber nicht auf 100.
Langweilen tun sie sich nicht.
Die sind nicht auf 80 Prozent, die Cores. Nie und nimmer sind die auf 80.
Die sind vielleicht auf 20 Prozent, während er das macht.
Na gut, aber vielleicht gibt es auch nichts zu tun.
Er rendert mein Projekt raus. Natürlich gibt es was zu tun.
Wie, es gibt nichts zu tun. Es gibt genug zu tun. Das ist nicht ausreichend parallelisiert.
Ja, aber das Projekt rausrendern, es ist ja kein Effekt und nichts drauf. Da tut sich ja nichts.
Da musst du ja nur einmal Daten reinziehen auf der anderen Seite und auf der
anderen Seite wieder rausschreiben.
Genau, aber warum dauert das so lange? Warum ist die CPU nicht zu 100 Prozent?
Vielleicht, weil deine SSD so langsam ist.
Bei den Datenmengen? Nee, niemals. Wenn ich dieselben Daten kopiere,
dauert es ja nur ein paar Sekunden.
Man kann ja noch nicht zehn Minuten mit beschäftigt sein, irgendwie etwas durchzuführen,
was nur zwei Sekunden dauert.
Aber du weißt, dass es Probleme gibt, die nicht parallelisierbar sind.
Ja, ganz wenige nämlich.
Nee, die meisten eigentlich.
Das ist Unsinn. Du kannst immer alles paralysieren, bis der Arzt kommt.
Man muss halt nur ordentlich, das ist halt das Ding, das Software Engineering.
Vielleicht solltest du da mal vorstellig werden.
Ich werde ja gerade vorstellig. Dieser Podcast wird ja selbstverständlich von
der vollständigen Software Engineering Zentrale in Cupertino angehört.
Sonst hätte es ja gar keinen Sinn, das hier so vorzutragen. Also, Wishlist.
Ja, Wunschliste. Ist wie Weihnachten. Man kriegt nicht alles,
was man will, aber wenn du mich fragst, was ich will, ich möchte eine Konsolidierung von macOS.
Ich will, dass da ein ordentlicher Pfad in die Software Zukunft gezeigt wird,
weil da befinden wir uns nicht.
Da befindet sich niemand, auch dein Linux nicht, dass es auch nicht die Bohne,
multithreaded in irgendeiner Form.
Ja, da laufen mehrere Cores und man kann viele Prozesse, aber das ist nicht
das, was ich meine, sondern einfach eine Softwarearchitektur,
wo einfach Parallelisierung erstes Gesetz ist. Das, weil...
Die Rechenkapazität, die schon hier mein M1 MacBook Air hat,
reicht für die 20-fache gefühlte Geschwindigkeit, wenn man es richtig macht.
Zehnfach. Mindestens.
Und da müssen die hin. Die müssen das einfach auch nutzen.
Das spart am Ende auch Batterielaufzeit, weil du deinen Rechner fünf Minuten
vorher wieder ausschalten kannst, weil du schon fertig bist und du die ganze
Zeit darauf wartest, dass irgendein scheiß Apple-Menü nicht aufgeht,
weil irgendwie gerade das falsche Programm im Vordergrund ist.
Also wirklich, das ist so dusselig. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ja, also eine klare Strategie, wo es mit dem Mac hingehen soll,
wäre im Prinzip auch mal interessant.
Also man hat das Gefühl, dass sie sich weitgehend davon abgewendet haben,
dass das nur noch so ein Beiboot ist, was man mitschleppt, weil man es irgendwie braucht.
Aber das eigentliche Geld wird natürlich auf iOS verdient, besonders mit dem iPhone.
Und die Mac Division ist halt nur noch ein Klotz am Bein.
Also so fühlt es sich zumindest an. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so ist.
Und da mal wieder mehr Gehirnschmalz reinzustecken zu stecken und sich zu sagen,
wie ist denn das Computing des nächsten Jahrhunderts oder des jetzt schon angebrochenen Jahrhunderts?
Es ist schon ein Vierteljahrhundert vorbei und es gibt irgendwie keine Vision,
wie so ein Computing jetzt mal weitergehen soll, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade AI sagt.
Und da fehlt mir auch so ein bisschen die Vision.
Ja klar, wir haben jetzt ein Hand-Off und wir haben jetzt dieses und wir haben
jetzt jenes, aber das ist auch nur so bestenfalls noch User-Login auf die gleiche Plattform.
Ja, Wishlist, ich hätte gerne Tiling. Das ist das Geilste, was ich seit Jahren
gesehen habe. So, endlich mal was Frisches.
Also ja, es gibt es seit 20 Jahren, jada, jada, aber so, baut mal Tiling ein.
So wie bei Cosmic.
Ja, also Mac, Mac, Mac. Performance, Performance, Performance.
Das wäre so meine Wunschliste Nummer 1.
Und das richtige Cover fürs iPad und weg mit dem Notch. Und dann bin ich auch
wieder ein Happy Customer.
Und Computer mit 128 GB RAM wäre mal ganz gut.
Und wo du Tiling sagst, ich habe es gerade eben schon mal versucht anzusprechen.
das Window-Management vom iPad wäre eigentlich auch mal fixenswert.
Also wenn man versucht, zwei Dinge gleichzeitig auf den Screen zu holen,
dann haut einem immer eins ab und dann willst du das von der Größe verändern
und da ist wieder einer weg.
Und es geht alles, aber es ist halt so arcanes Wissen. Man muss dann schon irgendein
Tutorial gucken, so okay, wie wann, wo muss ich, wann wohin touchen,
damit was passiert nochmal genau.
Es geht halt irgendwie schlecht ins Muscle Memory über.
Ja, also es ist so keine Ahnung.
In zwei Wochen sind wir schlauer. Hoffe ich.
Könnt ihr mal zusammen die Keynote mal wieder gucken, so wie früher.
Und schauen, ob wir uns alle aufregen oder freuen.
Können wir machen.
Mit viel Kaffee bitte, um sich einzuschlagen.
Ja, die Gefahr bestehe ich.
Obwohl die interessanten Sachen ja eigentlich im State of the Union passieren,
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, weil die Keynote ist halt auch so dieses große, gelackte,
wichtig zusammengeschnittene Video und in der State of the Union sagen sie dann
tatsächlich mal ein bisschen im Detail, was hat denn das für Auswirkungen und
was passiert denn da und wie funktioniert denn das und so.
Das finde ich in der Regel eigentlich spannender. Vor allen Dingen ist es auch
so ein Drop-off-Point, wo man sagt, okay, da will ich jetzt dann noch die Talks
dazu ... zu hören, weil ich das interessant finde. Aber gut...
Gut. Eigentlich wollte ich ja heute noch von einer anderen Erfahrung berichten,
das wurde dann aber verhindert, weil,
entschuldigen Sie nochmals, die Verzögerung wurde mir hier von Amazon mitgeteilt,
weil mir das Produkt heute nicht geliefert wurde, wie Sie es mir eigentlich zugesagt haben.
Von daher kann ich das erst später berichten.
Auch dann wäre wahrscheinlich meine Erfahrung eingeschränkt gewesen,
aber ich habe mich jetzt entschlossen, mir ein höhenverstellbares Schreibtischgestell zu kaufen.
Ist das etwas, was man auf den Schreibtisch stellt?
Nee, unter.
Unter.
Und dann zwischen Stehposition und Sitz beliebig hin und her und Speicherpunkte.
So ein Motor, der das halt hoch und runter fährt, jetzt auch nichts Weltbewegendes.
Fürs Studio oder für zu Hause?
Fürs Zuhause, weil die Studiosituation hier eine andere ist.
Also ihr seht das ja hier alle nicht. Wie ihr nicht seht, ist die Tischsituation in der Meta-Ebene,
dass hier drei große Tische zusammengestellt sind und dafür eine höhenverstellbare Lösung zu finden.
Das hatte ich tatsächlich mal eruiert und mir auch mal ein Angebot dafür machen
lassen, aber das wäre...
Sehr teuer und aufwendig gewesen, das war ich damals nicht bereit zu investieren
und mittlerweile denke ich mir so, naja,
hier sind auch so viele Dinge drauf, also diesen ganzen Apparat so in der Höhe
zu verstellen ist schwierig und dann wird man auch vor allem hier nichts finden,
mit dem alle glücklich sind.
Nein, das ist jetzt erstmal nur für den Schreibstuhl, dann werde ich mal gucken,
ob das irgendwie gut ist für das Sitzen etc., das werde ich nächstes Mal berichten.
Ich hatte mir das ja zu Hause fürs Homeoffice zugelegt, nachdem ich meinen Bandscheibenvorfall
dank Corona hatte und viel zu lange auf der Couch rumgehangen im Homeoffice
und dann musste da mal was Vernünftiges her.
Claudia nutzt das Moment täglich, die variiert also zigmal pro Tag die Höhe
zwischen Stehen und Sitzen und bei uns in der ZLB haben es auch sehr viele,
wo wir stammtmäßig jetzt mittlerweile eigentlich auch die Höhenverstellbaren
ausrollen, also das adaptiert gut.
Gibt es irgendwelche Features, die ihr da habt oder nicht habt,
die du besonders wichtig findest?
Also ich habe ja seit Jahren das damals vorrätige Modell von Ikea,
was jetzt nicht übermäßig billig, aber auch nicht übermäßig teuer war.
Was mir eigentlich von Anfang an gefehlt hat, war halt die beiden Sitzpositionen
oder die beiden Positionen speichern zu können.
Ja, Speicher ist wichtig.
Weil du sonst immer ewig dran bist und guckst dann nochmal hin und her und vor
und zurück und so weiter.
Keine Ahnung, ich hatte mich dann beholfen mit so einer Schnur,
wo Knoten dran sind und dann sieht man halt, wie weit ist die Schnur runter und so weiter.
Wie viele Knoten hat denn das Schiff?
Das wurde dann aber schnell inkompatibel zum Saugroboter und so weiter.
Also man will schon Speichermöglichkeit für Positionen haben.
Zwei würden mir jetzt reichen.
Okay, ich werde drei haben.
Ja, aber die sind wirklich wichtig, weil gerade das ergonomisch korrekte Sitzen
an einem Schreibtischstuhl, da gibt es ja immer so,
ich hatte gerade gestern wieder Schulung zur Arbeitssicherheit,
wo das dann auch immer ein Kapitel ist, mit Aufrecht und 90 Grad Winkel und so weiter.
Und da sieht das auf diesen Bildern immer so aus, als ob das alles ganz einfach und natürlich wäre.
Wenn man das aber dann wirklich mal probiert mit einem echten Tisch,
so merkt man, dass, ich illustriere das mal,
Der Platz, den man zwischen einem recht winkelig angewinkelten Arm und dem Oberschenkel
hat, der ist vielleicht mal gerade so 10 Zentimeter.
So und genau dazwischen muss perfekt die Platte liegen.
Ansonsten hast du einfach diese Winkel nicht. Das heißt, du hast da relativ wenig Spielraum.
Und das dann wiederum mit der Stuhlhöhe genau in Einklang zu bringen.
Dafür ist dann so eine abgespeicherte Position. So ich muss jetzt nicht irgendwie
10 Minuten rumfrummeln, bis ich es wieder genau getroffen habe.
ist das schon eine gute Sache.
Mir ist vor allem aufgefallen, dass ich diese Stühle, auf denen wir jetzt gerade
sitzen, ich habe ja diese HAG Capisco 8106.
Aber auch in zwei Ausführungen. Du hast die Chefvariante in Leder.
Und wir Fußvolk haben nur das mit dem schnöden Stoffbezug.
Das stimmt. Mehr Leder war nicht im Angebot.
Ich mache mal ein Bild, weil die sind wirklich toll und ungewöhnlich.
Wer die nicht kennt. Das ist ja so Büromöbelklassiker, die haben meine Aufmerksamkeit
erregt, kann ich auch mal verlinken.
HAG Kapisco 8106 ist sozusagen so einer der Bürostuhlklassiker.
und das Besondere an dem ist, dass der ja so einen sattelartigen Sitz hat,
und das bedeutet, dass man zwischen den Beinen so einen längeren Sitztiefe hat
als da, wo die Beine selber sind und der Sinn der ganzen Sache ist ja,
dass man damit abgewinkelt, also nicht mit 90 Grad sitzt, sondern dass man quasi
relativ hoch ist ist und die Beine eben so leicht schräg nach unten gehen.
Und wenn ich das halt mache...
Dann ist der Tisch halt genau jetzt 10, 20 Zentimeter zu tief, um das gut zu machen.
Also eigentlich will ich den Tisch nur höher bekommen, damit ich endlich mal
meinen Stuhl richtig benutzen kann, weil in dem Moment, wo die Beine so nach
unten abgewinkelt sind,
macht man nämlich auch automatisch die Wirbelsäule gerade oder gerade und dann
wird das alles ganz gesund.
So zumindest die Theorie. Mal schauen, ob sich das dann auch alles so entfalten wird.
Ich finde das zwischendurch dann, wenn man sich danach fühlt,
mal schnell sich hinstellen zu können, ist eigentlich auch immer ganz geil.
Das ist auch noch so ein Aspekt, von dem ich noch nicht genau weiß,
wie sehr mir das zusagen wird.
Also ich persönlich mache es jetzt nicht super oft. meistens eigentlich nur,
wenn der Staubsauger losgeht,
weil der ist genau auf 12 Uhr terminiert, wo dann eigentlich auch Mittagspause ist,
aber wenn ich in der Mitte von irgendwas bin dann stelle ich halt den Schreibtisch
hoch und mache den Stuhl zur Seite und dann muss ich halt so ein bisschen gucken, dass ich immer um den,
Staubsauger rumtänzel aber im Großen und Ganzen verbringe ich dann erstmal Zeit
im Stehen am Schreibtisch weil, ja.
Warum kommt der Stocksackroboter nicht nachts?
Weil er eigentlich die ganzen ersten Stock saugen soll und da ist auch das Schlafzimmer
dabei und dann wäre nachts schlecht.
Das stimmt.
Also das ist, aber es ist ja, es ist zumindest eine Anregung,
sich das mal zu überlegen.
Er muss ja nicht unbedingt mittags, aber ja. Ja, weiß nicht.
Gut, ich werde berichten.
Ja.
Haben wir noch was?
Keine Ahnung, gucken wir noch mal.
Ich habe noch kleinere Notizen. Ich habe noch mal reingeguckt.
Es ist noch, glaube ich, gar nicht so lange her, da haben tatsächlich Intel
und AMD, die beiden großen Hersteller von Intel-kompatiblen Chips,
sich geeinigt und haben so eine Art Interessensgruppe gebildet.
X86ecosystem.org. Wenn man da guckt auf der Webseite, dann sind da also auch
noch diverse andere Firmen im Boot.
Ehrlich gesagt nur die, die man erwarten würde, also Dell und HP und so weiter.
Microsoft natürlich. Und die haben sich jetzt tatsächlich das erste Mal wohl
relativ gut darauf geeinigt, wie es jetzt mit der Architektur dieser Plattform,
insbesondere halt im Instruction-Set weitergehen soll.
Bisher war das immer eher so eine Schlacht. Der eine führt was ein und der andere,
der hängt entweder hinterher, weil er seine Erweiterung nicht durchkriegt oder,
keine Ahnung, weil er auch nichts vorzuweisen hat oder so.
Aber inzwischen haben sie wohl gemerkt, wenn sie die X86-Plattform weiter irgendwie
am Leben erhalten wollen und nicht gegen Arm abstinken, dann müssen sie irgendwie zusammenarbeiten.
Aber das ist ja gar nichts Neues. Also hier sehe ich gerade,
dass sie im letzten Oktober ihr Einjähriges gefeiert haben.
Nee, es ist nicht neu. Was Neues ist dieses White Paper, was ich verlinkt habe,
wo sie jetzt tatsächlich,
einfach mal geschrieben haben, wie sich das jetzt vorstellt,
wie AI-Erweiterungen in ihren prozessoren kompatibel zueinander funktionieren soll,
Ob das zu irgendwas Sinnvollem führt oder nicht, das wird man dann sehen.
Gleichzeitig woanders habe ich noch gelesen, aber das habe ich jetzt hier auf
der Webseite nicht gefunden, dass sie sich geeinigt haben, insgesamt mal die
Registeranzahl im Prozessor zu verdoppeln,
was wohl tendenziell 30% Performance Improvement bringen kann,
ohne dass sie da deutlich mehr Strom mit verbrauchen müssen.
müssen halt entsprechend Platz auf dem Prozessor,
Register brauchen halt Platz, aber ja, also insgesamt sieht es wohl so aus,
als wollten die da versuchen ihren Markt so ein bisschen zu schützen, weil ganz ehrlich,
ARM setzt den schon gut zu, also das muss man einfach mal so sagen.
Ja und Apple setzt den auch ganz gut zu, also ich frage mich ja,
wie lange das mit diesem x86 überhaupt noch vorangehen kann.
Ich glaube, dass Apple, ja, Apple in unserer Welt macht natürlich einen großen Anteil aus.
Gleichzeitig ist aber so insgesamt an Computern, die von Leuten benutzt werden,
Windows, Linux, also x86-Systeme, sage ich mal, immer noch relativ weit vorne.
Weit vorne, in welcher Hinsicht weit vorne?
Einfach in der Verbreitung.
Ja, ja, klar, aber,
Dinge sind so lange vorne, bis sie hinten liegen.
Ja, ich glaube, die eigentliche Gefahr liegt eher da drin, dass das.
Dass das System Computer, Desktop oder Laptop oder wie auch immer,
PC, Mac, einfach so ein bisschen immer mehr zum Special Interest wird.
Also noch ist es so, dass viele von uns halt an Rechnern sitzen, um zu arbeiten,
aber du siehst das halt immer wieder, dass du irgendwo hinkommst,
bist in irgendeinem Kundengespräch mit irgendeinem Verkäufer und der zückt dann
das iPad raus und fängt an, im iPad den Kram einzutippeln und nicht mehr am Computer oder so.
Und dieser Trend ist natürlich insofern interessant, als dass X86 für die ultraportablen
Geräte, also im Prinzip alles, was jetzt Tablet ist oder Phone,
nichts anzubieten hat, weil sie zu viel Strom verbrauchen.
Das muss man mal so konstatieren. Laptops geht noch.
Laptops geht noch. Klar, von der Laufzeit ist immer so eine Sache.
Aber der Laptop-Markt ist zumindest für die Leute, die Laptops kaufen, der funktioniert noch.
Einigermaßen. Also wenn du, weiß ich nicht, war jetzt lange nicht dort,
aber wenn du bei Cyberport reinrennst, dann werden da eine ganze Menge PC-Laptops stehen.
Weil die Geräte werden noch verkauft. Also der Markt hat da glaube ich noch
eine ganze Menge Beharrungsvermögen.
Trotzdem ist es so, dass ich glaube, dass X86 auch insgesamt so ein Problem hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Image, die meisten Leute, die Rechner kaufen,
interessieren sich glaube ich nicht so ganz so dafür, was da jetzt für ein Prozessor drin ist.
Wenn jetzt nicht irgendwie Qualcomm und Microsoft zusammen irgendwie das schaffen,
mal eben die ganze Plattform, die sie da aus dem Boden gestampft haben,
auch aufgrund von Nicht-Funktionalität wieder abzuwirken.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, Qualcomm hat ja quasi ARM-Laptops
für Windows rausgebracht.
Windows selber hat auf ARM nicht gut funktioniert und Qualcomm hat auch noch
nicht richtig gut funktionierende Grafiktreiber dazu geliefert,
was dazu führte, dass die Leute schamweise die Geräte wieder zurück in den Laden
getragen haben und das Ganze ein wirkliches Fiasko wurde.
ja, keine Ahnung also ich finde es spannend, dass die sich zusammentun,
dass sie sich zusammenraufen weil man würde ja schon erwarten,
dass Inteler und AMD irgendwie Erzfeinde sind,
und das finde ich will schon was heißen Ja gut.
Ich meine das scheinen sie ja jetzt schon vor anderthalb Jahren Gut.
Dazu kommt dass Intel glaube ich auch jetzt mal vom Hohen Ross runtergestiegen
ist und eingesehen hat dass sie ein massives Problem haben.
Ja.
Also.
Das war das eine. In dem Zusammenhang noch ganz spannend, wir haben es glaube
ich nur am Rande erwähnt,
die Valve Steam Machine, die ja jetzt schon seit ewigen Zeiten angekündigt ist,
eigentlich schon hätte rauskommen sollen.
jetzt aber aufgrund von Speicher und also RAM und SSD-Markt irgendwie ein echtes Preisproblem hat.
Also jetzt ist der Punkt gekommen, wo Valve sie entweder massiv subventionieren
muss oder aber das ganze Projekt total einstampfen.
Also was ich gehört habe, ist es so, dass das Valve eben in der Lage war,
sich von ARM, von ARM sage ich schon, von AMD eine Kombination aus alten Chips
und alten Grafikkernen und so weiter,
einen relativ günstigen All-in-One-Chip-Grafik-CPU bauen zu lassen,
der jetzt kein Performance-Wunder ist.
Aber den AMD sowieso rumliegen hatte und nicht losgeworden ist,
weswegen ihn sie relativ günstig gekriegt haben und er auch einfach noch ganz
brauchbar Spiele laufen lassen kann.
Nur jetzt werden sie halt ganz fürchterlich von dieser RAM-SSD-Krise gebissen
und keine Ahnung, wir werden sehen, ob das Ding irgendwann rauskommt.
Den Controller, den Valve angekündigt hat, den haben sie ja rausgebracht,
der war ja irgendwie in einer Stunde ausverkauft.
und was mit diesem Headset ist, naja gut, keine Ahnung, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Tja, ankündigen, wenn man es noch nicht lieferbar hat, das ist,
funktioniert selten irgendwo mal richtig gut.
Naja, gut, ich sag mal so, wenn du deine Lieferketten im Griff hast und Apple
macht das ja im Prinzip auch immer, dass sie sagen Shipping ab November oder
irgendwas, dann kannst du das machen.
Und ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, dass das Valve auch inzwischen halbgebaute
Geräte von den Dingern hat.
Es wurde zwischendrin gerüchtet, dass sie die vielleicht als nackte Maschinen
verkaufen. Also ohne Speicher und SSD.
Also Speicher und SSD ist auch aufrüstbar bei den Teilen. Aber naja,
keine Ahnung. Wir werden sehen.
Es ist ein bisschen blöd gelaufen. Aber Valve ist halt auch kein großer Hardware.
Also gerade heute ist auf einer schwedischen Seite, also wirklich heute,
der Artikel rausgekommen, dass es gerüchtet wird, dass die Preise mittlerweile
so um 900 Dollar liegen sollen.
Das wäre dann mal deutlich mehr als eine PS5 und eine Xbox X kostet.
Ja, aber abgesehen davon, dass die wahrscheinlich im Preis auch steigen werden.
Also, naja, aber für 900 Dollar ist das Ding aber auch nicht so richtig verkaufbar.
Das ist halt das Problem, was sie haben.
Wie gesagt, Sie müssen es entweder subventionieren oder gleich ganz lassen.
Hilft nichts. Gut, das war das.
Dann würde ich sagen, sind wir auch langsam am Ende. Themen sind leer.
Ja, gerne.
Kopf auch, genau. Ich werde mir mal was überlegen, hier irgendwie,
wie ich euer Interesse einsammeln kann für Elixier. Wahrscheinlich muss ich was zusammenweiben.
Oder das habe ich jetzt ganz vergessen. Ich wollte gucken, ob ich noch irgendwo
auf meiner Plattform was habe. Naja, du willst ja schon irgendwie ein bisschen
was mit E-Mail hinterlegen.
Das muss ja auch in den Links hier sein.
Eigentlich ja schon. Mach es doch einfach. Mach es einfach.
Mach es einfach.
Mach es Otze.
Gehst ja eh nicht vor zwei ins Bett.
Genau, genau, genau. Schaut einfach mal in die Links, die wir so mitliefern
immer, wo alles drinsteht, was euch zu interessieren hat.
Zwei Flaschen Mate einkippen und dann geht das.
So, dann mache ich mal das hier. Viel Spaß dann beim Schauen der Keynote oder
wie auch immer man das jetzt nennen soll.
Die Werbevideo Nummer 1 und 2 bei der WWDC.
Und dann quatsch mal in der nächsten Sendung mal drüber, was passiert jetzt
von unserer Winsschlüssel. Oder ob.
Ja, da wird ja was passieren. So ist es.
Linux!
Bis bald. Tschüss.